in this complete game development course
you will learn how to develop a variety
of games using javascript frank's
courses are top notch and he has a
really creative way of presenting things
you are going to love this course hi
coders in this class we will use html
css and javascript to build nine
separate game development projects i
will write and explain all the code from
scratch line by line using just plain
vanilla javascript no frameworks and no
libraries we will start by learning
individual 2d game development
techniques on smaller standalone
projects and once we covered everything
we apply all of them to build a simple
mobile game simple point and shoot game
and a more advanced fast-paced 3d side
scroller with precise keyboard controls
and special visual effects my name is
frank and i'm a front-end web developer
if you want to learn even more about
game development and creative coding you
can check out my youtube channel in this
course we will learn everything you need
to know about sprite animation we will
write the javascript code that handles
seamless endlessly scrolling parallax
backgrounds we will learn how to extend
javascript classes to create a variety
of enemy types with different visuals
and different behaviors i will show you
how to implement state design pattern to
manage player states and special
abilities we will learn how to use
collision detection by color collision
between circles and between rectangles
we will add different particle effects
and many other things this class is made
out of nine separate standalone projects
and a couple of special lessons so if
you already know some of these
techniques you can skip around this
class is not for complete beginners but
if you are already comfortable with the
basics of javascript and you understand
functions for loops objects and arrays
come join me and let's build some games
in the first class we will explore two
different javascript techniques you can
use to animate sprite sheets and we will
build this project where you can choose
different player animations from the
dropdown we are giving away a lot of
free art assets you can download them in
the video description and you can use
them to follow along with this course
for more beautiful game art assets visit
this website now let's do a quick
javascript setup i will show you how
little code you need to animate
something on canvas i create a custom
variable called canvas that will hold a
reference to my actual html canvas
element i created in index.html i point
javascript towards it using
getelementbyid and i pass it id i gave
it canvas1
constant variable i call for example ctx
shortcut for context is equal to this
canvas variable from line one dot get
context and i pass it to d i could also
pass it webgl here which would give us
access to a completely different set of
drawing methods but that's for another
video
now i have all canvas 2d drawing methods
stored in my custom ctx variable and i
can call them from here for example ctx
fill rect will call a method to draw a
rectangular canvas if i console.log ctx
we can inspect this object it has some
properties which basically are global
canvas settings such as fill style that
says color of shapes we draw or font
which sets size and font family of text
we draw on canvas
this tutorial will be focused on sprite
animation we want to learn how to create
animated characters for games so we are
most interested in building canvas draw
image method which sits right
here i will explain everything you need
to know about draw image method and its
three versions in a minute it's easy
don't worry about it
before we do that i will quickly finish
canvas setup
to make sure we have correct scaling i
need to set canvas width and canvas
height by default canvas will be set to
300 x 150 pixels
and our drawings can come out distorted
that's why i will manually set it to 600
x 600 the same values i gave it in style
css
i create a custom variable called canvas
width i will use capital letters here to
make it clear this is a global variable
i set it equal to canvas from line 1 dot
width
and i set it all to 600
same width i gave it in style css
i do the same for canvas height also 600
now that we made sure scaling is correct
let's bring an image into the project
in this tutorial i want to show you two
different ways you can animate sprites
very simple one for beginners and then
more advanced more complex and flexible
way where you can just run commands like
run jump sit and it will play the
correct animation for us when you know
both you can decide which one to use
when you are building your games i want
everyone to get the same result that's
why i will be giving away this animated
sprite sheet for free today
to bring image into javascript project i
can just declare a custom variable i
call for example player image and i set
it equal to new image like this
this is a built-in image class
constructor it will create html image
element same as you would create if you
put image tag img tag in index html
markup
we can append it to our web page if you
want
but today we will just use it to store
that spreadsheet image for us so that we
can animate it with the javascript
i need to give it source
so player image variable from line 6 dot
src and i set it to path to my sprite
sheet your path might be different it
depends on how you organized your
project files
let's animate something on canvas i
create a custom function called for
example draw frame
actually let's call it animate because
this is our animation loop let's make
sure that's clear
inside animation loop first i want to
clear old paint from canvas between
every animation frame so i take ctx
variable from line 2
dot clear rectangle built-in method
it expects four arguments to specify
what area on canvas we want to clear
i want to clear the entire canvas so
from coordinates 0 0 to canvas with
canvas height
now we can draw
i will just test if everything works by
drawing a simple rectangle at position
50 50 and i give it width and height of
100 pixels
now i can call a request animation frame
built-in method which will simply run a
function we pass to it it will call that
function once
if i pass it animate the name of its
parent function from line 9 it will just
run over and over create an animation
loop
so we declared animate i also have to
call it like this and we have a black
rectangle drawn on canvas
if we don't specify fill style color of
shapes on canvas always default to black
it looks like a static image but it's
actually animating the same rectangle
over and over i can simply prove it by
creating a global variable called x
i set it to 0
and here on line 12 i replace hard coded
value with this variable and every time
animation loop runs i increase x by 1. i
told you you don't need much code to
animate something on canvas well done
you are a programmer now see you later
okay there's a bit more i can show you
let's put it back and let's use built-in
draw image method to draw our sprite
sheet on canvas draw image method is a
bit special you can pass it three or
five or nine arguments depending on how
much control do you want to have over
the image you are drawing the first
argument is always the image you want to
draw so i pass it player image variable
from line 6.
then i pass it x and y coordinates where
on canvas i want my image to be drawn
if i pass it 0 for x and 0 for y it will
be drawn from the top left corner of
canvas coordinates 0 0
it will also keep the image at the
original width and height the sprite
sheet i'm using has 10 rows and 11
columns of animation frames
it's many times larger than my canvas so
now we can only see this small part 600
times 600 pixels in the top left corner
of my sprite sheet it's 600 x 600
because that's the size
i set my canvas to
so this is the version of draw image
with only three arguments it works and
you can change x and y coordinates to
move your image around but you would
need to resize your images using some
other programs such as microsoft paint
or photoshop
but you don't have to do that because
draw image also accepts five arguments
that's its second version if you pass it
five arguments the fourth argument will
be width and fifth argument will be
height so we are now able to scale the
image up and down and we can also
stretch it vertically or horizontally if
i pass it canvas width and canvas height
it will stretch the image to match my
canvas area 600 600 pixels and since the
image is not the same ratio as my canvas
you can see the image is stretched just
a little bit let's remove the black
rectangle by commenting out line 11.
i can pass any values as width and
height and javascript will just stretch
my image based on these values
you can also change x and y to move the
entire image around
the final third version of draw image
method accepts nine arguments this gives
us the most control over the image the
first argument again is the image you
want to draw the next four arguments
determine rectangular area we want to
cut out from the source image source x
source y
source width and source height
and the last four arguments will tell
javascript where on our destination
canvas we want to draw just that cropped
out part onto
destination x destination y destination
with and destination height
these last four values basically work
the same as these four values in the
previous draw image call
i showed you the only difference is they
are not used to position and stretch the
entire image but just the area we cut
out using these arguments
i comment outline 12 but i will leave it
here for reference
and on line 13 i will add source x
source y source width and source height
arguments and i will use them to cut out
only one dock at a time
one frame from my large sprite sheet
so these four values determine area we
cut out from the original sprite sheet
and these four values determine where on
canvas we want to place that cut out
piece of image on two
if i set source x to 0
source y to 0 source width to 200 source
height to 200 we are cutting out square
200 x 200 pixels from the top left
corner
there is nothing in the area
if i change it to square 400 times 400
pixels we can see part of our dog
i can put any values here and cut out
any chunk of the original sprite sheet i
want i can also scale it stretch it i
can do whatever i want here
i create a global variable called sprite
with let's have a look at our sprite
sheet if i take width of the entire file
and divide it by number of columns i get
width of one frame
my spreadsheet is
6876 pixels wide and it has 12 columns
6876 divided by 12 is 573
i will use 575 for now because i made
the last frame a bit smaller when
assembling my sprite sheet in photoshop
and there's some margin that snuck in
sometimes when you see that your
animation is moving sideways when it
shouldn't try to fix it by adjusting
width and height by small pixel amounts
and watch what happens i will show you a
bit later what i mean it's simple you
can just ignore it for now
sprite height or height of a single
frame will be height of my entire sprite
sheet which is
5230 divided by the number of rows we
have 10 animations 10 rows so 5 230
divided by 10 is 523
on line 15 i can replace source width
and source height with sprite width and
sprite height variables i just
calculated
and now we are cropping out exactly one
frame from our sprite sheet
and in destination width and destination
height instead of stretching it to cover
the entire canvas i can also use sprite
width and sprite height variables here
and we are drawing the frame at its
original size
if you are still not clear what each of
these individual arguments passed to
draw image method does feel free to play
with it change the values and see what
happens it's quite straightforward once
you get used to it
here i'm giving it an image i want to
draw these four values specify a
rectangle area to crop out from the
original large sprite sheet and here i
am telling it where i want that cropped
out piece of my sprite sheet to be
displayed on canvas
if i set source x coordinate to 1 times
sprite width i'm jumping one frame as
this number increases i am moving to the
right jumping by the amount of sprite
width
this way i can display my animation row
frame by frame
when this number gets too high there
will be no frame there eventually
so source x argument allows us to cycle
through sprite sheet horizontally
if i want to swap between different
animations the way our spreadsheet is
structured i have to travel through it
vertically
we have source y argument for that
again starting from top would be 0 x
sprite height variable from line 9 and
that will give me the top row
in this case we have idle animation
there one times sprite height is row 2
jump animation
then there is fall animation running and
so on
traveling through the sprite sheet
vertically along the y axis switches
between different animations and we do
it by changing source y argument
traveling horizontally cycles between
individual frames of these animations
and can be done by changing value we
pass as source x argument
instead of manually changing numbers
like this let's output it to variables
i create variables called frame x and
frame y and i set them to 0 initially
then i just replace hard coded zeros
inside my draw image method with frame x
and frame y and now i can swap between
animation frames by assigning different
values to these variables
frame x cycles through frames of each
animation horizontally frame y swaps
between different animations it travels
through my sprite sheet vertically
now let's cover a very simple way you
can animate your sprites and then i will
show you proper advanced scalable
technique that is suitable for both
small and larger game projects
the simple way is this we know that
frame x variable cycles through our
spreadsheet horizontally first row in
our sprite sheet is idle animation it
has 7 frames inside animation loop on
line 18 i can say if frame x from line
10 is less than 7
increase frame x by 1 frame x plus plus
else meaning when it's equal or larger
than seven reset it back to zero
you can notice two things our animation
is blinking and it's going very fast
let's deal with it
first frame is zero so last frame is
actually position six if i change this
to six the empty frame is removed and
blinking is gone
on line 11 i can just change values of
frame y
and we are animating different rows in
the sprite sheet
problem comes when i get to frame y 4
which is row 5. we are starting from 0.
this animation has 11 frames but i'm
cycling only until frame 6 so we are not
playing the entire animation
when i get to this row we have a problem
again sitting animation has 5 frames and
we are cycling through more frames here
so now it's blinking because we are
including some empty frames
to get this to work properly every time
we want to swap between animations we
have to change frame y value on line 11
but also this hard hard-coded number 6
on line 18.
ideally it would have to be a variable
that always changes to the correct value
that reflects the number of frames for
each animation row depending which one
we are animating right now
i would solve it by having variable
called for example max frame i would
slot it here and every time i change
frame y variable i would change value of
that max frame variable from 6 to
whatever value we need here to display
all frames so 10 for this row and 4 for
this row since we are animating from
frame 0.
animation is going very fast to slow it
down we can use this simple trick
i will create a led variable called the
game frame and i set it to 0.
on line 22 inside animation loop i take
this game frame variable and for every
loop we increase it by 1. so now game
frame is endlessly increasing as our
animation loop runs over and over
on line 19 i create an if statement let
me just write it and i will explain it
when we see the whole thing
i say if game frame modulus percentage
symbol something question marks for now
is equal to 0
only then increase frame x
on line 13 i create a custom constant
variable called stagger frames whatever
value i give it it will slow down
animation by that amount
let's try 5
on line 20
i say if game frame modulus stagger
frame is 0
only then increase frame x
modulus operator percentage symbol is
also called remainder operator it
returns remainder when we divide the
first number by the second
let's say game frame is 17 and stack of
frames is 5 17 modulus 5 is 2 because 17
divided by 5 is 3 that gives us 15 and
remainder to 17 is
2. remainder operator simply divides the
first operand by the second one and
returns the remainder here i am checking
if the remainder is zero
game frame is ever increase in the
number and stagger frames is always 5.
this statement will return remainder 0
and be true every 5 frames
so because i set stagger frames to 5
this code block on line 20 will run
every 5 frames slowing down our
animation 5 times
new frame in our sprite sheet will only
be served every time the main animation
loop runs 5 times
i can also slow it just by 2.
0 here will stop animating the higher
the number you use here as stagger
frames the slower the animation will be
let's leave it at 5 for now i think it
looks good for most animations
as i said when i change frame y to 4 if
i want to display all frames in my
animation i also have to change 6 here
on line 21 to number 9.
for shorter animation rows like this
sitting animation it has only 5 frames
so i have to change this number to 4.
so now we have a way to swap between
animations but we always have to change
two values
let's refactor this code and let me show
you more advanced sprite animation
method that allows us swooping between
different animation states by changing
just one value we are venturing into a
bit more advanced territory if you are
new to javascript don't worry if it
takes you a bit longer to understand
what i'm about to show you it becomes
easier with practice we all started
somewhere
i delete code between lines 20 and 23 we
used it to cycle between animation
frames horizontally in this more
advanced method we will do it
differently
i set frame y to zero that's my top row
idle animation
i also delete lines 17 and 18. they are
commented out anyway
let's clean this up
inside animation loop on line 17 i
create a let variable called for example
position its job will be to cycle
through horizontal sprite sheets but in
a different way we will need this later
i take a game frame variable from line
12. this variable is increasing over and
over on line 20 as animation loop runs i
divide it by stagger frames variable
from line 13
and i wrap all of this in math.floor to
get rid of potential decimal points i
want this value to be only integers
whole numbers without decimal points
then i take this entire value and i do
remainder operator and six
six is here because i'm doing idle
animation which has six frames counting
from zero this line of code is not the
easiest thing to wrap your head around i
said this would be slightly more
advanced don't worry if you're
struggling to read this this is not
beginner level javascript anymore what's
happening here on line 17
game frame divided by stagger frames
means we will have to increase game
frame 5 times before we get to 1
because as game frame variable increases
1 divided by 5 is 0.2 2 divided by 5 is
0.4 3 divided by 5 is 0.6
game frame 4 divided by stagger frames 5
is 0.8 and only when we get to game
frame 5 divided by stagger frame 5 we
get value of 1 here
so as game frame cycled from 1 2 3 4 5
by dividing game frame by stagger frames
we go to 0 0.2 0.4 0.6 and 0.8
all of these values were turned into
zeros because it's wrapped in mastered
floor it took five animation loops five
increases of game frame variable to get
the number one here when this is 1
1 modulus 6 is 1 because 1 divided by 6
is a 0 and remainder from 0 to 1 is 1.
basically this value increases by 1
every time game frame variable increases
by 5 slowing or staggering our animation
5 times making it 5 times slower
we are using math.floor removing decimal
points from these
divisions for the first five frames we
get zero modulus six which is zero then
this calculation increases to one for
the next five frames one modulus six is
one
then two modulus six is a two 3 modulus
6 is 3 and so on
position variable increases until it
reaches 6. 6 modulus 6 is 0 7 modulus 6
is 1 8 modulus 6 is remainder 2 and so
on this calculation makes sure position
variable only cycles between a 0 and
this number
i appreciate that this calculation is
quite complex this is not course in
advanced mathematics and logic so for
now just take this little formula here
and believe me when i say it works don't
worry about understanding it completely
we are focusing on javascript today
being able to understand this
calculation has nothing to do with your
ability to be good with javascript these
are two unrelated skills
on line 18 i take frame x variable from
line 10
and i set it equal to sprite width from
line 8
and i multiplied by this position
variable we just calculated on line 17.
as i said this position variable will
cycle between 0
and number we put here
first row in my sprite sheet has 7
frames starting from 0 frame x will be
cycling through these values
horizontally
on line 19 inside the draw image i
remove sprite width because width of our
sprites is already accounted for inside
my frame x variable on line 18.
i misspelled stagger frames on line 17.
when i fix this small typo we can see
this is working and we are animating row
1 in our sprite sheet
don't feel that you need to fully
understand this calculation online 17 to
be good at javascript i did not come up
with this formula tricks like this are
usually figured out by someone much
smarter than me we can just use them and
they will work for us i could have
achieved the same result using a bit
more code
and simple more readable calculations
this is more complex and hard to read
for beginners because it's such a short
calculation it's kind of a neat trick to
use this but it's not a necessity i like
it because it makes the code look clean
and compact
i can still change value of stagger
frames variable on line 15 and it will
slow down or speed up my animation
this is really nice code base to animate
any sprite sheet but it can be done even
better to swap between animations i
still have to change frame y variable on
line 11 and i have to make sure that
this value on line 17 sets the correct
amount of frames per row to make sure we
don't have any empty frames or that we
are animating all available frames from
that particular row depending on what
animation we are currently drawing
i would like to have code structure like
this
some kind of data array called for
example sprite animations that contains
objects
each object's name in this array is the
same as the name of that particular
animation it holds data for so for
example idle jump run and so on
each of these objects can contain
additional data for example for
irregular sprites it can be pixel values
for width and height that can be
different for each frame and mainly it
will contain locations array
this location array will hold a set of
javascript objects and each of these
objects will have x and y property
each of these objects represents one
frame in that particular animation
and its x and y properties will be
coordinates we need if we want to use
draw method to cut out this particular
frame from the sprite sheet
that way we can access any frame we want
anytime by directly targeting positions
in this array i can just cycle through
this location array with a for loop and
it will always play the entire animation
for me without the need to set up number
of frames each animation has each time
it will know how many frames that
animation has based on the number of
objects in this location array
each object will be one frame
so how do we create a data structure
like this with javascript and how do we
map it correctly to match our sprite
sheet let me show you
on line 14 i create a custom constant
variable i call for example sprite
animations and i set it equal to an
empty array
this will serve as the main container to
hold all data for all my animations
i will create another variable i call
animation states
this will also be an array and i will
use it as a place where i can create
kind of a simple map that will match my
docs sprite sheet
i will go through my sprite sheet row by
row from top to bottom for every
animation row in my sprite sheet i will
create an object like this
with two properties name property will
be whatever i want to call that
animation row so for the first row
let's call it idle
and i will also need frames property i
check my sprite sheet and i see that
idle animation is made out of 7 frames
the second row i will call jump
animation and it has 7 frames i will
create an object like this for every row
in my sprite sheet going from top to
bottom but before i do that let's check
if it works
on line 15 i have this animation states
array which currently contains two
objects one for idle and one for jump
animation
i could have also given it more
properties but this sprite sheet is not
irregular so name and frames properties
is all i need to map coordinates for
each animation frame
i take animation states array and i call
build in array for each method for each
method execute provided function once
for each array element i will do es6
syntax here this is so called arrow
function
it's a simplified syntax to write
function expression in javascript
i can skip function keyword here and i
just create brackets where arguments i
pass to this callback function go with
for each the first argument we pass to
it is just a variable that will
represent each element in the array as
we are cycling through it
i will call it state as for each method
runs state will first represent this
object then this object and so on if we
add more
i'm simply saying inside this callback
function i'm about to write refer to
these objects as state so this name
property can be accessed as state dot
name for example
i'll also pass it second argument i call
index
index is another built-in feature of for
each array method it simply stores
number of each element as we cycle
through the array so this first object
will have index 0
this will have index 1 and so on i
expect you understand basic array
manipulation with javascript and
fundamental methods like for each but i
still wanted to explain in case we have
some beginners here
so this callback function will run for
each element in my animation states
array now i want to run through
animation states and create data
structure like this
that maps my sprite sheet and
coordinates for each frame
i create lead variable called frames and
i set it equal to an object inside i
will have property called loc location
that will be an empty array for now
i will create a for loop that will cycle
through state dot frames property so for
idle animation it will run seven times
as i set it here on line 18.
every time this for loop runs i want to
calculate x and y coordinates of that
animation frame from my sprite sheet and
i want to place them inside location
array on line 27
how do i calculate that
i create a temporary variable called
position x and it will be equal to j
variable from the for loop times sprite
width that i set to 575 pixels earlier
as the for loop runs and j increases
position x will be calculated for each
frame
i will also need position y which will
be index from line 25 times sprite
height we declared sprite height earlier
and we set it equal to 523 pixels to
match our sprite sheet
position y will be the same for all
seven frames of idle animation when for
each method moves to the second
animation object here
index will increase and for that
animation row different position y will
be calculated
this might be quite a lot going on if
you are a beginner this is more advanced
than the first sprite animation method
don't feel discouraged if you are
struggling to follow it takes time and
practice it wasn't easy for any of us at
first
so this for loop calculates position x
and position y for each frame as it
cycles through my sprite sheet
every time we calculate x and y i take
frames dot location array from line 27
and i use push method
i create another small object here on a
fly
it has x property set to position x from
line 30 and y property set to position y
from line 31 i push these values into my
location array on line 27
so this for loop will run through all
the frames in one row
in this case seven times and once we
create seven objects with x and y
coordinates and push them into location
array i take sprite animations array
from line 14 and i create a new key in
there
i will create something called key value
pair key is the name of the property
value is the value of that property
so i'm taking sprite animations array
from line 14 and i'm passing it state
dot name which will first refer to idle
then to jump as for each method runs
through animation states array
i'm saying create a new key new property
in sprite animations array call it idle
and its value will be frames from line
27 frames object contains locations
array which i just filled with seven
objects that contain x and y properties
for each frame in this animation
that's it we created the data structure
that maps locations in my sprite sheet i
can console log it now
i can see i made a typo here on line 29
you probably noticed it already
this should be j not s
so now i'm going to consoling animation
states from line 15 that's fine but what
i actually want to see is sprite
animations array from line 14 which we
just created and filled with data
you can see that my sprite animations
contains two properties called idle and
jump
if i look inside each contains a
location array from line 27 and number
of elements in that array corresponds to
frames i declared for each animation
each of these values was calculated here
on lines 30 and 31 you can see that all
y coordinates for idle are 0 and for
jump animation vertical y coordinate is
523
as we moved on to the second row in our
sprite sheet
now i can replace hard-coded number six
here on line 40 with length of this
location's arrays
i access this location array by
targeting sprite animations dot lock
actually no i skipped one level i need
to specify if i want location array for
idle or jump
let's just hard code idle here for a
moment and i want length of this array
remember i am just replacing hard coded
number six that was here so dot length
and that's it now it's dynamic i can add
animations with 4 or 15 frames per row
or however many i want and it will still
work with no blank or left out animation
frames here i am accessing sprite
animations from line 14
idle
location dot length
inside animation loop we are still
calculating frames using frame x and
frame y variables from lines 10 and 11.
we don't need these anymore because now
we have the exact coordinates stored in
locations array
i delete lines 10 and 11.
on line 40 i add let keyword in front of
frame x
and i will declare frame y variable here
frame y is just the value we can see
here so i can access it by saying sprite
animations idle
dot location at index position from line
39 dot y
i could do the same thing for frame x or
i can just leave it as is both will work
let's replace idle with a jump
it breaks
notice that row 1 with idle animation
was working and row 2 doesn't which
suggests something is wrong with how we
draw vertical position
inside the draw image on line 43 i
remove sprite width value from source y
argument we don't need it anymore as
frame y contains complete already
calculated coordinate
now i can go back inside animation
states array and i add data for all the
remaining animations
it's important to understand that you
can't skip rows here you have to go row
by row from top to bottom to match your
sprite sheet because vertical y
coordinate is tied to index in for each
method
i add full animation with 9 frames
run animation has 9 frames
dizzy 11 frames
seat has only 5 frames
roll seven frames and so on
i also need to make sure there is comma
between every object
if i try fall i can blink in
there must be an empty frame
full animation is actually only 7 frames
if i put less here we play only part of
animation if i put more here we get
blinking because some frames are empty
run animation works
dizzy works
seat animation works as well
you can see seed animation has 5 frames
and this animation has 11 frames and i
can swap between them easily without
having to manually change number of
frames like we did before
roll animation works
byte animation works let's go back to
idle
putting hard-coded text here like this
is not ideal of course i go up to line
10 and i create a variable called player
state
i set it to run initially
down on line 71 and 73 i replace idle
with this new player state variable
now i can swap between animations here
on line 10.
so it works
jump works
full works
in index html i create a new div with a
class of controls inside there will be a
select element with an id of animations
and name animations
label for animations will say choose
animation
i give it some options that match names
we gave to animations in script js file
in style css i target controls and i
give it position absolute set index 10
top 50 pixels
and transform translate x minus 50
to center it horizontally
i take controls select and option and i
increase their font size to 25 pixels
i can also remove the border around my
canvas
i want animations to change when i
choose different value in this drop down
in script js i take player state from
line 10
and i put it up top on line 1.
i create a constant variable called
drop-down and i point it towards this
new select element with id of animations
i take drop down and call add event
listener on it i will listen for change
event
every time its value changes
we will take player state from line 1
and since we are inside callback
function on event listener we have
access to event object i'm referring to
it as e event object has target property
target is simply referring to an element
that was clicked and it has value
property because i have added values
myself
whenever any of these option elements in
my drop down is clicked player state
variable will be set to its value
attribute
now i can easily swap between different
animations in my sprite sheet just by
selecting different options in a drop
down
parallax scrolling is when background
images move past the camera slower than
the foreground creating an illusion of
depth in a 2d space
this is what my game looks without it
and this is what it looks with parallax
which one do you prefer
today we are learning about vanilla
javascript game development for
beginners and by the end of this video
you will have deep understanding about
endlessly scrolling backgrounds and how
to add parallax effect to your games and
websites when we have full control of
individual layers we can match scroll
speed to different actions our game
character takes for example my dog
character can sit down and the game
stops moving or it can do this rolling
attack and the game speeds up art assets
for this episode were created by this
amazing artist check out their website
for more if you want what is the easiest
way to create endlessly scrolling
backgrounds how to make different layers
move at different speeds to create
parallax effect how to make scroll speed
dynamics so we can easily change it we
will learn all of that and more let's
bring our coding skills one step further
today together and have some fun with
plain vanilla javascript this tutorial
is for beginners let's go click the like
please
[Music]
i create a basic web page markup in
document head i use link tag to include
my style css file
we will use it to position canvas at the
bottom of document body i place my
script dark script.js file will contain
all functionality and logic for our
project
i also create html canvas element with
an id of canvas 1.
it will be our main project area and we
will draw on it with javascript
in style css i take bodytalk and i set
its background to black
canvas will be set to position absolute
border 3 pixels solid white
width of 800 pixels height 700 pixels
i do transform translate minus 50 for x
axis and minus fifty percent for y axis
and then i offset the top by fifty
percent and left by fifty percent this
will center my canvas in the middle of
the page both vertically and
horizontally
in script.js i create a custom variable
called canvas and i point it towards my
html canvas element by id canvas 1.
ctx shortcut for context will take this
canvas variable from line 1 and it will
call get context built-in method on it
getcontext can only be called on a
variable that holds a reference to
canvas element and when i pass it
argument that says 2d it will create an
instance of built-in canvas 2d api
object that contains all properties and
drawing methods we will need today i
need to make sure we have the correct
scaling because if you don't set canvas
width and height it will default to 300
x 150 pixels
i create a variable i call canvas
underscore with all capitals to make it
clear it's a global variable
i set it equal to canvas from line 1 dot
width which will access with attribute
on html canvas element we created in
index html
and
i set all to 800 pixels the same value
we gave canvas with in style css
i do the same thing for height canvas
underscore height is equal to canvas dot
height is equal to 700 pixels
this is how you set up most canvas
projects now we have our drawing board
ready and we can focus on building
parallax effect
i want the scroll speed to be dynamic
tied to a variable so that in our game
we can speed up or slow down using
special moves with our character to
control scrolling speed i will declare a
global variable called gamespeed and i
will initially set it to for example 5.
notice i didn't use const keyword here i
used let that keyword in javascript is
used to declare variables that can be
reassigned to different values later i
will need this to be able to dynamically
change scrolling speed
it's time to bring images to the project
art for this episode was created by this
artist i really like his art style you
can download them in the video
description you can use these images for
learning purposes for commercial
projects you will have to purchase a
full license from his website this
effect will also work with any other
image but maybe you first want to use
the same files i'm using so that you get
the same result and don't have to worry
about calculating different width and
height or making sure your layers match
once you fully understand the code from
today's lesson it will be easy to switch
the images and adjust values so that the
code base works with your own files the
images are very large if you experience
any lagging or frame drops making images
smaller will significantly improve
performance i kept them large on purpose
so that we get nice clean visuals but
especially if you are creating a mobile
game these images can be much smaller
you can download the project files in
the video description our background
will have 5 layers it is perfect to
demonstrate seamless parallax scrolling
for games this is one of my favorite 2d
game artists if you want you can go and
check out his website i will leave a
link in the video description he offers
some free art assets you can play with
and used in your games but if you want
something a bit more special his prices
are very affordable there aren't many 2d
game artists out there so if you can
help me out to support them and buy some
of their assets for your projects it
will help us to make our games unique
and by purchasing from and supporting
our artists they can make more beautiful
game assets for us
to bring image into our canvas project
is very simple with javascript i create
a constant variable called background
layer 1 and i set it equal to new image
this is built in image class constructor
it simply creates an image element we
can use append child built in javascript
method and it would slot image tag img
tag into our html file same as if we
wrote that dark in index html ourselves
we can also choose not to append it and
it will stay hidden and it will just
store the image for us
image constructor has the same
functionality as the
document.createelement
img we are simply creating html image
element and saving it in this variable
at first that image element is blank so
i access its source property and i set
it equal to layer 1.png
for you the path might be different
depending on how you structured your
project files and folders i left my
image files in the same folder with my
script file for now we have 5 layers 5
different images so let's do the same
thing for all of them to bring them into
the project
let's create animation loop i create a
custom function called for example
animate it will contain all the code i
need to draw my backgrounds
i will be calling it over and over to
create animation
let's start by calling
image built in canvas method this method
will take image and it will draw it on
canvas the first argument i pass it is
the image i want to draw so background
layer 1 from line 7.
i want to draw it at coordinates 0 0 so
from the top left corner of canvas
then i call build in the request
animation frame function and i pass it
animate the name of its parent function
from line 18.
this way animate will run over and over
creating my animation loop
on line 19 i need to call draw image
from my ctx variable from line 2.
background layer 1 image is not the best
one to use as an example let's try layer
two
layer three
four
five
let's do this at first with layer four
to see exactly what's going on and then
we can throw in all the other layers it
looks like a static image but it's
actually animating over and over let me
show you on line 18 i create a variable
called x and i set it to 0. on line 21
inside draw image method i replace
hardcoded0 with this x variable and
every time animation loop runs i
decrease x by 1. this will make our
image move to the left in a negative
direction on horizontal x-axis the
reason the image is being smudged like
this is because we can see all previous
frames we can see old paint if we want
to see only the current animation frame
we need to delete old paint i use built
in clear rectangle method it expects
four arguments to determine what part of
canvas i want to delete i want to clear
the entire canvas so from coordinates to
0 0 to canvas width canvas height now
old paint is being deleted and we can
only see the current animation frame
image is moving to the left by 1 pixel
per frame
on line 5 we declare the gamespeed
variable so down here on line 23 i can
say x minus equals gamespeed and now
scrolling of our game is attached to
this gamespeed variable if i do 15 it
moves much faster
as you can see the background just moves
endlessly to the left and eventually it
leaves canvas empty
these images were specifically crafted
for endlessly scrolling games and they
are seamless it means you can stack them
next to each other and it will look like
it's one repeating image i need to
somehow detect when my image has moved
off screen and i need to reset it so it
can scroll again
let's try it what if i say if x is less
than minus 1000 pixels
set it back to zero
else x minus equals game speed i
increase game speed to 15 here on line
5. you can see the image is reset in but
we can clearly see the jump when the
reset happens
let's try 1600 on line 23 still it jumps
i know that images we are using today
are 2 400 pixels wide so what if i use
2400 pixels here
and i also reset x to 2400
now we have this image that is 2400
pixels wide scrolling endlessly over the
canvas
and there is this black empty space that
is also 2 400 pixels wide
the trick people use is to simply draw
the same image twice and always reset it
the one that has moved off screen so
that it's available to scroll again and
canvas is never empty i will show you
exactly what's going on using two
separate x variables one for each image
and then we will optimize it once we
fully understand what's going on
on line 18 i have x variable which will
serve as horizontal position for one of
my background images
i will create variable i call for
example x2
that's for the position of my second
identical image
x will start at position 0
and on lines 24 and 25 i have my reset
checks to make sure it cycles around
endlessly
x2 will start where the first image ends
since my images are 2400 pixels wide x2
will be 2400 images we are using today
are very large you might experience
frame drops and login if you do you can
make them smaller but maybe if you can
just follow along with me till the end
and then refactor your code and image
files for performance just to make sure
we are looking at the same numbers at
first
it makes it easier for you to debug your
code if it's the same as mine
once you fully understand this technique
you can use it for any image size and
any scroll direction your game needs
on line 24 i just call draw image again
for the same identical image but instead
of drawing it at position x from line 18
we will draw it at position x 2 from
line 19 like this
i also need to reset x2 the same way i'm
resetting x this is so called spaghetti
code we have some code repetition here
and it doesn't look very clean yet i'm
just doing it for complete clarity to
show you what's going on we will
refactor it later you will notice we
have one problem when we do it this way
but don't worry we will optimize it and
fix everything i want even beginners to
understand now i can see some frame
drops because my images are large but i
only see it on my screen recording
software it still runs smooth in my
browser don't worry about the frame
drops at this stage it can be easily
fixed by making our images smaller let's
focus on the code first and make sure we
understand it you might notice there is
a gap between my images
what's happening now i have image 1
drawn at position x from line 18 and i
have image 2 drawn at position x2 from
line 19.
the problem with this technique is that
my images ignore each other they reset
based on two different variables x and
x2 these variables are completely
disconnected so if width of my image is
not divisible by gamespeed variable
it can actually happen that this gap
between images will grow larger or
smaller over time and we really don't
want that we want endlessly scrolling
seamless background let's deal with it
step by step so what's this gap between
my images why is it there and how do i
offset my images to get rid of it part
of the gap is my game speed because
these if statements that reset x and x2
happen independently of each other we
have situations where x resets and x2
will move 15 pixels to the left for that
frame 15 pixels because that's what my
gamespeed variable is set to on line 5
at the moment they never reset at the
same time because one of them is always
visible on canvas so when x resets image
1 resets on line 25 or when x2 image 2
resets on line 27 i need to offset the
other one by the amount of game speed to
account for the fact that for that frame
the other image kept moving while the
other one was reset in
gap is smaller now but there is still a
gap
game speed is 15 pixels per frame and my
images reset when their x position is
less than minus 2 2400
so unless 2400 which is my image width
is divisible by the current speed with
no remainder there will always be some
leftover pixels creating a gap
this gap could even grow larger and
larger as the scrolling and resetting
continues some people deal with it by
only allowing their game speed to be
certain values so that image width is
always divisible by game speed without
any remainder but we don't want this
limitation we want our game speed to be
fully dynamic maybe you want your game
to slowly go faster and faster as player
progresses to more and more difficult
levels or maybe you want to have special
moves in your game and when player
performs these moves you want them to
affect speed of scrolling like i do with
this role attack for example
to do this we just need to make sure
that our x and x2 reset statements check
position of the other image before they
reset
and they offset its new position based
on the current position of the other
image
that way even when gap is somehow
created it auto corrects itself next
time around during the next reset
i do it by accounting for the current x2
position in my x reset check on line 25
and i account for current x position in
my x2 reset check on line 27.
keep in mind that when these reset
checks happen x or x2 are small numbers
somewhere around 0 at that point this
might be a bit tricky to visualize and i
know that some of you are already saying
frank what are you doing there is much
simpler way to reset endlessly scrolling
backgrounds using just one variable
there is no need for this x2 variable
there is no need for all this offsetting
by speed and position of the other image
to synchronize them it can be done with
much less code and it is so simple and
if you already realize that well done
you are good let me know in the comments
if you are one of those people i went
through all of this to show you my
process and to actually show you how it
works i didn't realize it can be done
with one variable until i got to this
stage when i was building the initial
prototype also i think everything we
have done so far is really good for
beginners to see what's going on and how
this trick is achieved we will clean
this all up and optimize everything but
before we do that let's animate all
layers and make them move at different
speeds
parallax effect is when foreground layer
moves faster than the background layer
it creates kind of a 3d effect illusion
of depth in a 2d space it can be used in
games but it also looks really nice on
websites in our project we will have 5
layers 5 images and i want each one to
move at a different speed at the same
time i want all the layers to be tied to
the same gamespeed variable so that when
player performs special move for example
the speed of all five layers is affected
proportionately how do we do that let me
show you
first let's check if all five layers are
animated correctly
everything is working perfect so how do
i animate all of these layers at the
same time i guess i could just copy draw
image on lines 23 and 24 and duplicate
it for all 5 layers then i would have to
create a separate reset checks for their
x and x 2 positions to make sure they
scroll at the different speeds it's
possible to do that but there will be a
lot of code repetition let's do it in a
clean way
i delete x and x2 variable from line 18
and 19 i also delete all this code
between lines 20 and 25.
i will use javascript classes to create
a blueprint for a layer object then i
create five instances of that layer
class one for each of my five layers i
will put all of them inside an array and
i will be cycling through that array to
update and draw them it might sound
complicated if you never used the
javascript classes before but don't
worry i will explain everything it's
actually quite simple
javascript classes are used when you
want to create many similar objects in
our case we will create five image layer
objects javascript class is a blueprint
i will define it and then whenever i
call it it will create one instance of
that object based on my custom blueprint
when i say it creates similar objects i
mean these layer objects will have
shared properties and methods but some
of the properties will have different
values they will all have the same width
of 2400 pixels each layer object will
also have image and speed property but
each layer will have different image
assigned to it and different speed value
that's what it means when i say similar
same properties but maybe different
values let me show you how simple it is
step by step we define class by using
class keyword followed by custom name of
that class starting with a capital
letter i will call my custom class layer
for example each javascript class has
one mandatory method called constructor
in object-oriented programming when you
say method all it means is function
attached to an object method is just a
function so this special mandatory
constructor method has only one job
whenever our class is called later
constructor will trigger itself it will
create one new blank object and it will
assign values and properties to that new
blank object based on blueprint inside
the constructor constructor runs only
once per object every time javascript
class is called using the new keyword i
will show you in a minute
my constructor will expect two arguments
image we want to assign to that layer
and speed modifier because i want each
layer to scroll at slightly different
speed
we will pass these arguments from the
outside when we create our five layer
objects
i will show you in a minute for now
let's finish our blueprint the syntax
might be a bit strange for you if you
are new to object oriented programming
each layer object will have horizontal x
coordinate that starts at position 0. i
say this dot x because my layer class
will create many similar objects so i'm
saying here on line 20 set x property on
this particular object you are creating
right now to zero
because we are inside blueprint that
will trigger every time we call our
class to create an object
i will also have vertical y coordinate
that will be set to zero
all our layers will have the same width
of 2400 pixels
height will be 700 pixels for all my
layers
x2 coordinate will be where we draw the
second image the second image needs to
start where my first image ends so at
the horizontal position 2400 pixels
i know i said we could do this without
x2 property using just one variable let
me just recreate what we had before as a
class and then we optimize it together i
want to do this step by step for clarity
this dot image equals image this
declaration is a bit different what i'm
doing here i'm telling my constructor
create property called image on this new
object you are creating right now and
set it to image we pass as argument on
line 19. i will show you how to pass
arguments to constructor when the class
is complete
i will do the same now with this dot
speed modifier it equals the speed
modifier passed on line 19 as an
argument to my class constructor
this dot speed will be how fast is my
image layer moving i will calculate it
by taking my global game speed variable
and i multiplied times this dot speed
modifier from line 26
doing this will allow me to pass
different speed modifier value for each
of my five layers
and that way each layer will move at a
different speed but it will still be
tied to my global game speed
you will see in a minute my layer object
will also have access to custom method i
call for example update its job will be
to move layers horizontally by changing
their disk dot x and this dot x2
properties from lines 20 and 24 and it
will reset them when the layers move off
screen the same way we did it before we
are doing the same thing we had before
but this time we are wrapping it in a
reusable class syntax so that we can do
all of this at the same time for all 5
layers
we will also have a method i call for
example draw its job will be to take
information about this layer object and
to draw it on canvas every time update
method runs to change horizontal x
position draw will run again to redraw
the image after the new position
to make sure my game speed is dynamic
and always reacting to the current value
of my global gamespeed variable from
line 10 i need to recalculate this dot
speed like this
if you want your game to have a constant
never changing scrolling speed you don't
need to do this line of code
now i just say if this dot x from line
20 is less or equal to minus this dot
width from line 22 so minus 2 400 pixels
then set this.x to this dot width plus
offset it by the current position of my
x2 minus this.speed
i'm just recreating the same thing we
did before i explained why i'm
offsetting it by x2 and speed it is to
make sure there is no gap between my
images
i copy this entire code block and i do
the same thing for this dot x2 property
from line 24.
so this.x needs to be offset by the
current value of x2 and this.x2 needs to
be offset by the current value of this
dot x
if they are not resetting i just want my
x property to decrease by the amount of
this dot speed from line 27 to make my
background layer move to the left i will
wrap it in method floor to make sure we
have no decimal points in there
not sure if this is a good idea let's
see a bit later
i do the same thing for this.x2 this can
be optimized and simplified and we will
do it in a minute
now i can take this newly updated x and
x2 coordinates and i draw two identical
images next to each other like we did
before
so draw image built in canvas method
i pass it distort image from line 25
this dot x and this dot y
this dot width and distort height
then i draw the same image but i will
draw it at this.x2 horizontal coordinate
like we did before
and that's it layer class is complete we
have a blueprint inside the constructor
and my layer objects have access to
custom update and draw methods
now i can create a new constant variable
i call for example layer 4 and i set it
equal to new layer like this the new
keyword is a special command in
javascript it will look for class with
that name in our code and it will
trigger its constructor
on line 19 i can see that my layer
constructor expects two arguments image
and speed modifier
i need to pass them here when i'm
creating an instance of my class
so i will pass it background layer 4
variable as image
and speed modifier will be maybe 0.5 i
want this layer to be moving at half of
my game speed so if my game speed is 10
pixels this layer will be moving at 5
pixels per frame let's test it
so here on line 46 i call my layer class
constructor from line 19.
it created one new blank object for me
and assigned it properties and values i
defined in my blueprint between lines 20
and 27
then it saved that new layer object
inside this layer 4 variable so this is
how you create an instance of your
custom javascript class as we know my
layer class has access to update method
from line 29 and to draw method from
line 40.
i can just go inside my animation loop i
can take layer 4 variable from line 46
and i can call update and draw on it
like this
and here we go we refactored our image
layers into javascript class and now
it's very easy to work with it i can
pass it different speed modifier on line
46 to make it move at a different speed
that speed is still relative to my
global game speed variable from line 5
because i keep track of that on line 30
inside update method
i create variables for all my five
layers i will pass different images to
each one
i could just call their update and draw
methods by duplicating lines 54 and 55
like this
now i'm drawing layer 4 and layer 5 but
there would be a lot of code repetition
if i did it for all 5 layers if i change
speed modifier value i pass the layer
class constructor on line 50 you can see
their relative speed changes and we have
parallax effect awesome it is because
that speed modifier takes game speed and
adjusts it by multiplying game speed
from line 5 times this modifier value
at first it happens on line 27 when the
new object is created then it happens on
line 30 whenever update method runs to
make sure we can change global game
speed dynamically which we will do in a
minute then we are just using this dot
speed property to recalculate horizontal
x position of our background images here
on lines 37 and 38 and this is how you
make your layers scroll at different
speeds but still tie them together by
using global game speed variable
inside my animation loop i can just call
update and draw for all five layer
objects but i don't want any code
repetition i create a new variable i
call for example game objects and i set
it equal to an array
i put layer one variable from line 46 in
there layer two three four five
now i have all five layers inside a
single array so on line 56 i take this
game objects array and i call built in
for each array method for each method
we'll simply run through all elements in
the array and it will apply whatever
callback function i give it to each of
these elements each of the layers
first i need to declare how i want to
refer to individual objects in game
objects array within my for each
callback
i will refer to them as object for
example i'm doing es6 arrow function
syntax here where you can omit function
keyword
so for each layer object in my game
objects array i will call their
associated update and draw methods like
this
here we go we are drawing all five
layers now awesome let's pass each layer
a different speed modifier to create
proper parallax effect 0.2 0.4 0.6 0.8
and 1.
now each layer moves at different speed
but they are all still relative to our
global game speed variable from line 5.
if i change global game speed variable
it will affect all 5 image layers
proportionately because their speed is
calculated by multiplying game speed
times speed modifier
if you get any frame drops at this point
it is because we are using 5 images that
are 2 400 x 700 pixels you will get much
better performance if you make the
images smaller in photoshop or some
other graphics editor
as you can see i can change my game
speed to any value and parallax
background will still scroll based on
that
i want to allow my users to easily
change scroll speed in index html i
create a div with an id of container
inside i will have paragraph tag that
will say gamespeed colon and span
element with an id of show game speed
this will show real time value of
gamespeed variable
i create html input element with type
properties set to range
min value will be 0 max value will be 20
starting value will be 5
class will be slider for example and id
slider as well
i put html canvas element inside the
container
in style css i take container
i give it position absolute with 800
pixels
i center it in the middle of the page
using transform translate i set canvas
to position relative so that it aligns
with container i put border on the
container so we see where it is
input with an id of slider will have
width of hundred percent text color
white okay that doesn't work i take
paragraph tag and i move text color
there
on container i set font size to 25
pixels
and i remove border
in script js i create a new constant
variable i call for example slider and i
point javascript towards my new slider
element with getelementbyid
on the first page load i will set slider
value property which is
here
to gamespeed variable from line 5.
then i take hold of this span element
with id of showgamespeed and i save it
in a variable i call showgamespeed as
well
on the first page load i set its inner
html equal to the current value of
gamespeed variable from line 5.
if i change value of gamespeed and
reload page you can see it works
now i want to change scrolling speed of
my layers when i click this slider to do
that i need to connect it to gamespeed
variable from line 5.
on line 22 i take slider from line 18
and i call at event listener we will
listen for change event and in callback
function whenever change event occurs on
the slider which means whenever user
clicks on it to change its value i will
run some code callback function on event
listener has access to its built-in
event object i will refer to it as e
here
i can refer to it however i want
javascript knows that the first argument
passed the callback function on event
listener refers to this built-in event
object
if i console this e you can see it gets
console locked every time change event
occurs on slider and it contains a lot
of useful information about that event
right now i'm interested in its target
property which references target of this
change event
which is html input element with an id
of slider
when it gives me that i can access its
current value attribute which is exactly
what i need if i console.log
e.target.value
it will give me the current value of
this slider input element
i set minimum value to 0 and maximum to
20 here
all i have to do now is take gamespeed
variable from line 5
and i set it equal to e dot target.value
like this
and i will also update innerhtml in
showgamespeedspan
so that it displays the correct current
speed for us
now i can change scroll speed of my
layers by clicking on slider
if i change it to max 50 we can get it
to scroll really fast i hope your
computer can handle that these images
are too large
let's set max value back to 20.
you probably already realized earlier
that we don't need to have this.x2
property here online 33 and we can
calculate position of both images using
just this dot x that way we don't need
to have two separate reset checks here
and since everything is coming from just
one variable we don't need to do all
this complicated offsetting we did
earlier because we don't need to make
sure x and x2 are synchronized if you
want little challenge pause the video
right now and try to refactor update
method yourself by deleting all
references to this.x2 and using only
this.x to calculate positions of both
images if you don't know how to do it
don't worry i also didn't realize it at
first until i started working on this
tutorial
i comment out line 33 on line 51 inside
draw image method i replace this.x2 with
this.x from 929
i comment out this if statement
and also this line 48
i remove reference to this.x2 since i'm
using this.x for both images on line 51
and 52 you can see our parallax has gap
again this time a big gap
lucky for us it's very simple fix on
line 52 i set horizontal x coordinate to
this dot x from line 29 plus this dot
width from line 31.
that doesn't quite fix it yet as you can
see i also have to look at my if
statement on line 40. if this dot x is
less or equal to minus this dot with
minus 2 400 pixels set this dot x back
to zero
if you don't understand what is
happening right now look at this
i have one image drawn at position x
which starts at 0
and the second image is drawn at
position x plus width
these images sit next to each other and
scroll to the left together like this
when the first image moves past the left
edge of canvas the second image is there
to fill the gap and make it look
seamless
when the right edge of the first image
hits the left edge of canvas at the same
time digital x is minus 2400 pixels
because my image is 2400 pixels wide we
will trigger reset it will just jump
back here
and start scrolling again
the first method was controlling
x-coordinate for these two images
separately by using this.x and this.x2
variables
we had to make sure it synchronizes
correctly both images were moving
independently and i was offsetting them
by their scroll speed and by the current
horizontal position of the other image
to make sure they stayed aligned this is
just a visual representation of what was
happening of course the transition
itself where the image resets after
leaving the screen was happening
instantly more like this
this second improved technique uses just
one variable to move images horizontally
this image is at position this dot x and
the position of the second image is
calculated from that by adding this dot
x plus this dot width the second image
is always 2 400 pixels to the right of
the first image this way they will
always be synchronized since the
position of both images is coming from
the same variable
as you can see the movement is different
now we never actually fully see the
second image anymore we just see this
small part that pops in place so that it
looks like it's one long seamless image
again the transition the reset where the
images move to the right to start from
their original position happens very
fast it happens instantly so we jump
from this to this and that makes it look
like it's just one seamless movement
we can also calculate position x
differently
i can create game frame variable and i
set it to 0.
then in my animation loop here on line
65 i increase game frame by 1 for every
animation frame this way we have a
number that is endlessly increasing
now i can replace this if statement on
line 40 with a different calculation
when i remove this if statement
completely the backgrounds no longer
reset when they leave the screen
i also comment outline 43 and i can
replace all of this with just one line
of code
i say this.x from 930 is equal to game
frame variable we just created and i use
remainder operator and this dot width
from line 32
this.width is currently 2400 pixels
and game frame is endlessly increase in
number this calculation will make sure
this dot x cycles endlessly between 0
and the value of this.width between 0
and 2400 pixels which will have the same
effect as we had before
oh it will go to the right i need to do
game frame minus minus or 966 that's
better
but now all our layers are moving at the
same speed i need to factor in this dot
speed for line 36 in this calculation on
line 44.
this dot x equals to game frame times
this.speed modulus this.width now we
have the same parallax effect this one
line of javascript replaced all the code
between lines 40 and 43.
i don't think it's very clear and easy
to see what's happening on line 44 just
by looking at it i really have to use my
brain and remind myself how modulus
operator works to understand why it's
cycling between 0 and this dot width
i did a complete breakdown of this
technique in my sprite animation video i
will link it in the video description
i'm not going to explain this
calculation all over again
i don't think we need to understand this
line because it has one disadvantage
when compared to the code i had
previously on lines 40-43 look when i
change scrolling speed the position of
background jumps somewhere else because
we aren't gradually increasing this.x
like we did before we are recalculating
that value completely every time
gamespeed changes
clicking this input slider changes
gamespeed global variable changing
gamespeed affects this.speed because of
line 39 and this.speed changes value of
this.x on line 44.
if you know how to use this technique to
make it seamless without jumps in
horizontal position when i change game
speed let me know please i'm sure there
is some smart way to do it i played with
it for a while and i couldn't work it
out do you see how the background jumps
every time i change game speed let's
comment out these lines so that we can
compare it when using the original
technique horizontal position
transitions smoothly without jumps and
that is exactly what i want i need to be
able to change my scrolling speed
dynamically because i want the scroll
speed of my game to change when a
character performs special moves like
roll or set
let's comment out line 66 since we
decided not to use this technique
and i also comment outline 6.
our images are large it works well
because i'm running my code locally if
this code base was hosted somewhere
online we need to make sure all images
and html elements on my page are fully
loaded before we start the game on line
19 i take browser window object and i
call add event listener on it i listen
for load event in callback function when
the page is fully loaded only then i
will run all this code that depends on
images canvas and slider element to be
properly loaded and available
in this video we will build four small
projects completely from scratch we will
learn how to generate groups of animated
computer controlled characters for our
games and we will explore four different
movement animation patterns i went to
the forest and i caught some dangerous
magical creatures for you today we will
study them and learn how they move some
of them have wings some of them spin
around and some just float in the air it
will be interesting to explore their
movement patterns
[Music]
this is creative coating tutorial for
beginners let's learn fundamental
vanilla javascript principles and
techniques by building fun projects
together hope you get a lot of value
today art for this episode was made by
this amazing artist go check out his
website if you want to see more we will
cover 4
different movement animation techniques
and by the end of this video you will
have 4 complete projects and you will be
able to introduce a variety of different
enemies and movement patterns to your
personal javascript games sometimes we
tend to make our games too easy and
predictable let's give our players some
challenge by including different enemy
types
i create a simple web page markup i give
it some title
i link style css file in document head
we will draw everything on canvas so i
create it here and i give it id canvas 1
so that we can target it with css and
javascript later
i also link my script.js file which will
contain all animation logic
in the style css i take my canvas
element i just created and i want to
give it some border size and i want to
center it in the middle of the page so
border 3 pixels solid black position
absolute top 50 percent left fifty
percent
transform translate minus fifty percent
minus fifty percent
now it's in the middle
let's make it vertical so height
thousand pixels
width will be for example 500 pixels
everything else will be drawn with code
in script js file this is a beginner
tutorial so don't worry i will take you
through it step by step
as with every canvas project i need to
point javascript towards my canvas
element we just created in index.html i
do it by using getelementbyid and i pass
it id i gave my canvas element canvas1
like this
ctx shortcut for context is equal to
canvas dot get context and i pass it 2d
we will use a built-in set of 2d drawing
methods today
now i can call all these built-in
methods from my ctx variable if i type
ctx dot like this you can see that in vs
code editor my autocomplete feature
doesn't suggest any built in canvas
methods if i want them to be suggested i
can go up to line 1 and type
add type html canvas element
like this
this way i tell vs code this is a canvas
project and it will suggest built-in
html canvas methods for me you can see
arc method here to draw a circle clear
rectangle to delete paint from canvas
and so on we will use some of these in a
minute when we start drawing and
animating but first let's quickly finish
canvas setup we need to set canvas width
and height to make sure we get correct
scaling of our drawings so i create a
custom global variable called canvas
underscore width i set it equal to
canvas from line 2 dot with
and i set it all equal to 500.
canvas underscore height is canvas dot
height is equal to thousand
these values need to be the same i gave
it in style css
i want to create a factory function that
will produce many similar objects for me
each of these objects will be one
animated enemy before we create many
enemies let's just build one and make it
absolutely clear for beginners what's
going on when we have that it's easy to
scale it up i will create a temporary
enemy1 variable and i set it equal to
javascript object i give it x and y
properties and i set them to zero these
will represent horizontal and vertical
coordinate on canvas where we draw that
enemy
i will also give it width of 200 pixels
and height of 200 pixels like this
so now i have this simple javascript
object that is storing position and size
of one enemy let's animate it to create
animation loop i like to write a custom
function i call for example animate
inside i call build in fill rectangle
method this method expects x y width and
height of the rectangle we want to draw
so i will give it x y with a height of
this anime object
when i call animate like this we are
drawing a black rectangle representing
the enemy object i can change its values
and when i refresh the page it will be
reflected on canvas we are not animating
yet what if i want the horizontal x
position to be slowly increasing to make
the enemy travel to the right i can say
for each run of animation loop increase
enemy1.x property from line 8 by 1.
to create animation loop i call built-in
request animation frame method i pass it
animate
now animate will run all its code and
then it will call itself again this will
create an endless animation loop
i also need to delete old paint previous
frames from canvas i do it by using
built in clear rectangle method and i
clear canvas from coordinates 0 0 to
canvas with canvas height
now we see only the current animation
frame
i can also increase vertical y position
by 1 for every frame so we get movement
towards bottom right like this
i can change width and height of my
enemy easily you get the idea i think
let's comment out this temporary enemy
object and make it into a javascript
class so that we can generate a large
number of enemies at once javascript
class is kind of a template to create
many similar object it's a factory and
every time we ask it it will produce one
new object for us based on a blueprint
we give it classes are new syntax for
older javascript prototypes under the
hood is the same thing it's just
so-called syntactical sugar simpler
nicer way to do the same thing classes
are very easy and intuitive let me show
you we use class keyword and then we
name our class starting with a capital
letter my class will be called nme
constructor is a mandatory method every
class must have it will contain a
blueprint based on which every enemy
object will be created so here in
constructor i just give it x y width and
height same as we had in this simple
enemy object on line 7. the syntax might
be a bit strange at first here i'm
telling my constructor on this new enemy
object you are creating right now give
it property called x and set it equal to
10 pixels
starting vertical y coordinate will be
50 pixels
width will be 100 pixels and height 100
as well
so this is how you recreate single
javascript object into a reusable class
now we can call our enemy class as many
times as we want and each time it will
generate one new enemy for us based on a
blueprint inside constructor method
between lines 16 to 19.
i can delete the old code
and now these variables are undefined
because anyone doesn't exist so i create
a new constant variable called anime1
again
and i set it equal to an instance of my
new anime class to do that i use the new
keyword followed by a class name the new
keyword will simply look at that class
name in my code it will enter its
constructor it will create one new blank
javascript object and it will assign it
values and properties based on a
blueprint inside the constructor
now my fill rectangle method online 21
can use these values again to display a
rectangle what if i want another enemy i
can create another variable called
enemy2 and i set it to new enemy again
inside animation loop i take nma2 and i
increase its x and y coordinates as well
and on line 25 i need to draw another
rectangle representing that enemy like
this
they're moving at the same speed in the
same direction so we can't see the
second one let's adjust its speed for
example
now we can see that there are two of
them we can control them separately like
this but this wouldn't be very efficient
if we had let's say 50 or even 500
enemies so how do we make this code
better and remove repetition first let's
output this code between lines 21 and 24
that handles movement along x and y axis
into a shared class method that way we
can write this code only once and it
will be available to all objects created
by enemy class
i will call that custom function for
example update and as i said its job
will be to update coordinates of my
objects it will handle position
calculation and movement so inside i say
for every frame increase x by one
and also increase y by one
let's delete all this code and to run
update method i just created all i have
to do is call anyone dot update like
this
since anime1 object was created here on
line 19 as an instance of my enemy class
from line 7 it automatically has access
to this new update class method from
line 14.
i also need to remove line 25 so now we
put all movement calculation
functionality into this update method i
also want to put this drawing code into
its separate method so that we can draw
all enemies at the same time we can also
give them animated sprites and so on i
will show you in a minute
on line 18 i create a custom draw method
inside i call ctx fill rectangle the
same way we did here on line 27 but
instead of hardcoding enemy1 object here
like this i will use this keyword that
way this method will be reusable and can
animate not only enemy 1 but also anime
2 enemy 10 and m800 it can animate all
the enemies created by this class at
once
on line 27 i can replace these
hard-coded values with anime1.draw
it will look the same but now it's
reusable and scalable
inside constructor between lines 9 and
12 all enemies start at the same x and y
coordinates so if i create 50 enemies
they would all stuck on top of each
other and wouldn't be visible
let's randomize that every time i create
a new enemy its horizontal x coordinate
will be a random number between zero and
canvas width
and vertical y coordinate will be a
random number between zero and canvas
height
now every time i refresh page my enemy
appears at a different position
i could also randomize width and height
if i wanted to to make each enemy random
size i think you get the idea
so how do i create many enemies instead
of just one i comment out line 22 and i
create a for loop this for loop will run
for example 100 times
actually let's go up to line 6 and
create a constant variable called the
number of enemies and i set it to 100
and i replace hard-coded 100 on line 24
with this new variable
that's better we shouldn't be hardcoding
values if we can avoid it i want this
for loop to run 100 times and create 100
enemies for me using my custom anime
class but how do i store all these anime
objects and their properties such as
their x and y values i can for example
go up here to line 7 and create a custom
variable called enemies array and i set
it equal to an empty array
down here on line 26 i take that enemies
array and i call build in array push
method push method will just take
whatever we pass to it and it will push
it to the end of the array i pass it new
enemy
every time this for loop runs and it
will run 100 times it will create one
new anime using my enemy class
constructor and it will push that new
enemy into enemies array
it's the same as we did with anime 1 on
line 24 but here we are doing it 100
times
let's delete line 24
i also have to comment outlines 31 and
32 because anime one variable doesn't
exist anymore
how do i access all these hundred
objects i just pushed into my enemies
array and how do i trigger their update
and draw methods one by one so that they
can be animated on canvas first let's
console.log enemy's array to make sure
that for loop on line 25 did its job and
filled it with hundred objects
in console i can see we have hundred
enemies and each one has randomized x
and y coordinate
perfect
so as i said the goal now is to cycle
through all hundred enemy objects inside
enemies array and to trigger their
update and draw methods
this will need to happen for every
animation frame over and over because we
need update method to constantly
recalculate enemy position and a draw
method to draw them at that new position
on line 33 inside animation loop i take
enemies array that contains my hundred
objects and i call built-in array for
each method for each simply calls
providedcallback function for each
element in the array i will use new es6
syntax with arrow function here
inside my for each callback refer to
each individual object as enemy as you
cycle through enemies array
and for each of these objects call their
associated draw method
and also their update method like this
perfect you can see that each rectangle
appears at randomized x position and
they all move in the same direction
because of lines 17 and 18. what if my
enemy had randomized speed
i create a new property called
this.speed and i set it equal to a
random number between minus two and plus
two because i want some of them to go to
the left and some of them to go to the
right
if you find it hard to read this line of
code as a random number between -2 and
plus 2. think of it this way this part
of code generates a random number in
this range so between 0 and 4 and this
number sets the start of that range so
we are generating a random number
between 0 and 4 but we are pushing that
range to start from -2 so result we get
is a random number between minus 2 and
plus 2. i remember i always found math
at random very unintuitive until i found
a better way to think of it anyway now i
have this top speed property and i can
replace it here on line 18 for
horizontal position and also on line 19
for vertical position now you can see we
have rectangles moving in many different
directions
i delete code on line 29 and also on
lines 32 and 33.
on line 21 inside draw method our
enemies don't have to be represented by
black rectangle we can write any drawing
code here and it will be called and
replicated for all enemies at once i can
for example try stroke rectangle instead
we can also draw circles stars you can
put selfies from your holidays to
represent each enemy object here we have
complete flexibility
what i want to do here is to create
animated creatures because we want these
to be enemies for our javascript games
with this video we are giving away 4
different animated enemies drawn by this
amazing artist go check out his website
for more content he is very talented he
allowed me to share this prize with you
for educational purposes for free you
can download them in the video
description and you can also find link
to his website there if you want to use
these sprites for commercial purposes
you would have to go to his website and
buy a full license
they are free only for purposes of this
educational video show him some support
if you can we don't have many good 2d
artists like this if we support them
they will be able to create more
beautiful game art assets for us
today we will create four different
projects each one will have different
enemy with a different movement pattern
and on each one we will demonstrate
different beginner-friendly movement
animation technique
i want you to always have a nice
complete project at the end of my videos
so that you have something to show to
your friends or on your coding portfolio
it feels good to complete something
don't you think
you can use these as animated
backgrounds or a screensaver or you can
take this code and slot it into your
personal games it will be compatible
with my previous games if you follow
these tutorials
let's start with a very simple one the
first project will have baths flying in
random jumpy patterns perfect for
halloween game or even a website for
example i'll leave the creative
applications of this on you
first i need to bring new image into my
javascript project to do it i create a
custom variable called anime image and i
set it equal to new image
animeimage.src is equal to enemy1.png
if you are using the same spritesheet i
am using
it might be a good idea to use the same
files at first and follow along and once
you understand the code it's easy to
adjust it and to use your own custom
images on line 26 inside the draw method
i call built in draw image canvas method
we will use it to animate our butt
sprite sheet i will explain sprite
animation quickly as i code but if you
need more detailed explanation i made a
special video where i focus on it in
depth i will link it in the video
description ctx dot draw image and i
pass it image i want to draw and i pass
it x and y coordinates
and this is what we get
we can also pass it optional with and
height arguments which will scale the
entire image into that specified size
you can see it pushes the entire sprite
sheet with all six frames inside the
rectangle
we don't really want that we only want
to crop out one frame at a time and we
want to be jumping by the amount of
sprite width to the right to display the
next sprite frame we want to go frame by
frame from left to right until we reach
the last frame
then we want to jump back to the first
one and start again we can do this with
the draw image method because it offers
additional four optional arguments we
can pass to it
let's go up inside anime constructor to
create property called sprite width i
check my sprite sheet divide its width
by the number of frames and i can see
that width of a single frame is 293
pixels sprite height of this particular
sprite sheet is
pixels
now let's add additional four arguments
to draw image method to tell it what
area we want to crop out from this
sprite sheet to display only one frame
let's start by displaying just frame one
so i want to crop out area from
coordinates 0 0
to coordinates sprite with sprite height
now we are drawing just frame 1.
so in this version of draw image method
we are passing it nine arguments in
total the first is the image we want to
draw
the next four represent the area we want
to crop out from the source sprite sheet
and these last four arguments determine
where on canvas we want to place that
cropped out frame onto
you can see my pads are slightly
distorted because i am stretching them
to fit this.width and this dot height
here which are unrelated to the actual
dimensions of my butt enemy character
ideally i want to preserve the aspect
ratio so i make width and height
relative to the sprite size
i take width and height and i move them
to go after sprite width and sprite
height so that they can see these values
now i can make width one third of sprite
width
and height one third of sprite height
now our bytes are the correct ratio
maybe i want to make them a bit larger
let's try 2.5
that's better
right now we are displaying only frame 1
because of these hard-coded 0-0
coordinates let's cycle through all
frames and animate our characters
on enemy class i need a new property
called this dot frame and i set it to 0.
on line 30 instead of hard coding
horizontal coordinate 0 which will give
us this frame i will take
this dot frame variable and i multiply
it times this dot sprite width that way
when frame is 0 we display this frame
when it's 1 we display this frame
2 3 and so on
so now all i have to do is that frame
cycles between this and this frame
between 0 and 5.
i will use es6 ternary operator which is
a simple one line if else statement
basically i say if this dot frame is
more than four question mark set this
dot frame back to zero
else colon increase frame by one this
dot frame plus plus
this should be colon
our buds are flapping their wings and
animating but they flap very fast and
all of them flap at the same time let's
fix that there's a proper way to time
animation frames using request animation
frame and delta time and i will show you
how to do that in some other video today
let's slow down our animation the
simplest way possible on line 11 i
create a variable called a game frame
and i set it equal to zero
inside animation loop on line 46 i
increase game frame by 1 for every loop
and up on line 28 inside update method i
say if this ever increasing game frame
variable is divisible by let's say 2
with a remainder of 0 only then serve a
new animation frame this line simply
means run this code only every 2 loops
of main animation loop
if you are getting a little unsure i
made a special sprite animation video
where i go in depth and slowly over all
of this for now let's just move on and
focus on movement patterns
now bats animate slower but they all
still move their wings at the same time
in the same rhythm i want to randomize
their animation frequency i create a
custom property called for example flap
speed and i set it equal to random
number between 1 and 4.
i replace hard coded 2 on line 29 with
this randomized flap speed value
this will make some of them animate very
quickly some of them slower some will
animate every one or two or three or
four frames it will be randomized the
reason it doesn't work is because math
at random returns numbers with the
decimal point so game frame is never
divisible by that very specific number
with a remainder of 0
and frames never increase
to fix that i just need to wrap it in
math.floor
now some bats flap their wings slower
and some do it very fast
i will remove the stroke rectangle
i can also take enemy image variable
from line 9 and actually make it a
property on javascript class like this
this dot image equals new image
this dot image src source is nma1png
i delete that and inside draw image on
line 34 i refer to this dot image in
stat
by changing value of number of enemies
on line 6 we get a different number of
bots in our project
currently our buds just fly away from
canvas and never come back we don't
really want that
let's create the first simplest movement
pattern which will simply be just
randomized jumpy chaotic movement
i comment out this dot speed on line 17
and on line 26 i replace it with math at
random times 3.
i do the same with this.y on line 27
since we are adding positive numbers to
x and y all bats are going to leave
canvas like this how about we tried a
random number between minus 1.5 and plus
1.5
now they kind of stay in place and just
wiggle around we can increase their
wiggle by giving this random number a
larger range for example between plus
2.5 and minus 2.5
i can see that my initial enemy x and y
coordinates are not 100 within canvas
let's adjust line 15 like this
and since i'm using this.width here i
need to move it after this.weight has
been declared
now they initially spawn within canvas
horizontally these brackets are
important look what happens when i
remove them
they just start from minus distort width
which is wrong these brackets need to be
here
let's do the same thing vertically for
this dot y
i reduce the number of enemies to 100 or
10.
let's make the range much larger on line
26 between minus 7.5 and plus 7.5
i can just play with these values and
get the random simple jumping movement
this is the simplest way you can animate
enemy characters or npcs for your
javascript games we will do three more
adding a little bit more complexity each
time
let's see what comes out of that
i will be expanding deleting and
adjusting the same code base so if you
want maybe it's a good idea to create a
copy of this project at this stage so
you have this movement pattern saved in
case you want to use it for your games
later i will be using different enemies
spreadsheet and different movement
pattern for the next one i hope you're
having fun
for the second movement pattern we will
do something a bit different first let's
switch to a different sprite sheet here
on line 14. i will use image i called
enemy2 png
it's different size so i have to change
sprite width and sprite height sprite
width is 266 pixels and sprite height is
188 pixels
i uncomment this dot speed on line 15
and i give each game character a random
speed between 1 and 5 pixels per frame
for example on line 26 i set this.x to
be equal to minus this dot speed
if i comment out why we can see that
bats just fly to the left in a straight
horizontal line and they never come back
let's first do a reset check if this dot
x from line 20 plus this dot width from
line 18 is less than zero meaning when
the character moved behind the left edge
of canvas and is completely hidden
that's why i included this dot width
here when that happens i want its
horizontal x position to be reset back
to canvas width moving it behind the
right edge of canvas so that it can do
another flyover
now we have endless right to left
movement awesome
we already have something interesting
here but what if i want them to sway up
and down as they flap their wings making
it a bit more dynamic and if these were
enemies in my javascript game maybe it
would make it a bit more difficult for
player to avoid them how do i create
wavy movement do you know what sine wave
is
let's do a little bit of a very simple
beginner friendly trigonometry
trigonometry is a branch of mathematics
that studies relationships between side
lengths and angles of triangles we use
it to create wavy and circular movement
in our javascript animations thanks to
built in javascript math methods today
we will have a look at math.sine and
math.cosine built in javascript methods
sine is a trigonometric function of an
angle defined in a context of a right
triangle all we need to know for now is
that market sign returns the sign of a
number we pass to it that number
represents angle value in radians and it
returns numeric value between -1 and
plus 1.
so this input angle value it takes if i
put it inside animation loop and slowly
start increasing it over time by very
small amounts when i pass this angle
value to math.sine it will return a
series of values that endlessly cycles
between -1 and plus 1 making it easy for
us to convert these values into wavy
movement so called sine wave what i just
said might be a bit complicated for
beginners and it might not make much
sense yet let me show you
i will need this angle property on my
enemy class constructor and i initially
set it to 0.
this is the number that will be
increasing and after being passed to my
dot sign it will give us that series of
values between -1 and plus 1 as i just
mentioned
let's do it so you can see on line 28 i
set position y plus equals math.sine and
i pass it this dot angle
then i increase this.angle by 0.1 for
every animation frame
as the angle slowly increases do you see
the waves
i can change the value here on line 29
to change shape of my sine wave
angle doesn't have to start from zero it
can be a bit randomized let's try with
math at random times two
it will not be very visible it will
become clear what it does a bit later i
will point it out quickly said starting
value of this.angle determines what
position along the sine wave
this particular character appears at
first before it starts moving it's more
obvious if we map movement to a circle
and we'll do that in a minute
i can also randomize the speed at which
angle value increases on line 30. i do
that by creating a new property called
for example angle speed and i set it to
a random number between 0 and 0.2
then i take this variable and i replace
this hardcoded 0.05 with it
now each anime has its own angle value
that is being increased by a slightly
different amount for each frame this
will randomize the wave shape for each
enemy
let's set this.angle to 0 for now
i reduce the number of enemies on line
6.
as i said method sign returns values
that cycle periodically between -1 and
plus 1.
what if i wanted to make the curve more
prominent
i can simply just multiply it times 3
here on line 29 and now we are getting
values that cycle between -3 and plus 3.
do you see how the sine wave of enemy
movement is more prominent
look what happens when i put the
different numbers here
i hope it's becoming more clear what i'm
doing
if i put times 10 we get a very
prominent curve
if these are enemies in your game good
luck to all players trying to avoid them
especially for certain sprite sheets
this movement might be very suitable
maybe you have some strange aliens in
your space game and you want to move
them in this weird wavy pattern instead
of hardcoding number 10 here i can again
put this value in a variable that will
be randomized for each enemy that way we
get even more variation in movement
between enemies i will call it
this.curve for example
sorry about my variable names sometimes
it's hard for me to come up with
suitable names for all these custom
properties i hope it's becoming at least
a little bit clear what each of these
properties does so far i want curve
property to be a random number between 0
and 10 and i replace this hardcoded 10
with it here on line 30.
maybe 10 is too much let's do times 7
here on line 26
do you see what we just did
some of them move in a very prominent
waves some have barely any vertical
movement this would make our game more
unpredictable
i can add as many enemies as i want
let's put 200 here on line 6.
but infestation this will be a hard mode
in my game
so we did endless horizontal movement
with vertical sine wave element to it
what if we bring it a step further and
also add some trigonometry for
horizontal x-coordinate
we can make the enemies move in all
kinds of different shapes and patterns
that way let me show you
as usual i will first swap to a
different image on line 14 i set image
src to nma3 png
i check my sprite sheet and i see that
width of a single frame is 218 pixels
and height is 177 pixels
let's comment out lines 29 and 30 which
will stop our character from moving
around on line 29 i want horizontal
movement to be cycling within a certain
range
i call math.sine and i pass it
this.angle from line 24. this.angle
value is increasing over and over on
line 31 as update method is called from
inside animation loop i will also
multiply it times method pi divided by
180
let's just experiment here a bit
if i multiply this whole thing by 10
nothing happens 50
we see some movement 100
yes they are moving now this angle speed
on line 25 affects how fast angle value
on line 31 is increasing
if i set it to 0.9 they will move faster
times 2 might be a good speed for now
they kind of disappear behind canvas
edge i can move them by adding some
value to this dot x position like this
plus 10 will move everything slightly to
the right
plus hundred
how about plus canvas width divided by
two
i want to center them horizontally now
they are too much to the right i need to
offset them by the amount of their width
i change this.curve on line 26 to be a
random number between 0 and 200 and i
replace hard-coded 100 on line 29 with
this dot curve property now some of them
move in a large range some only in a
small area
as we said before method sign when we
feed it an angle it will return a value
between plus 1 and -1 since this angle
is ever increasing on line 31 we are
getting a continuous series of values
that endlessly bounce between minus 1
and plus 1 by multiplying all of this by
this dot curve here for characters that
have this dot curve 200 for example they
are endlessly cycling between -200 and
plus 200.
put it in brackets
actually this has to be this dot width
divided by two
yeah now they are centered horizontally
on line 29 we are animating horizontal x
position let's also do this with this
dot y on line 30 and see what happens
if i copy the same formula and replace
width with height
because we are dealing with vertical
movement
we get this pattern
this is where cosine comes in
i'm not going to explain trigonometry in
detail in this video but the main idea
is you have a circle and radius of that
circle can represent hypotenuse the
longest side of a right angle triangle
if we connect lines like this to
complete the triangle
sine value represents relationship
between opposite side of the triangle
and hypotenuse
cosine is the relationship between the
adjacent side of that triangle and
hypotenuse hypotenuse size never changes
but sine and cosine is cycle
periodically as the size of opposite and
adjacent side of this imaginary triangle
changes
as a result sine and cosine complement
each other to map a circle path and
that's what we are taking advantage of
here method sign is creating periodical
horizontal movement for me online 29 and
on line 30 math.cosine is doing that for
vertical values together they complement
each other in a way that results in a
circle movement you can play with these
values swap sine and cosine make both of
them sine or cosine it should illustrate
it better what's going on if you see how
these changes affect our animation
if i want to have some space in the
middle we know that this dot curve
determines radius of the circle my
characters are moving in that value is
randomized for each one i can give it a
minimum value for example let's do a
random number between 50 and 250.
i can also change angle speed on line 25
this will affect how fast angle is
increasing on line 31 and because that
angle is being passed over and over to
mattered sign and mattered cosine it
will increase the speed at which our
characters move along the circular path
see here we already have some
interesting movement pattern for our
enemies i could use this in some parts
of my game right now sine and cosine are
even what i mean is they cycle between
the same set of values over and over
which results in even circular movement
what if i make the horizontal position
the cycle at half the speed compared to
vertical position by saying math.pi
divided by 360 here now vertical
position does two cycles while
horizontal position does only one
because of the difference between 360
and 180
these two values here this will give us
a different movement pattern if i give
both of them the same number it will be
a circle smaller numbers will result in
a faster movement the resultant movement
is always a relationship between these
two values these values don't have to be
directly divisible by one another but it
might help to visualize it better
for example here horizontal position
will go over five cycles while vertical
position will do one cycle it's because
of the relationship between 90 and 500
it gives us interest in movement
i can change their speed also by
adjusting this.angle speed on line 25.
so this technique can be customized to
achieve movement pattern you are looking
for
maybe your game starts easy but later it
becomes more difficult so you need
faster enemies
if i put 360 here 360 is divisible by
90. if you watch the animation we will
get four horizontal cycles before we get
one vertical cycle because 360 divided
by 90 is 4.
don't feel like you have to fully
understand sine and cosine at this stage
to take advantage of this technique i
will make a special video where we deep
dive into this functionality for now
this is all we need to know to be able
to use this for our games if i want the
shape to be number 8 i can just make
vertical value double of horizontal
value here
i can play with different numbers and
see what happens
can also have cosine for both like this
it will cause them to backtrack to go
back and forth following the same path
rather than moving in circles swapping
sine and cosine will make our characters
follow circular path in the opposite
direction i don't like how they fill the
entire width but they don't fill the
height of my canvas how do i make them
use all available space we are using
this.curve which is a random number
between 50 and 250 and it makes them
move within that range what if i replace
it with canvas width on line 29
okay that's too much because this value
is radius of their movement half circle
if i want them to cover width of canvas
i need to give them canvas width divided
by two
much better let's do the same for
vertical position on line 30 canvas
height divided by two
awesome now our movement path is even
more obvious
i will increase number of enemies on
line 6 just so that we fill the path
with more objects and see it better
now you can clearly see that our enemies
are running along a set path shape of
this particular path is determined by
relationship between 90 and 270 here
three horizontal cycles fit into one
vertical cycle because 270 divided by 90
is 3.
if i make the values the same we get
circular path again it's an ellipse
because i'm stretching the movement here
and here
108 in x and 90 in y will mean two
vertical cycles happen before we get one
horizontal cycle what happens if i swap
180 and 90.
interesting
to get h shape i would have to swap sine
and cosine here
are you starting to understand how these
values affect the shape of path our
animated characters take
you can play with this for a while
experiment with different values and see
what happens on canvas trial and error
can sometimes be the best way to come up
with unique interesting results
trigonometry is a big topic and we will
come back to it in some other course
i'm sure some of you get other ideas for
this technique it doesn't have to be
used for patrolling enemies in games as
we are doing here
you can for example use it to create
automatically moving particle effects
and animations for website and many
other things
creative coding gives us a lot of
opportunities to come up with unique
beautiful stuff and that's why we are
building these projects together to
improve our vanilla javascript skills
and at the same time to explore what's
possible maybe it will spark new ideas
in some of you
i know that there are many creative
people watching my videos i'm just here
to give you the tools where you take it
and how you decide to use it is up to
you
we can play with these values and create
different paths this.angle property on
line 24 determines where along our path
our animated characters appear at first
i can spread their starting position
along the path by using math at random
i could have also used something a bit
more unusual like oscillators or pearly
noise here but i want to keep this video
beginner friendly we can do more
advanced path following and random
movement algorithms later
another simple technique uses a
completely different trick and it
results in what i think is the best
movement pattern if you want your
enemies to appear like they have mind of
their own at least when we stay in the
world of simple beginner algorithms
there are many advanced ai techniques
you could use but this is javascript for
beginners you might want to make a copy
of this codebase because to achieve the
next effect i will break this one little
bit
let's delete lines 24 25 and 26
i will also set this.x and this.wire to
0 inside my update method
and i delete line 28.
comment out lines 26 and 27 and now
initial x coordinate is randomized on
line 20 and vertical coordinate is
randomized here on line 21.
i will create a new property a call for
example new x and i set it to random
number between 0 and canvas with i do
the same for vertical y coordinate with
this dot new y property
so i have initial horizontal position on
line 20 and i have a new horizontal
position on line 22.
on line 9 i have game frame variable
that is endlessly increasing inside my
animation loop i will say every time
game frame is divisible by 30 with a
remainder of 0 which basically means
every 30 frames of my main animation
loop i want to reset this dot new x and
this dot mu y to a different random
position
basically i just need to copy lines 22
and 23 here
now i will calculate variable i call for
example dx distance on horizontal x-axis
it simply is the difference between this
dot x from line 20 and this dot new x
from line 22
dui distance on vertical y axis is this
dot y from line 21 minus this dot nu y
from line 23.
now that we have distance between
current position and the new position i
can make characters move towards that
new position by saying this dot x minus
equals dx from line 32 and this dot y
minus equals d y from line 33
it's resetting too fast let's change 30
to 60 here on line 28. now we get
instant position change every 60 frames
i can make them travel towards that
position by saying dx divided by 20. i
can also do that for vertical position
by saying dy divided by 20 here
now current position is always moving
towards the new position by 20th of
their distance for every animation frame
i can increase these numbers to make
them move slower
i can also increase the interval on line
28. i like this but you can see that
positions reset every 100 frames for all
enemies at the same time that looks a
bit weird i want each character to reset
at its own randomized interval
i create a property i call for example
distort interval and it will be a random
number between 50 and 250.
then i replace hardcoded hundred with
this.interval on line 29. it won't work
yet because this.interval is a random
number with decimal points so gameframe
will never be divisible by that very
specific number with a remainder of 0 so
new positions will never be calculated
to fix that i need to wrap this in
math.floor which will round it down and
make sure we get only integers whole
numbers without decimal points
also now you can see that each enemy is
moving at their own rhythm
i can add more enemies on line 6.
it kind of looks like a swarm of
mosquitoes
[Music]
i also need to swap enemy sprite sheet
to keep up with tradition
i will use anime 4 png here
i look at my sprite sheet and width and
height is 213 pixels this time
there are many other calculations and
algorithms that you can use to make
enemies move in a certain way let's make
that today's challenge can you alter
some of the code we wrote today and
create your own movement pattern you can
also make enemies follow the mouse or
maybe try to avoid it there are many
ways to make this interactive let me
know in the comments if you watched all
the way here if you did well done today
we added an important set of techniques
to our vanilla javascript game
development toolkit i'll see you soon if
you want more game development check out
my playlists links in the video
description
collision detection is important if you
want to build the javascript games and
you need to detect when two elements
collide
or when you are building particle
systems where objects interact with each
other or maybe you want your canvas
animations to interact with regular
website elements
for most projects all we need is simple
collision detection algorithm between
two rectangles or between two circles
for more complex shapes we also use
collision detection technique called
separating axis theorem
it can be used to detect collision
between convex polygons or rectangles
that are rotated and aren't axis aligned
you might also have more specific needs
for your games or creative coding
projects some of other common scenarios
are collision detection between point
and circle
point and square
between line and circle
line and square
between two lines and so on it becomes
more complex when you need to detect
collisions where shapes such as convex
and concave polygons are involved
there are some clever tricks people came
up with to handle these more advanced
scenarios
such as detecting collision by color or
projecting lines from a point and
checking if the number of intersections
between that line and polygon is odd or
even a number with more complex shapes
it's a good practice to wrap them in
simple rectangles and only run advanced
collision checks if these rectangles
collide and we know that the shapes are
close enough and collision is possible
for many games all you need is to create
a generic shape around our objects so
called hitbox even though the collision
is not pixel perfect we can adjust these
hitboxes to roughly match collision
areas of objects with different shapes
main advantage is that the code is very
simple and performant because it doesn't
require complex calculations to
determine whether two objects collide or
not
these hitboxes can have shape or
rectangle circle or polygon
the simplest collision detection
algorithm is between two rectangles that
are axis aligned it means that they are
not rotated
it simply compares x and y coordinates
and width and height of these two
rectangles if they overlap we get
collision if there is a gap between them
we know there is no collision
let me show you two different simple
algorithms you can use to detect
collision between two rectangles two
hitboxes in our games let's say we have
rectangle one and rectangle two both of
these objects have x and y coordinates
and some width and height
the first way i can check if they
collide is this i create a simple if
statement and i check if horizontal
position x of rectangle 1 is less than
horizontal position x of rectangle 2
plus width of rectangle 2.
basically if this point is less than
this point less means if it's to the
left on horizontal x-axis
at the same time we want to check if x
of rectangle 1 plus width of rectangle 1
is more than x of rectangle 2.
that means if this point is to the right
from this point
we also do this vertically so we check
if vertical y coordinate of rectangle 1
is less than vertical y of rectangle 2
plus height of rectangle 2
if this point is above this point
and lastly we check if vertical
coordinate of rectangle 1 plus height of
rectangle 1 is more than horizontal y
position of rectangle 2.
if this point is below this point if all
of these 4 conditions are true we enter
this code block in our if statement and
collision is triggered
else we know there is no collision we
can also flip the logic completely this
second algorithm does the same checks
but it's a bit more efficient if i
change the logic a little bit
and use or operator it returns true if
at least one of its operands are true
let's go through the logic here
if x of rectangle one is more than x of
rectangle two plus width of rectangle
two we know they cannot possibly collide
so this will return true and we know
straight away there is no collision
also if x of rectangle 1 plus width of
rectangle 1 is less than x of rectangle
2 again we know these rectangles can't
possibly collide just one check and we
know there is no collision
if y of rectangle 1 is more than y of
rectangle 2 plus height of rectangle 2
there is no way for collision to happen
if y of rectangle 1 plus its height is
less than y of rectangle 2 we also know
they don't collide
so if at least one of these four checks
is true we know there is no collision if
all four return false we know that the
rectangles must collide else statement
is entered and collision is detected
i hope this was visual enough and you
got some clarity on how these checks
work if you have any questions let me
know
if you want to see how to implement
these particular algorithms in an actual
project and where exactly to place them
in your code base i use them in many of
my games such as in tower defense
frogger flappy bird and many more i will
link some in the video description if
you want to learn more with me check out
some videos on my vanilla javascript
game development playlist i also do web
animations generative art for beginners
and more everything with vanilla
javascript using no frameworks and no
libraries hope you have fun and show me
some of your creative coding projects
please you can message me on twitter if
you want let's be friends
collision detection is important if you
want to build particle systems where
elements interact with each other
or when you are building javascript
games and you want to detect when two
objects collide or maybe when you want
your canvas animations to interact with
regular website elements
three of the most common techniques we
use for games and creative coding are
collision detection between circles
rectangles and polygons there are also
other potential scenarios and some
clever people came up with interesting
ways how to detect them with code some
are easier than others one of the most
useful ones is collision detection
between two circles
you can detect if two circles collide
with javascript very easily the
algorithm just takes two center points
of our circles and checks if the
distance between them is less than the
radii of these two circles added
together what does that look like in
code let me quickly show you let's say
we have two javascript objects circle
one and circle two they have some
coordinates so position on horizontal
x-axis and position on vertical y-axis
and some radius i connect their center
points with a line
this line represents distance between
center points of these two circles i
connect position of circle 2 to my
current mouse position so we can move it
around
if the distance between these two center
points is more than radius of circle 1
plus radius of circle two we know they
can't collide if the distance is the
same we know they touch and if the
distance is smaller then some of these
two radii added together we know the
circles overlap they collide to be able
to measure distance between two points
of a javascript in this case center
point of circle one and center point of
circle two we will use simple and very
powerful algorithm once you learn this
and get comfortable with it you will
unlock next level in your coding and
animation projects to measure the
distance between these two points and
check if the circles collide we need to
know length of this line we calculated
by imagining there is a right angle
triangle in between like this
in this triangle our distance is
actually hypotenuse the longest side of
a right triangle opposite to the right
angle
this is the right angle 90 degrees
we know x and y position of center point
of circle one
and we also know x and y position of
center point of circle 2. with that we
can calculate length of both arms of the
right triangle this side is simply just
the difference between horizontal x
position of center point of circle 2
minus horizontal x position of center
point of circle one
we can do the same thing to calculate
this side
vertical position of this center point
minus vertical position of this center
point
now we have this imaginary right
triangle between our two points we know
this side
we know this side and we know this is
the right angle 90 degrees
now we want to know how long is this
side hypotenuse of our triangle opposite
to the right angle we can achieve that
easily with pythagorean theorem it
allows us to calculate relations among
the three sides of a right triangle
imagine we draw squares on top of each
line like this pythagorean theorem tells
us that the sum of the areas of the two
squares around the right angle equals to
the area of the square on the hypotenuse
c squared is equal to a squared plus b
squared
that means c is square root of a squared
plus b squared if you want to know why
this is true check out radu's video i
will link it in the video description
so distance between center point of
circle 1 and center point of circle 2 is
dx times dx
which is side a
squared plus d y times d y
side b squared this would give us a
squared value and i want square root so
i wrap it in math dot square root like
this now we calculated the hypotenuse of
the right angle triangle which is the
distance between center points of circle
one and circle two
the distance is less than radius of
circle 1 plus radius of circle 2
we have collision
if the distance is exactly the same
number as the sum of radius of circle 1
plus radius of circle 2 we know they
touch
if the distance is more we know there is
some space between the circles and they
don't collide
visual and audio feedback that reacts to
player actions and in-game events is
really important if you want your
javascript games to feel good
you can for example attach sound and
explosion animation whenever collision
happens in your game you can also use
this technique to make score points
float from defeated enemies
or from collected items
today we will build an easy fun project
together that combines javascript audio
and sprite animation when we covered all
these basics of triggered event-based
animations we will build a game that
will look something like this to really
put all these principles in action
[Music]
i create a regular web page markup
in document head i link my css style
sheet
i create html5 canvas element with an id
of canvas one we will draw on it with
code i also link my javascript file down
here at the bottom just before the
closing body tag
all i need to do install css is to
position my canvas element so i target
it with id
i give it border 3 pixel solid black
position absolute
height 700 pixels with 500 pixels
background black
let's center it so top 50 percent left
50
and transform translate minus 50 minus
50
this trick will only center elements
that have position set to absolute as we
do here on line three
everything else will be drawn with plain
vanilla javascript here in script js
file i need to point javascript towards
my canvas element so custom variable
called for example canvas is equal to
document.getelementbyid
canvas1
ctx shortcut for context is equal to
canvas.getcontext2d
this will instantiate object that holds
all 2d drawing methods we will need
today
canvas width is 500
canvas height is 700
let's test if we set it up correctly by
drawing a quick simple shape it's good
to test your code as you go makes it
easier to debug i set global canvas fill
style to white this will apply to fill
of all shapes now unless i redeclare it
again and give it a different color i
call build in fill rectangle method
i pass it coordinates 5050
with 100 pixels and height 150 pixels
perfect we set it up correctly and we
are drawing on canvas now let's make it
more fun
i delete the rectangle and i create a
variable called for example explosions i
set it equal to an empty array its job
will be to hold all active explosion
objects i create i created them using
javascript class i call it for example
explosion with a capital e
constructor will expect x and y
coordinates coming from the outside this
is important because we want the
animation to be triggered at a specific
location where the event happens for
example we wanted to animate at
coordinates where two elements collided
or at coordinates of mouse click i will
pass this x and y coordinates to the
constructor whenever i want to trigger
new animation and create new object
using this class it's very simple i will
show you in a minute
so on this new explosion object give it
this.x property and assign it to x that
was passed as an argument on line 8 from
the outside
do the same for this.y vertical y
coordinate
this dot sprite width will be weight of
a single frame in my sprite sheet i
calculated by taking width of my sprite
sheet and i divide it by the number of
frames in this case my sprite sheet is
1000 pixels wide and has 5 frames
1 000 divided by 5 is 200.
height of my sprite is 179 pixels
sometimes you get sprite sheets that are
too large or too small so you might want
to scale it while still keeping the
aspect ratio relationship between width
and height to make sure the image is not
stretched or squished
i declare the slot width property and i
set it equal to this dot sprite width
from line 11 divided by 2.
this load height will be this dot sprite
height divided by 2. it's important to
divide or multiply them by the same
number to keep the same aspect ratio by
the way for optimization it's always
better to multiply than to divide
division operation in javascript is more
performance expensive so instead of
dividing them by 2 i could have
multiplied them times 0.5
i will bring my sprite sheet into the
project you could declare it as a global
variable but i think it's a bit cleaner
to put it as a property on class like
this this dot image equals new image
this is just image class constructor and
it will create new blank html image
element
this dot image src will give it source
attribute and i set it to boom.png if
you want to use the same file you can
download it in the video description
this image was kindly provided by one of
my favorite game artists i will link his
website in the video description as well
he has a lot of cool game art there if
you are interested
to animate this sprite sheet i will crop
out one frame and i will be jumping to
the right by the amount of sprite width
frame by frame to do that i will need
this.frame variable i will set it to 0
at first we will also need to add some
behavior to this class we do it by
creating class methods i will need one
to update and one to draw my explosions
update method will only have one job for
now to increase this dot frame from line
17 by one for every animation loop this
dot frame plus plus
draw method will take values from the
constructor and it will draw current
frame of animation on canvas we will use
built in html canvas draw image method
that takes image we pass to it and it
draws it draw image method has three
versions with three or five or nine
arguments depending on how much control
you want over the image you are drawing
since we are animating a sprite sheet we
will use the longest version with nine
arguments the arguments we need to pass
to it is image we want to draw
source x source y source width and
source height
of area you want to crop out from the
source sprite sheet
and destination x destination y
destination width and destination height
these last four arguments will determine
where on destination canvas you want to
place that cropped out image on two
it might sound complicated but it makes
sense if you use it couple of times when
you learn how to use draw image method
and you get really comfortable with it
you will have complete control over
sprite sheets you want to animate it's
really good and so useful so now i will
replace these placeholder values with
actual variables we prepared inside
constructor image we want to draw is
this dot image from line 15.
source x is the only one from these nine
arguments that might be a bit more
complicated for beginners to calculate
current horizontal position i need to
take sprite width from line 11 and i
multiplied times this dot frame from
line 17 as the program runs this dot
frame increases inside update method on
line 20 we will get frame 0 1 2 3 4
because we are multiplying sprite with
times frame
source y is horizontal y coordinate we
want to crop out from the source since
this sprite sheet has only one row
source y will always be zero source
width is this dot sprite width and
source height is this dot sprite height
from line 12.
so now we told javascript what sprite
sheet we want to draw and what area we
want to crop out from it
to display just one frame
now i just simply tell it where on
canvas i want to draw it
destination x is this dot x from line 9
destination y is this dot y from line 10
destination width and height is this dot
width and distort height from lines 13
and 14. our class is complete this is
all we need to trigger this dust cloud
animation and attach it to any event we
want to
there are many events we can do here
let's try one i call window.add event
listener built in javascript method we
will be listening for mouseclick event
and in callback function that will run
every time click event occurs
i will at first just draw a simple
rectangle to make sure everything works
fill rectangle expects four arguments x
y width and height
i want this rectangle to be drawn at the
current coordinates of my mouse click
to do that is easy callback function on
event listener has access to built-in
event objects usually we name it e or
event like this
but you can name it anything you want
javascript knows that this argument
passed to callback function on event
listener refers to event object you can
put abc here and it will still work as
long as you refer to it as abc later in
the code as well basically here i am
saying take event object with
information about this click event and
save it in a custom variable i call e
if i console log this e i will get an
error
let's comment outline 29 for a second
now whenever i click on canvas i get
this console log that contains all
information about current click event
that just occurred if i open it i can
see we have all kinds of details here
all we want is where on canvas this
event happened so we can draw a
rectangle at the least coordinates i can
see x and y coordinates are down here
as properties called x and y now that i
know the name of properties i'm looking
for i can use these values inside fill
rectangle method i want to draw it at x
coordinate of current mouse click
i know that value is stored on my event
object in a property called x as we just
saw so i put e dot x here and e dot y
width and height could be anything i
want i want my rectangle to be for
example 50 x 50 pixels
i can't see anything when i click that
is because i used black background and
default fill is also black i set fill
style to white color when i click you
can see that we draw a white rectangle
on canvas but it's not being drawn under
mouse why is that in this case event.x
gives me value that doesn't account for
this top and left margin between start
of my webpage and start of canvas what i
need to do is offset my coordinates to
account for it good way to do that is to
measure canvas position first you can do
this with one line of code i create a
custom variable called for example
canvas position and i set it equal to
canvas from line one and i call get
bounding client rectangle built-in
method on it
get bound inclined rectangle is a very
useful built-in javascript method it
returns an object provided information
about the size of an element and its
position relative to the viewport
i can console log my canvas position
variable now and you can see the object
here
it contains bottom left right and top
position on the graphics here you can
see exactly what these values represent
it also contains information about its
width and height and its x and y
position you can use this to measure any
html element on your page if you are
offsetting something it's really useful
i delete console log on line 7. i like
to clean up after myself as i go
so if i want my white rectangle to be
drawn under the current mouse position i
need to offset e dot x and e dot y by
top and left margin between viewport and
canvas horizontal x coordinate is e dot
x minus canvas position dot left
now you can see that horizontal position
is exactly under mouse
i also fix vertical position by saying e
dot y minus canvas position top
perfect
you can see that rectangle is being
drawn towards the right bottom from my
mouse cursor this is how rectangles work
on canvas if i want my mouse to be
exactly in the middle of the rectangle
both vertically and horizontally i need
to do one more small tweak here i offset
my positions by half of width and height
my width and height is 50 so i offset x
and y by minus 25
now when i click mouse cursor is exactly
in the middle of white rectangle when i
place it on canvas i know this might be
very basic for some of you but i want
beginners to be able to follow along
with us this course is for everyone
now that we understand how to draw a
simple rectangle on click let's take it
to the next level and use our custom
explosion class to create sprite
animation every time we click somewhere
on canvas first thing i want to do is to
take this calculation that offsets and
centers my horizontal and vertical
positions and i put them here in
separate variables this is just to keep
my code clean and easy to read
i call them position x and position y
and i just copy this formula in there
i can't really do -25 here if i want to
keep my code base reusable i need to
offset it inside my explosion class i
will show you in a second
i do this position y vertical formula
i remove console log on line 31 and i
also delete my white rectangle we will
be drawing animated cartoon explosions
now
on line 5 i have this array that will
hold all my current active explosion
objects the goal is to use explosion
class on line 8 and when we click we
push new object into this array from
line 5. we cycle through all its frames
using update method on line 20 we draw
each step to display the animation and
then when we reach the last frame we
remove the object from the array and we
delete it
line 31 inside click event listener i
take this empty explosions array from
line 5 and i call push on it push is a
built-in array method it will take
whatever we pass to it as an argument
and it will push it at the end of the
array
i pass it new explosion
the new keyword will find my class on
line 8 and it will run its constructor
to create a new object based on this
class's blueprint on line 9 i can see my
constructor expects two arguments for x
and y coordinates this is important
because we need to know where on canvas
we want to create this triggered
animation here on line 31 i just pass it
position x and position y variables we
calculated on lines 29 and 30.
so now i have a way to add new explosion
object into my array on mouse click
i will need a function to cycle through
all objects in the array to update and
draw them
let's create animation loop i will write
a custom function called animate inside
i create a for loop that will cycle
through all elements in the array
sometimes if we click really fast in
sequence we will have many objects
animated at the same time sometimes this
array will be empty it will have 0
elements and this loop will be skipped
for each object in the array we will
call its update method
and also it's a draw method
to create animation loop i call built in
request animation frame function and i
pass it animate the name of its parent
function from line 34.
now i can call animate to kick off
animation loop
awesome this is working kinda we can see
old frames because we are not clearing
canvas and i also need to center my
animation around the cursor better
to only see the current frame i call
built in clear rectangle method and i
want to clear the entire canvas
if you look closely you will notice we
are skipping frame 0 because update
method increases frame variable by 1
before we draw the first frame i want
each triggered animation to have its own
timer that way we can stagger the
animation speed
on line 19 i created this dot timer
property and i set it to 0.
on line 22 inside animation loop i
increase this dot timer by 1 for each
animation step now i can say if this dot
timer is divisible by 10 with a
remainder of 0 this simply means run
this code every 10 frames
only when timer is divisible by 10
increase frame by 1. this will slow down
the animation timer has to increase 10
times before frame increases once
now we can see the initial first frame
as well and animation speed is 10 times
slower than before
let's make width and height slightly
bigger on lines 14 and 15.
you can see that my animation is drawn
too much down from mouse cursor same as
we did with white rectangle before i
want mouse cursor to be in the center of
the animation
to do that i can simply offset x and y
by half of width and height i can either
do it here or i can also do it here
inside draw image method it would give
us the same result i can't offset x and
y here in my event listener because at
this point i don't know what width and
height my animation is i could hard code
some values here but that would not be
reusable
i think the cleanest way is to move
this.x and this.y to go after width and
height here
so that they can see these properties
and i offset them here this dot x is
equal to x which was passed as an
argument on line 9 minus this dot width
from line 12 divided by 2. this centered
my animation around the cursor
horizontally
and this dot y is y minus this dot
height divided by two
perfect
right now i'm just adding more and more
objects into my array they stay there
even after they stopped animating
you can see that if we console
explosions array from line 5.
we are just adding more and more objects
into the array every time we click i
need to find a way to remove the ones
that have stopped animating we could do
object pooling here to avoid
instantiating and deleting objects over
and over but i will show you how to do
that in some more advanced tutorial
today let's just do the simplest
solution on line 45 inside the for loop
that runs through all objects in my
explosions array after i draw and update
them i check if this particular object
has frame property more than 5.
frame property comes from line 18 and on
line 24 we are increasing it to draw our
animation frame by frame sprite sheet
has 5 frames and we count from 0 so i
know if frame property is more than 5 we
played the entire animation
on line 44
if this particular object has frame
property more than 5 i will remove it
using built-in array splice method
splice method just wants index of object
we want to remove so i for index and i
want to remove one object at this index
so i comma 1 to make sure the next
object in the array is correctly updated
and animated after we removed its
neighbor we need to adjust index by -1 i
minus minus because i'm controlling my
array on line 36 in browser console i
can see that we are correctly adding and
removing objects from the array awesome
we have a solid infrastructure for
triggered animation and we can connect
this code to collision coordinates for
example and run this animation when two
objects collide in our game we can also
connect it to different events and user
input it doesn't have to be a click
event to avoid code repetition i will
put this code into a separate custom
function i call for example create
animation
i cut all this code
and i paste it here
i call create animation from inside my
click event we need to pass down
reference to event object to calculate
coordinates like this
look what happens if i connect it to
mousemove event
it gives us pretty cool effect
experiments this looks like some deep
sea creature
when i move it like this you can see
that the first frame of dust cloud
animation is always rotated the same way
maybe i want to rotate it a different
angle every time we create new explosion
to do that i use built-in save and
restore html canvas methods let me just
write this and then i will explain
what's happening
translate will set rotation center point
in this case i want to rotate around its
center so this dot x and this dot y
i want each one to be rotated by a
different random angle value i create a
new property on line 20 called this dot
angle
circle is 360 degrees
html canvas rotate method expects
radians so 360 degrees is roughly 6.2
radians this dot angle will be a random
number between 0 and 6.2
i pass this.angle to canvas rotate
method on line 31 like this
now it's rotating too much
it's because i translated the drawing
context to this.x and this.y on line 30.
then i rotate it and then i go from that
point further to another this dot x and
this.y here x and y coordinates for our
animation are already captured here on
line 30. so on line 32 i replace this.x
and this.y to zero think about it this
way i use translate which would be point
zero zero on canvas to this.x and this.y
so between these save and restore calls
0 0 is actually this dot x and this.y
that's better i also need to offset it
by this.width divided by 2 and this dot
height divided by 2 here inside draw
method
and remove it on lines 14 and 15. this
is how you rotate anything on canvas you
save the current state of canvas to make
sure the following changes affect only
one draw call i translate rotation
center point on top of my current object
i want to rotate i rotate the entire
canvas context by random angle value we
draw our image and we restore canvas
context to the original save point to
make sure this translate and rotate only
affects one draw call of one object
canvas rotation is one of the more
difficult concepts for beginners to
understand i spent the entire halloween
episode explaining it so don't worry if
this was too fast for you if you want
more details on how to rotate things on
canvas i will link that episode in the
video description for now let's just
move on you can see each dust cloud is
now rotated randomly so the trail itself
looks more chaotic as every dust trail
should let's comment out mouse move
event
now we have this nice cartoon dust cloud
animation whenever we click on canvas
it's missing something let's give it
some sound it's really easy to attach
sound to event animations in javascript
i go to opengameart.org
and let's click browse
and sound effects
i remember there was one i really liked
here on left i will type magic in title
search
[Music]
oh yes it's this one magic special
effect spark it contains four cool magic
sounds
i download it and i take the one called
ice blast
i rename it to boom.wav
for you the path might be different if
you chose different file or you placed
it in a different folder i only want to
play the sound file once per animation
so in update method on line 25
i say if this dot frame is equal to 0
take this dot sound from line 21 and
call build in play method on it like
this
choosing the right sound and animation
speed is very important to how your game
feels in the end
if you do it well your game will be
satisfying and your users will love to
play it don't forget to click the like
if you learned something new today for
more vanilla javascript game development
and animations check out my playlist i
will link relevant videos in the
description down below thanks for coding
with me today hope you had fun
do you want to build awesome games and
master front and web development at the
same time in this final javascript and
html5 canvas game tutorial i want to
show you 5 techniques i wish i used
sooner today we will build a game
completely from scratch step by step
with no frameworks and no libraries we
will learn how to achieve pixel perfect
collision detection using colors how to
use time stamps and delta time to make
sure our game runs at the same speed on
different machines we will learn about
arrays and i will show you how to remove
all the game objects using array filter
method and how to use array sort method
to create a correct draw order in a 2d
game we will also talk about modern
javascript syntax and we will learn how
to make our animation code cleaner and
less repetitive with spread operator i
will also share many small tips and
tricks as we go along students of
today's course will get two premium
spreadsheets completely for free kindly
provided by this amazing artist check
out his website for more click the like
please if you are excited and ready to
learn let's talk about javascript have
fun
[Music]
i want you to build projects you can
show off to someone and be proud about
so as usual we will build a game and by
the end of this tutorial you will have a
complete project i learned some of these
techniques from my friend raju he has a
lot of other cool things to teach you if
you want you can go and check out his
courses i will link some in the video
description some of you tell me that you
only make games by animating divs and
other html elements it's a great way to
start and learn the basics html canvas
can handle many more moving objects at
the same time so if you want to try and
build games that have a little bit more
complexity maybe this is the time for
you to give canvas a chance let me show
you it is easier than you think to build
interactive animated projects with it i
will take you through it step by step
and help you understand i have a
introductory game development series and
a beginner playlist where i go slower
over all the important techniques if you
find yourself struggling at some point
or you think i'm going a bit too fast
maybe try to watch that one first over
there we also create really cool
projects but i keep beginners in mind at
all times it might be an easier starting
point for you and then you will be ready
to take on videos like this one and
actually properly understand everything
i will leave some links in the video
description let's go
[Music]
let's create some ravens i will have an
array that will hold all my raven
objects it needs to be a led variable
not const i will explain why in a minute
i create a custom class called raven it
will be a blueprint based on which all
my animated ravens will be created by
javascript constructor will create one
blank new object every time it is called
and it will assign it properties and
values as we define them here
it will have width property and its
value will be for example 100 pixels
height will be 50 pixels this dot x
starting horizontal x coordinate will be
just behind the right edge of canvas so
they can fly across to the left so
canvas width vertical y coordinate will
be a random number between 0 and canvas
height since rectangles on canvas are
drawn from the top left corner going
right and down i don't want any ravens
to be partially hidden below the bottom
edge of screen initial y position will
be a random number between 0 and canvas
height minus the height of a raven
between here and somewhere around here
it needs to be in brackets like this to
give us the correct range of values
direction x will be horizontal speed
basically it will be a random number
between a 3 and 8. i want ravens to
bounce up and down as they fly so the
initial vertical speed i call direction
y for example will be a random number
between minus 2.5 and plus 2.5 minus
values will move upwards plus values
will move the raven down along the
vertical y-axis update method will move
the raven around and adjust any values
that needs to be adjusted before we draw
the next frame at first i will just
simply move it to the left so this dot x
from line 11 minus equals this direction
x from line 13. draw method will take
these updated values and any drawing
code we put here will represent single
raven object visually first let's start
with a simple rectangle i call built in
fill rectangle method and i pass it x y
width and height ravenclass is complete
we have a way to create ravens let's
create animation loop i create a custom
function i call for example animate it
will take argument i call timestamp this
will be a numeric value in milliseconds
so one second will be number 1000 i will
show you exactly how it works any code
inside this animate function will run
over and over updating and drawing our
game frame by frame
the first thing we will do between every
frame is clear old paint all the
drawings from the previous frame so
clear rectangle and i want to clear the
entire canvas from coordinates 0 0 to
coordinates canvas with canvas height we
will run some code in between and then
at the end we will use
requestanimationframer method that we'll
call animate again create an endless
animation loop
i will console.log test to make sure it
works and i also need to call animate
like this on the first page load to
trigger the first loop in browser
console i can see the loop is running
perfect
it's good to test your code as you go to
make sure there are no typos it's safer
than to write the entire project and
then try to look for bugs there step by
step approach will save you a lot of
time
i can also test if my raven class is
working i will use it to create many
ravens but i can also just create one
i create a variable called raven and i
assign it to new raven like this this
will create one raven object for me
which will have access to update class
method from line 16 and draw method from
line 19.
i call it from inside my animation loop
and
here's my raven it just flies over once
if i refresh the page it flies again
this works so far we are doing great
instead of having one raven i want to
create a new raven periodically and i
want to make sure that periodic event is
triggered at the same interval on very
slow old computers and on brand new
gaming super pcs to make sure the
timings in my game are consistent and
based on time and milliseconds rather
than on the power of my computer and its
ability to serve frames at a certain
speed i will use timestamps i will
compare how many milliseconds elapsed
since the last loop and only when we
reach certain amount of time between
frames only then we will draw the next
frame it's actually very simple but it
might take some time to get used to it
if you are a beginner let's do it and
see how it works
what is happening here we are calling
animate using request animation frame
animate becomes a callback function on
requestanimationframe method and default
javascript behavior for callback here is
to pass it automatic timestamp as an
argument its value is in milliseconds
just so you know where this timestamp
will be coming from it's a default
javascript behavior when using request
animation frame it will pass its
callback function
in our case animate automatic timestamp
argument we will see it better in a
minute as the loop runs request
animation frame calls animate over and
over passing it timestamps my goal here
is to take time from the current loop
save that value run the loop again with
a new timestamp value and compare them
to see how many milliseconds it took in
between frames
i will need some helper variables here
time to next raven will be a variable
that will accumulate millisecond values
between frames until it reaches my
interval value and trigger next frame
initially it will start at 0. raven
interval will be a value in milliseconds
every time time to next raven
accumulates enough to reach 500
milliseconds it will trigger next raven
and it will reset back to 0 to start
counting again
i will also need variable that will hold
value of timestamp from the previous
loop the initial value will be 0.
inside my animation loop i will
calculate delta time this will be a
value in milliseconds between timestamp
from this loop and saved timestamp value
from the previous loop
after i used last time value to
calculate delta time i will assign last
time variable from line 8 to the new
timestamp passed here in this loop so
that we have that value ready to compare
in the next loop
let's console timestamp
i can see i misspelled last time here
capitalization of letters is very
important in javascript
you can see in console i'm getting
timestamps in milliseconds since the
loop started the very first value is a
second so it goes like this seven eight
seconds and so on so this is the
automatically passed timestamp value
here it's generated by default by
javascript because we made animate into
a callback function on request animation
frame method here on line 33
there is a way to do this without
calculating delta time at all but i
haven't tested that and i'm not sure
what is the browser support for that
technique so let's go with this tested
safer solution today i will remove
console.log leaving too many console
logs in your projects especially the
ones running so often like this can
affect your performance so keep that in
mind on line 6 i have time to next raven
variable here in my animation loop i
will increase its value by delta time
for every animation frame
i will console log delta time now
again i need to be careful about
spelling my variables correctly here
i can see that on my computer time
between frames is around 16 milliseconds
my computer is powerful and it is able
to serve a new frame every 16
milliseconds
on your computer the number might be
different i would actually be very
interested to know if it's the same
number or a different one for most of
you if you are following and coding with
me can you leave a quick comment with
that number please you can just type 16
if it's the same number or whatever
different number you are getting right
now
so time to next raven starts at 0 and is
increasing by this value of around 16
milliseconds per each frame
on line 7 i created a variable called
raven interval and i set it to 500
milliseconds in my animation loop i will
say when time to next raven reaches this
raven interval
when this number that starts at 0 and
increases by the amount of milliseconds
that happened between frames reaches 500
at that point we will take raven's array
from line 10 and use built-in array push
method
i will pass it new raven which will
trigger my raven class constructor
create one new raven object and it will
push it inside raven's array
when that happens i set time to next
raven back to zero so it can start
counting again from the beginning
i know i just said raven a lot
time to next raven starts at zero it
increases by the amount of a delta time
by the amount of milliseconds between
each frame
which will be dependent on performance
of your computer however since slower
computers will take longer to serve the
next frame
their delta time will be a higher number
and it will move towards our target
raven interval in bigger steps as a
result this code will be triggered at
the exactly same time on slow and fast
computers this is one way how you can
properly trigger periodic events in your
projects using time stamps this might be
a bit too much to wrap your head around
if you are a beginner it's one of the
reasons i don't always use timestamps in
my animation tutorials because i can't
really explain all of this in every
single video but try to learn it if you
can if you still don't get it don't
worry i will explain it in future
projects again so eventually it will
start making more sense repetition and
practice is the best way to learn at
least for me it is
i console cravens and i see nothing is
happening even though my animation loop
is running it seems that this if
statement never evaluates the true so
the code inside is never triggered
controlling is great for debugging i
console time to next raven first
oh i can see its value is a non not a
number
here's our problem
why is it this value it must be because
we are adding delta time to it here i
consolidate delta time and i can see
that the first initial value is also not
a number delta time is calculated here
on line 30 so now i console log
timestamp
and this is the root of our problem that
cascaded all the way through my
variables that use each other to
calculate their values when the animate
loop starts the very first time stamp is
undefined because timestamp only gets
created on the second loop here on line
39 when we call request animation frame
to fix that is easy i just need to give
timestamp a starting value on the first
call of animate that starts my animation
loop here
i will pass it timestamp of 0 as an
argument
awesome that fixed it and since i'm
consolidating raven's array on line 36 i
can see it adds new raven object to the
array every 500 milliseconds
i remove the console log we have data
for ravens inside the array we just need
to cycle through that array through
every single raven object and call their
update and draw methods so that we can
actually see movement on canvas
i declared my ravens array here on line
10.
inside animation loop i will use this
syntax which might be a bit unusual for
you here i'm creating so called array
literal by just dropping square brackets
like that i'm creating a quick new array
on the fly
and these three dots are so called
spread
operator now i'm spreading my ravens
array inside this new quick array i just
created
spread operator allows us to spread
iterable such as this ravens array to be
expanded into another array let's finish
writing this line of code and i will
explain why i'm doing that since we are
dealing with an array i can call
built-in array for each method i need to
assign it a variable name for each
object in this array so we can use it as
we iterate
as we cycle through it i will call that
variable for example object so this
object variable now represents each
individual raven object in raven's array
and i can say for each raven object in
ravens array call their associated
update method we wrote on line 20.
so this line of code will cycle through
the entire ravens array and it will
trigger update method on all of them
since we are inside animation loop this
will happen over and over for each
animation frame
i will do exactly the same thing for
draw method from line 23
and we are updating and drawing our
ravens awesome
now you might ask why am i using this
fancy syntax here where i created a new
array and i use the spread operator to
expand my ravens into that new array
just so that i can call update and draw
on them i could have just called it on
the raven's array directly without
expanding it like this the reason i did
that is because when i create particle
class in a minute i can just spread my
particles into the same array along with
the ravens as long as my particle class
will have update and draw methods to
call the code will work and i can call
all my classes by just expanding more
and more arrays in here
i can for example also have an array of
enemies obstacles power ups and other
elements in my game i can spread all of
them into a single array and call their
update and draw methods all at once i
will show you exactly what that looks
like in a minute i think it makes the
code look clean and easy to read what do
you think
online 34 i'm periodically adding new
object into raven's array right now it's
an endlessly growing array of objects
and on lines 37 and 38 i'm iterating
over all of them even the ones that have
moved off screen and are not visible
anymore eventually this would build up
and cause performance issues so i need a
way to remove the ones that have moved
past the left edge of game area
sometimes i use array splice method to
do that i used splice in many other
tutorials before but there might be a
better way to do it using splice while
cycling through the array removes
objects from somewhere in the middle of
the array so then we have to write code
to adjust the index to make sure
neighbors of that object don't get
skipped easier way to discard objects we
don't need might be using built-in array
filter method we will just run through
the array call update and draw for each
raven and then we will filter out ravens
that have moved past the left edge of
screen what does that look like in
javascript let me show you
i create a new class property called
marked for deletion and initially i set
it to false
in update method i say if horizontal x
coordinate of this particular even
object is less than 0 minus this dot
width meaning it has moved all the way
behind the left edge i set its marked
for deletion property to true inside
animation loop i take the variable that
holds my raven's array from line 10 and
i reassign it to a new array
that's why the initial declaration of
raven's array needs to be a led variable
not const because const variable cannot
be reassigned
it will be the same array but objects
that have marked for deletion property
set to true will be filtered out filter
method creates a new array with all
elements that passed the test
implemented by provided function so here
i'm saying take raven's variable from
line 10 and replace it with the same
array but i wanted that array to be
filled only with objects for which this
condition is true
here we have a little bit of double
negative sorry the test in my callback
function wants marked for deletion value
to be false if marked for deletion is
false then this condition evaluates as
true and this particular even object
will not be deleted again and said very
simply take raven's array from line 10
delete everything in there and replace
it with contents of the same ravens
array but only with those objects that
have marked for deletion property set to
false
exclamation mark here means false
since we are going to look in raven's on
line 42 i can check in browser console
and i can see that number of objects in
the array is between 3 and 6. it only
contains ravens that are active and
visible on screen perfect
i remove the console log these ravens
look a bit boring just black rectangles
let's use animated sprite sheets instead
on my class i create a new property
called this dot image and i set it equal
to new image i set source on that new
image as raven png
art for this episode was made by this
amazing artist link to his website is in
the video description he also allowed me
to share this particular spreadsheet
completely for free with my students so
you can download it along with all other
project files in the description for
more game art check out his website and
support him if you can there aren't many
good 2d artists like this and he's one
of my favorites i try to buy his game
art assets whenever i can
i will need a couple of helper
properties here this dot sprite width is
width of a single frame in my raven's
sprite sheet in this case 271 pixels
if you are using a different sprite
sheet take its width and divide it by
the number of horizontal frames maybe it
would be easier if you follow along with
me using the same sprite sheet and then
when you understand the code and it's
working for you you can replace it
sprite height is 194 pixels
on line 31 inside draw method i call
built in draw image method it expects
between 3 and 9 arguments depending on
how much control you want over the image
you are drawing minimum is 3 arguments
image you want to draw so this dot image
from line 20 and x and y coordinates
where to draw it
now it's just simply taking the entire
sprite sheet and drawing the whole thing
at its original size
we can also give it optional width and
height arguments which will scale it
i need to make sure my brackets and
commas are correct here
so now it's scaling the entire sprite
sheet to fit inside 100 times 50 pixels
let's do stroke rectangle here so we can
see it better
we can also give it a total of 9
arguments
these additional 4 arguments will allow
us to only crop portion of the image
source x source y source width and
source height
so the longest version of draw image
method takes 9 arguments image we want
to draw
x y width and height of area to group
out from the source image
x y with an height of where to place
that cropped out image on destination
canvas
let's just crop out the first frame now
source x and source y is scored in at 0
0.
source width is sprite width and source
height is sprite height
you can see our ravens are a bit
stretched it's because these initial
width and height values are completely
disconnected from the actual dimensions
and aspect ratio of our sprite sheet
i move sprite width and sprite height up
here so that we can use them to
calculate values that come after with
could be for example sprite width
divided by 2 and height could be height
divided by 2.
this works but now all our ravens are
the same size and as my friend marcus
says multiplication is faster than
division so let's create a new property
called size modifier and it will be a
random number between 0.4 and 1.
now instead of dividing it by 2 i will
multiply width and height by this random
size modifier value which will make the
ravens be different sizes
while still preserving the aspect ratio
so no stretching
this dot frame is the number of frames
in our sprite sheet counting from zero
so the initial value will be zero this
frame
this dot max frame could be four or five
depending on how you reset it back to
frame zero let's go with four maybe i
will adjust my frame reset check to this
value in a minute
if this dot frame from line 25 is more
than this dot max frame from line 26 set
this dot frame to zero
else increase frame by one
to actually reflect this value on canvas
i replace source x argument on line 37
with this dot frame times this dot
sprite width so it will go 0
1 2 3 4 5
and back to 0
as frame variable cycles on line 32
all the ravens are flopping wings very
fast and at the same interval
how do we speed up or slow down sprite
animation the speed at which the next
frame is served
and how do we make sure it's consistent
across all machines on old slow
computers and new powerful ones as well
we can do that by using delta time we
calculated delta time on line 43 inside
animation loop
delta time is the difference in
milliseconds between last frame and
current frame and this value will differ
based on power of your computer some
computers can surf frames much faster
than others
since i already calculated this speed at
which my machine can surf frames in my
game i will just pass a delta time as an
argument to my update method here on
line 50. that way it will be available
up
here let's test it i console delta time
it won't be available until i passed
delta time as an argument here as well
now the values are coming through
i will need a couple of helper
properties
time since flap will be 0 at first it
will be growing by the amount of delta
time until it reaches value in flap
interval
then it will trigger next frame of
sprite sheet and reset back to zero
this time since flop plus equals a delta
time remember that delta time is the
amount of milliseconds between frames so
faster computers will have smaller
numbers here slower computers will have
high delta time values as a result it
will reach the target value at the same
time on slow and fast computers unifying
animation speed across different devices
i say if this.time since flap from line
27 is more than flap interval from line
28 only then run this code that handles
cycling through frames
for this to work every time this
condition is met and if statement is
entered i also have to reset time since
flap back to 0 so it can start counting
again when to serve the next frame
now i can change the value of flap
interval and you can see it changes the
speed at which we cycle through frames
in our sprite sheet
500 milliseconds per frame is very slow
five milliseconds per frame is fast
faster than my computer can handle us
since we know my computer can handle the
serve next frame every 16 milliseconds
as maximum i can also randomize flap
interval so that each raven animates at
a slightly different rhythm
random number between 100 and 200 feels
too slow
how about a random number between 50 and
100
that feels better
quick recap we are calculating delta
time difference in milliseconds between
last frame and current frame the value
of delta time will be different on slow
and fast computers to make sure we have
consistent time in across different
machines we have time since flap
variable that increases by the value of
delta time per each frame until it
reaches target value in the flap
interval
then it serves the next frame resets
back to 0 and starts counting again
preparing to serve the next frame
ravens are flying in straight lines from
right to left i also created the
direction y property on line 21. it's a
random number between minus 2.5 and plus
2.5 so summary events will move up and
some will move down in negative or
positive direction along vertical y axis
based on this value
inside update method i say
this dot y plus equals this dot
direction y now you can see some
vertical movement
it's now a little bit harder to target
them making our game more difficult for
players
one thing i don't like now is how they
disappear behind the top and bottom edge
i want them to move all the way across
the screen and when they touch bottom or
top edge of game area i want them to
kind of bounce and reverse their
vertical movement to the opposite
direction
i do that with an if statement i say if
this dot y is less than 0
or if this dot y is more than canvas
height minus distort height
set their direction property from line
21 to its opposite value this to
direction y times -1
now they just bounce when they reach
edges of the game area
let's draw score i create a led variable
called score and i assign it to 0
initially
i create a custom function called draw
score inside i set fill style to white i
want white numbers
i call built in fill text method
inside i will hard code string score
colon space plus score variable we just
declared and i wanted a drone on canvas
at coordinates 50 75 for example
now i just call draw score from inside
my animation loop keep in mind since we
are drawing everything on the same kind
of a sequence in which you call this
will affect how our game is layered
i want score to be behind ravens so
first i draw score then i draw ravens
it's very small so let's set the global
canvas font to 50 pixels impact
now it's easier to read
i will play with it a bit i can use
canvas shadows here but i can also just
draw the same text again at slightly
different coordinates for example 55 and
80.
the first layer will be black
the second layer will be white
in the game we will have to click ravens
before they disappear behind the left
edge of screen i create an event
listener for click event callback
function on event listener has the
default access to this event object i
assign it variable name for example e it
contains information about the click
event that happened for example its x
and y coordinates in relation to
viewport if i console e dot x and e dot
y i get coordinates of my click whenever
i click somewhere in the game area i
promised we would do collision detection
by color today to do that we first need
to know what color is the pixel we are
clicking on
i create a custom variable i call for
example detect pixel color it will be
equal to built in get image data method
get image data simply scans area of
canvas and returns an array like object
called uint8 clamped array it's a simple
data structure full of unassigned 8-bit
integers
it's clamped which means it can contain
only integers whole numbers between a
certain value range specifically between
0 and 255.
let's scan canvas and inspect what it
gives us
get image data needs four arguments x y
with and height of area we want to scan
i want to scan just one pixel we click
on with mouse so coordinates of this
click event e dot x e dot y
and width and height of scanned area
will be just one pixel we want pixel
perfect precision here
okay let's just console log this
variable to see in what format get image
data gives us the pixel color
to make sure we understand how it works
if you are getting error at this point
keep watching i will explain it and i
will show you how to deal with it now
whenever i click somewhere on canvas get
image data scans area of one pixel
directly under the mouse click and it
gives us this image data object
this auto-generated image data object
contains three main properties
data property which is an array
currently it has four numbers inside and
within height of scanned area in our
case one pixel the way color data is
structured here is that each four
elements in this data array represent
one pixel specifically it's red green
blue and alpha value
if you use css you know that any color
can be created by combining a certain
amount of red green and blue
the only difference between css rgba
declaration and this is that in css
opacity is a value between 0 and 1. here
opacity alpha is also a number between 0
and 255.
0 is transparent
255 is fully visible
here for example you can see i clicked
and it gave us 0 0 0 for red green and
blue and 0 for alpha it means we click
somewhere in the empty area keep in mind
that canvas is just the ravens and score
the rest is transparent rainbow colors
you see are on the background and are
applied to body element with css
we are calling get image data on ctx
variables so it is just scanning that
particular canvas element it doesn't see
anything else
some of you might be getting error when
you click on canvas and try to run get
image data on it we are drawing sprite
sheets our raven images on canvas in
some browsers you won't be able to call
get image data on the same canvas where
you draw images it will give you an
error that says something like canvas
was tainted by cross-origin data if you
are running your code locally most
likely you see that error i'm using
local server so i'm not getting that
error right now it's a security measure
related to cross-origin resource sharing
apparently there could be viruses hidden
in some images and by scanning that
image with get image data you could
expose yourself to that virus there are
many ways to get around this problem and
scan canvas without exposing yourself to
any potential risks
in our case it's simple let me show you
but first i will assign a differently
colored hitbox to each raven so i want
one canvas that has only these hitboxes
and no ravens
because when i click it i want to get
color of that particular hitbox not of
the black raven if i create a secondary
canvas and i use it just to draw these
hitboxes and no images it won't give me
tainted canvas error i will explain more
as we write it in index.html i create an
additional canvas with an id of
collision canvas
in style css i comment out rainbow
background for a moment so that it's
very clear what we are doing
the same as i set up the first canvas i
will also set up this new collision
canvas
be careful here i always make mistakes
and typos when assigning multiple
canvases like this for some reason i
don't know why
constant variable called collision
canvas is document getelementbyid
collisioncanvas
collisionctx which is context is
collisioncanvas.getcontext2d
i also set collision canvas width and
height
just to check i give it red background
yes it's covering the entire browser
window perfect on my raven class i
create a property called random colors
at the point where each raven is created
i want to roll the dice and randomly
give it red green and blue color value
we know that color values can be in a
range between 0 and 255 so red will be
math at random times 255 like this
it will give us decimal points i need
only integers here so i wrap it in
math.floor
i do the same thing for green and blue
now we have three random values in this
array assigned to each raven object
i create one additional property called
this dot color and here i concatenate
rgba color declaration using these
values red is random colors index zero
green is index one
blue is index 2 plus closing bracket
like this
to use this color i declare fill
rectangle on line 54 and i set fill
style to this dot color from line 37 now
each raven has a random red green and
blue color assigned when it's created by
our class constructor and we use these
three values to create rgb color for its
hidden box hitbox means collision
detection area and in our case it's the
colored rectangle around each raven we
can also do much more complex shapes and
still get pixel perfect collision
detection but for purposes of this
tutorial rectangles are fine i don't
want to complicate things too much this
tutorial is to help you understand the
technique so now each raven has an array
of three random values between 0 and 255
and these values are used to draw its
hitbox
we will use these values scan as a
unique password for each raven we click
on canvas get rgb value of that pixel we
clicked on using getimagedata method and
we compare them with this random colors
property if they all match we know we
click on this particular raven
this technique has one downside there is
a very small chance that there will be
two identical colors generated next to
each other but since we do random number
between 0 and 255 3 times
and we only have between three and seven
active ravens on the screen at any given
time the chances of that happening are
astronomically low if we have any math
experts who can run the numbers let me
know in the comments it will be one in
millions possibly billions now i told
you what i want to do what does that
look like in javascript
before we write collision code there is
one small thing layers i want big ravens
to be up in front and small ravens to be
behind to create a sense of depth and
correct the draw order in a 2d space
right now sometimes you see smaller
ravens up front because they are drawn
here on line 83 based on the order at
which they were pushed into the array on
line 78 i don't have to sort them for
every animation frame only every time i
push new raven to the array
i want to sort out all objects in the
array by size i use built in array sort
method sort method will simply
reorganize order of elements in the
array their indexes based on provided
check in a callback function it will run
through the array and compare every
element against every other element and
sort them in ascending or descending
order
ascending order is default it will run
over my ravens array and use these a and
b variables for each object
i can choose many different properties
to sort them by today i will choose
width because i know ravens in the back
will have smaller width than the ones up
front
i'm just gonna return it like this
simple syntax and i'm comparing width of
every element in the array against the
width of every other element in the same
array a minus b will sort my array in
ascending order based on width which is
exactly what i want i want small ones to
be drawn first and larger ones to be
drawn on top you can read more about
built in javascript sort method online
we can see that it works large ravens
are up front and smaller ones are behind
perfect as i said i want to avoid
tainted canvas error so i need to make
sure i have a separate canvas i can scan
color from that doesn't have any images
drawn on it
i take collision context variable i
declared on line 6 and i draw my colored
rectangles on that canvas instead
by adjusting code here on lines 54 and
55.
nice that worked i can see we are not
clearing the old paint on that canvas so
on line 74 i call clear rectangle on
collision context as well now we have
two canvas elements one has colored
collision rectangle and the other has
ravens and score drawn on it on line 68
inside click event listener instead of
scanning my main game canvas for pixel
data
i will scan just collision canvas
instead
now when i click it will ignore the
black ravens and imagedata object will
give me red green blue and alpha value
of rectangle i clicked on
i will compare it with red green blue
value inside random colors property on
each raven to know which one was clicked
on and then i will set its marked for
deletion property to true there are many
techniques you can use to compare two
array-like objects against each other
let's just keep it simple
when i click on one of these rectangles
i can see the values are inside this
image data object on a property called
data
data is an array with red green blue and
alpha value of pixel we clicked on
i create a variable to get hold of this
array
detect
pixelcolor.data which refers to this
uint8 clamped array with four elements
there is also a way to check for
collision detection between two objects
based on opacity alpha value like this
but today we will do collision between
point and shape between mouse and ravens
i will ignore alpha value from now on
and i will just focus on these three
values red green blue
so this pc pixel color variable holds
this data array with four elements i
take my ravens array and i call for each
on it
for each raven object in the array i
will check if its random colors property
from line 36 if the first element in the
array index 0 is the same value as pixel
we clicked on
at the same time we also need the second
and the third element to match if random
colors array on my raven matches exactly
red green and blue values on pixel we
clicked on we know we have a collision
index 0 is red index 1 is green index 2
is blue
we are comparing the 2.
if they match we have collision so i
will take that raven object and set its
marked for deletion property to true
and i will increase score variable by 1.
awesome it works i can click on ravens
and they disappear and increase my score
i can set opacity on collision canvas to
zero
and i can enable rainbow background on
body element
collision detection still works
correctly well done if you followed this
far you are doing great
what should we do next
how about we add explosion animation and
sound effect whenever we click on a
raven
i will just repeat the same pattern we
did for raven class i create an array
called explosions it will hold all
active animated explosion objects i will
create a class to create a blueprint for
these objects its constructor will
expect three arguments x y and size
because position and size will come from
the outside and will depend on the raven
we clicked on
this dot image will be new image
this dot image src will be boom png you
can download the spreadsheet for free in
the video description
sprite width will be 200 pixels
sprite height 179 pixels
this dot size will be size we passed as
an argument on line 61.
same for this dot x and this dot y these
values come from the outside this dot
frame active frame will start from zero
this dot sound will be new audio like
this
this dot sound src source and here as a
source you can add any sound you like
for example i will go to
opengameart.org website i click browse
sound effects and i will search for
magic sfx special effects
[Music]
i will choose this pack of 4 sounds i
download it and i will use the one
called ice blast
i will rename that file as a boom dot
wav
and i will add it to my project folder
you can choose a different sound if you
want you can also have multiple sounds
and play a random one here it's up to
you
in update method same as we did before i
will use delta time to time my animation
we will have one variable to accumulate
the delta time values called for example
time since last frame
it will start at zero
then we need a second variable to define
limit when the next frame triggers
i call it for example frame interval and
i set it to 200 milliseconds
i pass delta time as argument to update
method
it will be coming directly from
animation loop i will show you in a
minute this.time since last frame will
be slowly increasing by the amount of
delta time
if time since last frame is more than
frame interval 200 milliseconds i
increase this dot frame from line 69 by
one
i also want to play the sound when we
are on frame zero when the explosion
first appears there are better ways to
do that but for today i will simply
check if active frame of this explosion
is a zero and i take this sound from
line 70 and i call build in play method
on it
explosions will also need draw method
which will draw the actual sprite sheet
animation
we will pass the draw image 9 arguments
same as we did with ravens image we want
to draw this dot image from line 62 four
values for area to crop out single frame
so source x is this dot frame times this
dot sprite width source y will be zero
because we only have one row of sprites
source width will be
sprite width from line 64 and the source
height will be sprite height from 965.
so now we told javascript what area we
want to crop out now we need to give it
x y width and height where to place it
on destination canvas so this dot x this
dot y
and this dot size for width and distal
size for height
as this dot frame variable increases
here on line 79 because of this source x
property
here we will show frames 0 1 2 3 and 4.
now where do we trigger this code to
create and animate new explosion the
best place would be here i think
this if statement detects collision by
color
so when collision is detected i take
explosions array from line 59
and i push new explosion in there this
will trigger explosion class constructor
on line 61. i can see it expects value
for x and y coordinates and size because
i want explosion to depend on the size
of the raven we clicked so here we are
cycling through raven's array referring
to individual ravens as object i want to
pass x y and width of that raven as x y
and size arguments here
okay
that should work
i can test it by console again
explosions array from line 59.
i can see as i click and hit ravens
explosions are being added perfect
i made sure my explosion class has
update and draw method
same as my raven class that's why here
on line 123 i can simply just use spread
operator and expand the entire
explosions array into this array i'm
creating on a fly
so that i can call update on all ravens
and all explosions at the same time
like this
i do the same thing for draw method on
line 124
i like this syntax it looks clean
down here i will also remove all the
explosion objects from the array using
built-in array filter method
i need to create a property called
marked for deletion on my explosion
class for this to work
as you can see i'm repeating the same
pattern we used for ravens i hope that
using the same structure like this helps
you to understand and navigate in the
code a bit better
initially i set it to false
in update method i write an if statement
if this.frame from line 69 is more than
5 which means after all the frames of
sprite sheet have been displayed one by
one and explosion animation is complete
i set marked for deletion from line 74
to true
when i click on ravens sound plays and
explosion sprites are animated we are
making great progress we just need to
polish some details here
if i change frame interval on line 73 to
500 you can see it only affects the
first frame the rest of animation is
playing really fast
oh it is because i need to reset time
since last frame back to 0 every time so
it can count towards the next frame
interval over and over to serve next
frames
500 milliseconds is too slow let's try
200
i want to align explosion animation
better over the raven sprites
let's move it a bit upwards by adjusting
destination y argument in draw image
method
i will make it relative to size this dot
y minus this dot size
this dot size divided by four
yeah
i think this is aligned well now
let's create game over condition on line
11 i create a global variable called
game over and i set it to false
initially inside update method on
ravenclaws i create an if statement
if any raven manages to get all the way
across the screen and behind the left
edge of game area game will end if this
dot x is less than 0 minus this dot with
set game over from line 11 to true
and inside animation loop on line 132 i
only want to run request animation frame
and serve the next frame
of our game as long as game over is not
true exclamation mark here
when raven gets all the way across the
screen game over will be set to true and
game will stop
like this
i also want to display game over message
same as we did at draw score i will
create a function called draw game over
first style will be black
fill text will be for example game over
your score is
plus i concatenate score variable
i want it in the middle of the screen so
x coordinate will be canvas width
divided by 2 and y coordinate will be
canvas height divided by 2.
now i need to call my draw game over
function here in animate if game over is
false keep serving the next frame
else call draw game over method to
display message and final score it's not
centered it's because these coordinates
on line 101 mark top left corner and the
text goes towards right and bottom from
that point same as when you are drawing
rectangle or image on canvas with text
it's easy to center by setting text
align property to center like this
yes that worked same as i did with score
i want to give it shadow i will use this
trick where i draw the same text twice
with different fill color and i offset
it by 5 pixels
nice
let's change direction of background
gradient maybe 45 degrees
125 degrees
let's do a little bit of experimenting
now and also to solidify what we learned
today i will use the same code pattern
we used for ravens and explosions to add
particle effects to our game i will go a
bit faster now this part is just for fun
feel free to run your own coding
experiments
i create an array that will hold all my
particle objects
i create particle class constructor will
expect x y size and color this will be
coming from outside the class and will
depend on what raven is leaving this
trail and creating these particles it
will be shooting from their tails as
usual we will create properties for this
dot x and this dot y
this dot radius since particles will be
drawn as circles it will be random
number tied to size of a raven let's try
this formula and see what it looks like
particles will be growing in size so we
need max radius to know when to remove
them and also at which point they reach
maximum opacity
it will be random number between 35 and
55 for example
marked for deletion as usual will be
false at first horizontal speed x will
be a random number between 0.5 and 1.5
because i want the particles to slowly
draft to the right
this dot color will be passed from the
outside update method will move
particles to the right horizontally
it will increase radius by 0.2 per frame
and it will check if this dot radius is
more than max radius if it is it will
set marked for deletion to true
draw method will just draw a simple
circle begin path to start the drawing
fill style will be this dot color from
line 101
arc method to draw a circle
i pass it x y
radius start angle and ant angle like
this
and we fill circular path with color
we have a class that will serve as a
blueprint to create particles i want
them to follow ravens as they fly to
create trails behind them to do that i
go up inside update method on raven
class every time we serve next sprite
sheet frame at the same interval we are
going to take particles array we just
created and we will push new particle
inside
my particle class constructor expects
four values to come from the outside x y
size and color so i pass it x and y of
this raven width of the raven as a size
argument
and this dot color we use for collision
detection rectangles will also be color
of particle trail for that particular
raven
you can see here on line 95 constructor
wants these four properties to come from
the outside so that it knows where on
canvas to draw the particles how large
and what color
i can see i forgot to declare this dot
size here
like this it will come from here and it
will be used here to make radius of
particle circles relative to the size of
raven smaller ones should have smaller
trails so we have particle class
here on line 52 we are creating new
particle object and pushing it into
particles array
inside animate i use spread operator
again to expand contents of particles
array
here so that their update method gets
called and i also expanded here for draw
method
i also need to make sure all particles
with marked for deletion properties set
to true get filtered out from particles
array
nice we are drawing particle trails you
can see they come from the top left
corner of raven hitbox i will adjust
that position a bit here inside particle
class constructor
first i need to move this dot size up so
that its value is available for all
properties coming after it this dot x
will be x passed as argument on line 95
plus this dot size from line 96 divided
by 2 to center it horizontally
yes this dot y will be y plus this dot
size divided by two
no that's too low this dot size divided
by three much better
i want particles to be drawn behind
ravens we are drawing everything on a
single canvas element so how things are
layered depends on the order at which
javascript cycles through these objects
and calls their draw methods for every
frame i will change the order here to
draw particles first and then ravens and
explosions will be drawn over them like
this
awesome we have a working code let's
clean it up
in update method on particle class i
want radius to grow faster
0.5 0.8
0.5 is fine
drawing trail on every single raven can
be performance expensive i want a
property that will allow me to randomize
it and allow me to set what percentage
of ravens will have particle trails on
my raven class i create a property
called this.hessa trail i want this
property to be true for certain amount
of ravens and falls for the rest
as marcus pointed out in my generative
art tutorial any conditional expression
results in a boolean value so instead of
doing if else statement here i can
simply just roll dice with math at
random
master random code like this will return
a random value between 0 and 1. so i
call it and i check if that random value
is more than 0.5 and that's it it should
be true roughly for 50 of ravens this
conditional expression results in a
boolean value true or false depending on
if math at random rolls a random number
that's higher or lower than 0.5 i really
like this syntax very simple and clean
inside update method on ravenclass i
will only create new particles if this
dot has trail is true
like this
now only half of my ravens will have
trails
i also want particles to animate from
fully visible to transparent
inside draw method on particle class i
set global alpha property on my canvas
to be 1 which is maximum fully visible
minus the current size of the particle
divided by max size as the particle's
radius grows eventually radius will be
the same size as max radius so let's say
max radius is 30 pixels at that point
where the current radius is the same
size as max radius we will have 30
divided by 30 here which is one and one
minus one is zero particle is slowly
growing more and more transparent and at
the point when it reaches maximum radius
it will be at zero global alpha this
formula might be a bit difficult to
completely understand if it's the first
time you see it but it's very useful we
will talk about it again in some other
video
as you can see global alpha is spilling
over and affecting my ravens as well
that's an easy fix if you want to change
some global canvas properties such as
fill style global alpha rotate translate
and so on and you want those properties
to affect only a single element you draw
and not the others you can just wrap
that drawing code between built-in save
and restore methods save will create a
snapshot of current canvas global
settings and then we change global alpha
here which will affect just this one
particular particle and then i call
restore to revert canvas settings back
to what they were at this point
save and restore are especially useful
for rotating elements on canvas but you
can also use them for other things like
this
my particles are blinking before they
disappear it is because javascript first
runs over the entire array before it
filters the particles that are too large
out
and my global alpha formula works only
in a specific range between 0 and max
radius some particles get outside that
range and are drawn fully opaque for a
second before they get filtered out to
fix it is simple i just trigger marked
for deletion a little bit sooner for
example by saying max radius minus 5 in
my check online 111
let's make the trail nicer i will add
five particles every time instead of
adding just one on line 54 i create a
for loop like this and i put this code
inside
if i make radius grow slower trail will
be longer because it will take particles
more time to reach max radius
be a bit careful here not to have too
many active particles on screen at once
because at some point it will start
affecting performance and frame rate
i can also randomize the initial x and y
coordinates a little for example i can
add random number between minus 25 and
plus 25
i think it looks a bit more interesting
like this i can also add more enemy
types for example i can add fast flying
bats that will be worth extra score
points maybe i want ravens with trails
to be worth more score but also have
more lives there are many things we can
do here if you are still feeling
creative check out some of my playlists
i have creative coding for beginners
game development playlists and advanced
animation effects everything with just
html css and plain vanilla javascript no
frameworks and no libraries check out
some recommended courses in the video
description i'll see you there if you
want to build games with javascript all
you need is a small set of tools and
techniques let's add a couple more of
them to our toolkit today and make sure
we really understand them in javascript
the extends keyword is used to create
so-called child class that way i can
have my main parent class where i define
properties and values share between all
my enemy types and then i can have child
subclasses that define specifics such as
different visuals different movement
patterns and so on for each enemy type
then when i instantiate my ghost object
and i call update on it if javascript
can't find update method on the ghost
class it will go look for it
automatically on the parent anime class
and it will run the code from there
there is another special keyword called
super today i will show you exactly when
and how to use it let's build a project
step by step completely from scratch and
in the process let's learn everything we
need to know about subclassing in
javascript and how to use it to keep our
code modular clean and easy to read
this tutorial is for beginners i will
take you through the code in a way to
make sure you understand everything we
will build a really fun animation
project and i will show you many game
development techniques today this video
is independent and i will explain the
code from scratch but it's part of a
larger series where i teach you tools
and techniques you will need if you want
to be a game developer or if you just
want to learn front-end web development
and javascript on fun visual animation
projects
if you go along with me today you will
get three free premium sprite sheets so
that you can get exactly the same result
check out this website for more
beautiful game development art assets to
start my project i create a basic
webpage boilerplate markup a link style
css file javascript file and i created
html5 canvas element with an id of
canvas one i bring my three images into
the project by creating three img tags
with ids worm ghost and spider you can
find these images to download in the
video description it might be a good
idea to use the same images as me at
first and then modify the code and use
your own art assets once you get
everything working it might save you a
lot of time debugging if you follow
exactly what i'm doing especially if you
are a beginner
i give my canvas a border width and
height
and i position it with css in the middle
of the page
i will also hide the project images
we will draw them and animate them with
javascript in a minute by including
images as image tags i can make sure
they are fully loaded before my
javascript code runs by using load event
listener it will prevent potential
errors i will show you exactly what i
mean as we go along i set up my canvas
using these four lines of code as usual
let's outline the entire project
structure now so that you can see what
functions and classes we need and how
they are connected to each other when we
have the complete project structure we
will be expanding on individual parts to
add more functionality the most
important thing today will be my game
class i will use it as the wrapper that
contains and controls all movement and
animation logic and basically everything
else it's a javascript class so it will
need a constructor which is a monitor
method for all javascript classes it
will also have update and draw methods
in game class constructor i create a
property i call this dot enemies my game
object will hold an array that contains
all enemies like this
my game class will also have a private
method called add new enemy this method
will be called every time i need to
create and set up a new enemy for my
game if method's name starts with a hash
symbol like this it will be a private
class method it means it can only be
called from within my game class to
manage some kind of internal
functionality in our case adding a new
enemy into this.enemies array from line
8. if you try to call this private
method from outside game class you will
get an error
notice that update and draw methods are
public because i will need to call them
from my animation loop from the outside
a bit later
my add new anime private method will
need a way to create new enemies for the
game
so we will write another class i call
anime and inside we declare a blueprint
whenever i call this anime class from
inside add new anime method it will
create one new enemy object for me i
will show you how to make animated
ghosts worms and spiders they will all
be created by this enemy class but they
will have different animations and
different behaviors to make our game
more interesting and maybe more
difficult for the players so again as
you know every class needs a constructor
to hold the blueprint
and we will also have update and draw
methods here update and draw method on
gameobject here will be handling
updating and drawing my entire game for
example all enemies player obstacles
backgrounds menus and so on update and
draw method here on the anime class will
be handling only each individual enemy
such as their position movement pattern
sprite animation and so on and finally
to complete the skeleton of our project
we will need a custom animate function
that will call what needs to be called
and a loop around to move and animate
things in our game here in animation
loop i declare what happens in our game
frame by frame at first we will call
built in clear rectangle method and we
will clear old paint from the entire
canvas so from coordinates 0 0 to
coordinates canvas with canvas height if
you are a complete beginner this is
horizontal x axis and this is vertical y
y-axis so point zero zero is here and
point x two hundred y two hundred for
example is here
this is the basic thing you need to
understand if you want to draw on canvas
so we cleared old paint from canvas to
make sure we can only see the current
animation frame we write some code here
depending on what we want to happen in
our game and we call request animation
frame built in javascript method which
will simply take function we pass to it
and it will call it once
animate will run its code and call
itself again run its code and call
itself again over and over this is how
you create animation loop i don't want
any of this code to run until i'm sure
my web page including canvas element and
all project images have been loaded so i
highlight all the code and i cut it for
a second
i want to put it inside load event
listener
document dot add event listener and we
will listen for dom content loaded
javascript event i actually made a
mistake here because the dom content
loaded event fires when the initial html
document has been loaded and parsed but
it doesn't wait for style sheets and
images the correct event to listen for
here is the load event which only fires
when the whole page has been loaded
including all dependent resources such
as style sheets and images so please
replace dom content loaded event with
load event here you will not notice any
difference if you are working locally
because images will load instantly but
if you are loading images from an online
server somewhere load event is the one
you need here
so i paste all the code back here inside
my load event listener
we have canvas setup
main game class enemy class and animate
function if you want to animate
something it's important that it runs at
the same speed on slow old computers and
on brand new gaming super pcs not every
computer is able to surf frames at the
same speed also some screens have
different refresh rates and request
animation frame adjusts when it serves
the next frame based on screen refresh
rate
so what i want to do now is count how
many milliseconds happened between
frames and only when we reach certain
threshold we will serve the next frame
since we are passing animate as an
argument to request animation frame here
request animation frame has another
secret feature it will pass an automatic
timestamp argument to the function it
calls so our animate has access to
timestamp argument which was
automatically generated by javascript
because i called animate using request
animation frame here i want to calculate
the difference between previous and
current animate call in milliseconds
difference between frames and animation
is also called delta time simply
explained as request animation frame
runs over and over it is passing animate
this automatic timestamp argument i want
to know what is the difference in
milliseconds between previous timestamp
and timestamp from the current loop so
called deltatime
i will calculate it by saying a
timestamp that was passed in this loop
minus timestamp that was passed in the
previous loop i will call it for example
last time after i used last time
variable that was holding old timestamp
from the previous loop to calculate
delta time i can reassign last time to
the new time stamp from this loop so
that it can be used in the next loop
again
let's console delta time to see if it
works
here i declare animate i also need to
call it the start the first animation
loop
oh yeah last time is not declared i
declare it right here and i initially
set it to 1. this value of 1 will only
be used for the very first loop because
on the second loop it will get
reassigned to the current timestamp
in console i can see my delta time is
around 16 milliseconds this is very
common refresh rate for most computer
screens but if you have high refresh
screen you can get a lower number here
and if you have old computer you can get
higher number here especially when you
create a bigger project where you
animate many moving parts at this point
even very slow computers should handle
16 milliseconds delta time time between
animation frames since our game doesn't
have any graphics yet
if i scroll in console all the way up to
my first delta time console aux i can
see the initial call was none not a
number it's because animate only
receives automatic timestamp argument
here when it gets called by request
animation frame on the very first
initial call it doesn't have any
timestamp argument so i will pass it 0
just for that first loop
now we know how to calculate delta time
number of milliseconds between frames
faster computers will have lower number
slower old computers might have higher
delta time because it can take them more
milliseconds to serve the next frame
since we have this delta time value we
can adjust animation speed with it to
make sure our game runs at the same
speed on slow and fast computers i will
show you where and how to use it as we
build our project and start animate and
move game characters around on canvas
console lock like this can cause
performance issues so don't forget to
remove your console logs when you don't
need them anymore
on line 22 i have my anime class it has
a mandatory constructor method which
will be used as a blueprint to create
one new enemy object whenever i call
this class with a new keyword from
somewhere in my project let's write that
blueprint and inside we declare
properties and values of our enemies
each anime will need x and y starting
coordinates so that javascript knows
where we want to draw them on canvas our
first hard code coordinates 100 hundred
we will change that in a minute i will
also give each enemy width of 100 pixels
and height of 100 pixels
update method on enemy class will just
move the enemy by 1 pixel to the left
draw method on my custom enemy class
we'll call build in a fill rectangle
method and it will first draw a black
rectangle representing my enemy i pass
it this dot x from line 24 this.y this
dot with and this load height
great we have anime class now we can
call it to create enemy object and add
it to our game inside add new enemy
private method i take this loot enemies
from line 9 and i call build in push
method push method can be called on
arrays and it will take whatever we pass
to it and it will push that at the end
of the array so i pass it new enemy
the new keyword is a special command in
javascript it will make javascript look
for a class with the name enemy and when
it finds it it will take its constructor
and use the blueprint inside to create
one new blank javascript object and
assign it values and properties based on
instructions inside the blueprint
that new anime object will also
automatically have access to update and
draw method on anime class
when you instantiate object with the
javascript it will run its blueprint
inside constructor so i will do
something which might look a bit strange
to you any code put inside the
constructor will be executed when you
create a new instance of that object
with the new keyword so here when i
create new instance of my game object
i will create enemies array and i will
call its private add new enemy method
automatically which will push new enemy
inside enemies array
to check if that really happened i will
also console lock this dot enemies to
execute all this code here all i need to
do is to instantiate my game class so
let's do it down here on line 39 i
create a new constant variable i call
for example game and i set it equal to
new game like this
doing that created one new blank game
object and a train code inside
constructor here on line 8 so this
console log from line 11 is showing that
this dot enemies from line 9 contains
one new enemy object perfect
you can see that enemy object has x and
y width and height as we declared here
on line 25.
now inside update method on game class i
will cycle through all enemy objects
inside this dot enemies array and i will
call their update method from line 31. i
hope you know syntax of for each method
i'm simply saying here take
this.enemiesarray from line 9 and for
each object in this array run their
associated update method
this is es6 syntax so called arrow
function i will also take the same
enemies array from line 9 and i will
call draw method from line 34 on all
these enemy objects currently there is
only one inside but there could be many
more
down here inside my animation loop i
take instance of my game class from line
39 i call update method we just wrote
and i also call draw method and here we
are animating one enemy in our game
i hope you can see advantages of code
structure like this let's say i also
have array of obstacles background
layers power ups players and so on i can
call all of these from update and draw
method on my game class to get
everything moving with very little code
from a single wrapper function keeping
my code clean and organized this way
it's a good practice not to use global
variables inside our classes so i will
take context with and hide and i will
put them inside my game class these
arguments will be passed here on line 39
when i create an instance of game class
so i pass it ctx from line 3 to tell
javascript which canvas i want to draw
on i will define width of my game by
passing it canvas width from line 4 and
canvas height from line 5.
these three variables just as my game
class constructor expects here on line
8.
then i take these arguments and convert
them into class properties
this dot ctx is ctx passed on line 8
this.width is width and this.height is
height
now i converted public variables into
class properties and i can pass them
around when i need them by passing game
object as an argument i will show you
let's say i need width and height of my
game inside the enemy class because i
want my enemies to appear behind the
edges of game area
on line 23 when i create new anime
object i will pass it this keyword which
here refers to the game object we are
currently inside
that game object will carry all
references to its width height and other
properties with it let me show you so
i'm passing this keyword and inside my
anime constructor i will call it game
here i created this.game property and i
set it to game that was passed as an
argument
now i have access to game object from
inside my anime class i can console log
it and you can see all its properties
including width and height
so now i have access to width of my game
from inside enemy class by saying
this.game.width the initial starting x
horizontal coordinate for enemies will
be just behind the right edge of canvas
initial starting y-coordinate will be a
random number between 0 and this dot
game height so in this case between 0
and 800 pixels because height of my game
is 800
now whenever i reload page new enemy is
generated with random vertical
coordinate i achieve that by passing
reference to my game class to enemy
class constructor online 23 which will
take all these properties and values
with it
i call it game and convert it into class
property on my enemy class making them
available when i need to position newly
created enemies this is one way how you
can pass class variables around if you
want to avoid using global variables in
your projects i don't really want to add
just one anime when i create instance of
game class i want to create new enemies
over and over in a certain interval
if i just call this.add new anime from
inside update method it will create new
anime for every animation frame that is
too many and it would freeze my game
very quickly i commented out
game class is responsible for adding new
enemies to the game so i will give it
two new properties this dot enemy
interval will define number of
milliseconds between adding each new
enemy into the game let's try 400
milliseconds
this dot enemy timer will count
milliseconds from 0 to 400 over and over
in update method i can say if this dot
enemy timer is more than enemy interval
call add new enemy private class method
also at that point we want to reset
enemy timer back to zero so it can start
counting again
else meaning if enemy timer is less than
400 milliseconds increase enemy timer by
one
every time we add a new enemy i will
counterlog this.enemies array from line
12 just so we can check if it's adding
objects or not
i decrease enemy interval on line 13.
awesome we are adding enemies but you
know how we said that each computer
could run at a different speed that
could mean that enemies are being added
faster or slower on some computers i
want my game to run at the same speed on
every computer and that's why down here
on line 56 in animation loop we
calculated the delta time time between
frames and milliseconds i will use it
now i pass delta time to game.update
method on line 58. from my previous
console log i know my delta time is 16
milliseconds my computer can serve a new
frame every 16 milliseconds value of
delta time is dependent by the power of
your computer but also on your screen
refresh rate because request animation
frame method adjusts to maximum screen
refresh rate if the computer can handle
it now i have access to delta time value
here in my update method so instead of
adding hardcoded value plus 1 i will add
value of delta time to my enemy timer on
line 13 i set an m interval to 400
milliseconds
or maybe 1000 milliseconds
here i am increasing enemy timer by 16
milliseconds per frame when we
accumulate enough to reach 1000
milliseconds one second we will add new
enemy to the game
if somebody has a faster computer their
delta time will have smaller value
on slow computers delta time will have
higher value and will be getting near to
the target 1000 less often but in larger
steps so in the end my code will run at
the same or very similar speed on slow
and fast computers regardless of their
power or monitor refresh rate and this
is how you use the delta time to trigger
periodic events in your games or
animation projects i also need to make
sure i'm passing the reference to my
canvas properly and not using global
variable
let's follow the logic we declare ctx
here on line 3. i pass that global
variable to my game class when i
instantiate it on line 52.
on line 9 i take that argument and i
convert it to class property
then i pass ctx from line 9 to draw
method on my enemies
and on line 47 i need to make sure draw
method on enemy class expects that
argument and this way line 48 is using
this.ctx that was passed around from
gameobject rather than using globalctx
variable
i'm going to log in this.enemiesarray
online20 and i can see it keeps growing
i need a way to remove enemies that have
left the screen we could potentially
also use something called object pooling
here but i will leave that for another
episode first i will need a flag on my
enemy objects that will mark them as
ready to be deleted and then we will
simply filter these objects out i will
call that property this dot marked for
deletion and i initially set it to false
then inside update method on anime class
i will check if this dot x is less than
zero minus this dot with meaning the
enemy has moved across the screen and
behind the left edge of canvas if it has
i will set its marked for deletion
property to true
now i can go inside update method on
game class and here i will take
this.enemiesarray from line 12 which
currently has around 20 objects and it
keeps growing and i will filter it
filter is a built in javascript method
that manipulates arrays it simply
creates a new array with all elements
that pass the test implemented by the
provided function so here on line 17 i'm
saying take this.enemies from line 17
and reassign it to the same array but
only include elements that have this dot
marked for deletion property set to
false exclamation mark here means false
let's run the code and see if it works
yeah we stop at 10 enemies and it's not
growing anymore because we are removing
old ones as we are adding new ones might
be one good performance idea here you
don't have to check and filter enemies
for every frame of animation we could
for example do it in a certain interval
i could even take this line of code and
put it inside this if statement
it would still filter old enemies but it
would run only periodically whenever i
add a new enemy to the game
we are making nice progress we have
already implemented so many features
here between lines 35 and 53 i have my
enemy class it's a blueprint with
properties and methods that determine
what my enemies look like how they move
and how they behave let's expand on it
and make them more interesting rather
than simple black rectangles i will
create a so-called sub class or child
class by saying class worm extends enemy
doing that will make anime a parent
class of worm and for example if i call
update or draw and javascript can't find
that method on my worm class it will
automatically go looking for it on the
parent class so it will look for that
method on anime class same goes for
properties declared in constructor if
there is no constructor on my worm class
it will automatically use the
constructor from anime
when i do this i can have shared enemy
class that declares all logic properties
methods and features that all my enemies
have in common for example their sprite
animation logic collision checks with
player and so on while at the same time
i can declare child classes where i can
override improve and change some of
these properties and methods to create
unique and very different behaviors for
different enemy types and that's exactly
what we will do now let me show you how
much visual and behavior variety we can
create without repeating the code all
enemies have in common doing this will
keep our code clean and modular and you
can go crazy with different enemy types
while still keeping your logic organized
and easy to read on my worm class i
don't have to declare constructor at all
and javascript will automatically use
constructor from line 36 on enemy class
but in most cases you want each enemy to
have different width height x and y
position and so on so i kind of want to
use both
i want to take all properties from enemy
constructor and i want to add some
additional properties on top of it that
will be specific only for my worm
objects i declare constructor and i know
worms will have unique value for image
properties so this dot image equals worm
this line of code is a weird syntax and
i will explain what's going on and how
comment works when i bring image to my
project this way in a minute let's first
finish constructor method on worm class
same as on line 36 worm class
constructor will expect the game as an
argument
now i want to say take all the code
between lines 37 and 43 on enemy class
constructor and use it here to do that
we use special super keyword the super
keyword is a special command in
javascript and it's used to access and
call function on an object's parent so
here i call super and i pass it game to
literally run the constructor on its
parent class
after that i can add more properties on
my worm class constructor like this
important thing to note here is that you
have to first call super and run parent
constructor like this before you declare
any additional properties using this
keyword otherwise you will get a
reference error
in derived classes like this super must
be called before you can use this
keyword so now my worm constructor
contains all the code from between lines
37 and 43 and additional distort image
property set to worm each enemy type
will have different starting x and y
coordinates and different width and
height so i will actually take all these
and put them on my worm
i want enemy class constructor to have
only properties and values that are
shared for all my enemy types
up here on line 31 inside private add
new anime method rather than
instantiating parent anime class i will
instantiate child worm class
again i'm passing it this as an argument
and because we are inside game class
this reference is the entire game object
so all these properties
we travel down to worm class and inside
constructor we are taking that game and
passing it to super
instantiating constructor of its parent
anime class which is
here
anime class also has update and draw
methods and when i call update and draw
on my worm and javascript can't find it
it will automatically go looking for
them on the parent anime class i hope
it's becoming a little bit more clear
how this works and how parent and child
classes relate and work together if i
run the code we have our worms coming
again just to prove that draw method
that is called from line 46 is taking
properties from worm class constructor
let's change this dot with on line 56
as you can see now my worms are 200
pixels wide so what is this weird syntax
online 58 this is not how we usually
bring images into a project usually i
would use getelementbyid to target my
image element with an id of worm that i
created in index.html in the beginning i
wasn't aware of this so all the credit
goes to dany who says a little known
fact is that any elements created in the
dom with an id attribute are
automatically added to the javascript
execution environment as a global
variable
this means that you can access any html
element with a javascript using its id
no need for
document.getelementbyid or queryselector
i'm just doing this as an experiment and
you will see in a minute that it
actually works if you're having any
issues you can still bring the image
into the project the usual way and also
ideally pass it to the worm class
constructor as an argument so that we
are not pulling global variables
directly from the outside i'm just
experimenting here a bit i really like
tips like this thanks danny
nowhere in my code have i declared this
worm variable the only place you can
find this reference is id on line 12
inside index html but this image will
still work you can test it by console
logging this.image
i have too many console.logs let's
comment outline 38.
yes you can see that the javascript is
actually finding the image with an id of
worm automatically without us having to
use getelementbyid like we usually do so
let's use that image and make our worms
look a bit better than black rectangles
you can download these spreadsheets for
free in the description and you can use
them to follow along with this video for
educational purposes to use them in any
commercial project you would have to buy
a full license from the artist's website
i will link his site as well he has a
lot of great game development art assets
there check it out
i feel like i explained built in canvas
draw image method 100 times on this
channel this method is so important at
first i will just use the version with 5
arguments image we want to draw
x
y
width and height where to draw it on
canvas this way we will just squeeze the
entire sprite sheet with all its six
frames into the predefined area of 200
times 100 pixels notice that i'm calling
draw method on my worm class it's using
these properties but since javascript
can't find draw method on worm it will
look for it on parent enemy class and it
will use that one
let's remove this console.log
and this fill rectangle as well
i can change width and height but now i
would actually like to draw just the
first frame from the worm sprite sheet
i removed all these lines i commented
out earlier
i create a new property on worm class
called this.sprite width and it will be
a width of a single frame in my sprite
sheet if i take width of my sprite sheet
and divide it by 6 the number of frames
i will get 229 pixels height of a single
frame is 171 pixels
i take width and height and move them up
here
now i need to use draw method to cut out
just single frame from that sprite sheet
and place it on canvas for that i will
need to give it nine arguments so
additional four to tell javascript what
area i want to crop out from the source
image i need to give it source x
source y source width and source height
arguments source x and source y will be
0 0 since i'm just cropping out the
first frame for now source width and
source height will be distort sprite
width from line 52 and this dot sprite
height from line 53 so to crop out a
single frame from an image with draw
image method i need to give it nine
arguments image i want to draw
x y width and height of what area i want
to crop out and x y with an height of
where on canvas we want to place that
cropped out piece of image onto
now we are drawing just one frame
perfect you probably noticed that it's a
bit stretched that's because this width
and height which is coming from here has
no relation to the actual size of a
single frame
so the ratio is different let's make
width and height the same aspect ratio
as our sprite sheet
i do that by making width half of sprite
width and height will be half of sprite
height i need it to do half because the
original size would be too large as long
as i use the same modifier on both width
and height in this case i divide both of
them by two it will preserve the aspect
ratio of the original sprite frame
all my worms are moving to the left by
one pixel per frame what if i want each
worm to have different speed for example
a random value between 0.1 and 0.2
and up here inside update method on
enemy class i say this dot x minus
equals the slot speed
that will be very very slow let's make
it faster you might have realized that
i'm not using delta time in this
movement calculation so let's use it to
make sure the worms move at the same
speed on all machines
i'm calling this update method here on
line 25
so i pass it delta time which we made
available here before
now that i have access to delta time in
update method on enemy class i will pass
it here as an argument and to factor in
time difference between animation frames
when moving something around we have to
multiply it that way faster refresh rate
with lower delta time will move often
but by smaller steps slower pcs will
have higher delta time they will not
draw frames so often but they will have
higher delta time so they will make
larger steps to compensate for the
difference
now the base speed is too much so i
amend it on line 59
i will actually rename it vx velocity on
horizontal x-axis because maybe some
other enemies will have a vertical
movement also i need to rename it on
line 41.
if i go up on line 13 and reduce enemy
interval to 100 milliseconds we will get
a lot of worms and something will become
apparent they are layered randomly in
order as they are added to the game for
example this worm should be probably
behind this one and this one behind this
one if we pretend this is 3d game space
and worms that are higher should be
behind worms that are lower it would
look better how do we achieve that that
index or whether worm is in front or
behind at worms depends on order at
which they are added to the array on
their index in that array because as i
push them into enemies array one by one
we cycle through them from index 0 to
the maximum index in that array and we
draw worm with index 0 then worm with
index 1 on top of it if they are in the
same area
then worm with index 2 will be on top of
them and so on
i want to reorganize my array so that
index in the array is tied to their
vertical position so that we first draw
worms in this area and then we draw the
ones in this area on top of them as we
go down on the page vertically in plus
direction on vertical y-axis that will
cause worms to look like they are
properly behind each other and not messy
like this look at this this is a mess
this one is sliding over the other one's
eye
so every time i push new worm into the
array i will just build javascript sort
method you can simply just call sort on
the array and it will sort them in
ascending order by default if you want
more control you can give it a callback
function sort simply takes every element
in the array and it performs a check
comparing values between these two
elements pushing them up and down in the
array depending on the condition in the
callback i want worms with lower
vertical y coordinates to have lower
index so that they are drawn first so my
condition will be a dot y minus b dot y
like this
sort is a built in javascript method it
abstracts away the actual algorithm that
does the sorting work so let's not spend
more time on it now all we need to know
for now is how to use it when i run the
code you can see that worms that are
higher are drawn behind the worms that
are lower making it look like they are
moving in actual 3d or maybe in two and
a half the cartoon space well it doesn't
look messy anymore you can swap between
ascending and descending order by
swapping these values in our case we
want a minus b also notice i'm not
sorting the array for every animation
frame only when i add new enemy into the
array
so this is our worm class it's a child
of anime and it doesn't have update and
draw methods because as we said if
javascript doesn't find them on the worm
class it will go looking for these
methods on the parent class
but what if i want to use the base code
from draw method on enemy class and i
want to add some extra code to it to
create some additional visuals for
example as boris suggested ghosts need
to be semi-transparent but i don't want
reduced opacity on worms only on ghosts
so how do we do something like that i'm
sure you can come up with some clever if
statement but let's keep it clean and
use child classes for that
i will copy my room class and rename it
to ghost
image online 74 will be ghost
referencing the id
here on line 13 in index html i look at
my sprite sheet width divided by number
of frames so sprite width of single
frame is 261 pixels
height is 209 pixels in this case
horizontal speed modifier will be a
little bit higher than worms let's say a
random number between 0.1 and 0.3 so
that's the base ghost child class how do
i randomly push worms or ghosts into my
game one way to do that is to create a
property on my main game object called
distort enemy types
it will be an array with two elements
for now worm and ghost
inside add new anime private method i
will randomly pick one of the options in
the array i create a constant variable
called random anime and i set it equal
to this dot anime types and square
brackets so if index here is 0 we get
worm
and if index here is 1 we get ghost how
do i randomize this index and let it
choose one of these randomly every time
we run add new anime method i can just
put math at random statement and it will
be a random number between zero and
length of distilled enemy types array
that way i can keep adding more and more
enemy types to the array and this code
will still work maybe my game will have
20 different enemy types it doesn't
matter it will still work the only
problem is that math at random returns
numbers with decimal points and there is
no index 1.5 in this array it's easy to
fix
i will wrap it inside method floor which
will round it down to the closest
integer now i can check if random enemy
variable is warm
we will push new worm into this dot
enemies array
else if random anime is ghost we will
push new ghost perfect so we have
this.enemy types array on the main game
class this can contain as many enemy
types as you want inside add new enemy
we randomly choose one of them every
time we are about to create new enemy
object and based on that random choice
we create either worm or ghost so now
both worm and ghost are child classes
that extend my main enemy class
let's switch to kind of flat 2d view i
want worms to move only on the ground so
i change their vertical y position to
this.game.height
minus distort height
worms are sliding on the floor ghosts
are flying in the air i want ghosts to
take up only the top 80 percent of the
game area
not to be so close to the ground their
vertical y position will be a random
number between 0 and game height times
0.8
or maybe 0.6 yeah
since we switched to this new view i
don't really need to be sorting my
enemies by their vertical position
anymore so i comment out this code on
line 35. with both worm and ghost we are
only modifying properties on the
constructor they both inherited the same
identical update and draw method from
the main enemy class with no
modifications at the moment we said we
wanted to make the ghost
semi-transparent so let's do it
i declare draw method on ghost class and
now two things can happen
we can override the draw method with a
completely different code here because
when we create a new worm javascript
will not find the draw method and we'll
go looking for it on enemy parent class
but with ghost it will find the draw
method right here and it will ignore the
original draw method on enemy class the
second option is that i want the code
from draw method on enemy class to run
plus i want to write some additional
code on top of it that will be unique
only for ghosts i can do that by calling
super the super keyword here simply
represents parent class so imagine i'm
saying enemy dot draw because i want to
call it's draw method first super.draw
means animate.draw basically super
represents the super class the parent
class so here inside the draw method on
ghost class first i call draw method on
enemy class and i know it expects ctx as
an argument so that it knows what canvas
we want to draw on that ctx property is
coming from
here on line 29 by the way where i'm
calling draw on all objects inside
this.enemies array i'm calling draw on
all ghosts and all worms at the same
time
so first we call draw method on parent
enemy class from 950.
we will run all the code in here
but we will also add some additional
code that will be specific only for
ghost objects in this case i will set
global alpha property to 0.5 this will
set opacity to 50
you can see that it affects all ghosts
and all worms as well it's because
global alpha canvas property works the
same as fill style for example once you
set it you are setting it for the entire
canvas it will stay that value for
everything drawn on the same canvas
unless you redeclare it to something
else since i want global alpha to only
affect ghosts and nothing else on canvas
i set it to 0.5 i draw my ghost and i
set it back to 1.
the alternative way to do this would be
to call ctx save built-in method which
will take a snapshot of all canvas
settings at that point then we can
change global alpha and anything else we
need to change we draw the ghost and we
call ctx restore which will
automatically restore canvas properties
including global alpha back to what they
were at this point when we called safe
for the first time this technique is
especially useful if i was changing
multiple canvas properties at the same
time not just global alpha so this is
how you extend a method from parent
class with a help of super keyword
now that we know how to do it we can
also extend update method and make
ghosts move in wavy patterns let's try i
redeclare update method on ghost class
and i pass it delta time
i call super dot update and i pass the
delta time
this will run all the code in update
method on enemy class from line 46
here
i add a new property called this.angle
and initially i set it to 0.
then in update method i will say this
dot y vertical position of my ghosts
plus equals mastered sign built in
javascript trigonometry function and i
pass it this.angle as an argument
i covered this in my enemy movement
patterns episode as part of the series
before so now just quickly moth.sine is
a built-in javascript function that
returns a sign of a number we pass to it
it expects angle value in radians and it
will return a value between -1 and plus
1. if you keep calling it and passing it
every increase in angle value as we are
about to do here it will endlessly cycle
by small increments between minus one
and plus one creating wavy movement
pattern so called sine wave so every
time update method runs i will increase
this dot angle from line 79 by one that
angle value is being passed to math.sine
function
here at the same time
you can see it makes the ghost shake up
and down we can also multiply it times a
certain radius value this will make the
curve larger like this we need to be
increasing angle much slower let's try
0.1 per frame
0.05
0.02
you can see how that affects the
movement curve i change radius value
and angle value
let's randomize the wave size for each
ghost i create a property i call for
example this dot curve it will be random
number between 0 and 3.
and i use it here
now some ghosts move in smaller some in
larger waves
i reduce the number of enemies by
increasing enemy interval on line 13.
let's add a new enemy every 500
milliseconds for example
so with ghost class we are extending
draw method to make it semi-transparent
and update method to give it wavy
vertical movement worm class is just
using the base draw and update methods
from its parent anime class let's create
another child class and let me show you
a completely different type of movement
for the third enemy type i just copy
worm class here so that i don't have to
write all of that again
i will call it spider
i check my sprite sheet sprite width
width of a single frame is 310 pixels
sprite height is 175
i want spiders to start from just behind
the top edge of game area so 0 minus
distorted height their horizontal speed
will be 0.
i only want them to move up and down
image will be spider referencing this id
from line 14 in index html
i give them v y velocity y property and
set it to 1.
now i create update method i pass it
delta time first i call update method
from parent anime class from line
46
and then i add some additional code at
first let's just increase vertical speed
by one
on line 15 i add spider to my enemy
types and here i say else if random
enemy is spider push new spider object
into enemies array
my spiders are not showing and that's
because
yes they just move down and their
horizontal coordinate is off canvas so
we can't see them
i set their horizontal coordinate to be
a random number between zero and game
with
nice we have spiders here let's make
them move up and down let's say if this
dot y is more than 200 pixels from the
top revert this v y to a negative number
since we are adding this dot v y to
vertical position here on line 110
if it becomes a negative number it will
make the spider go up awesome we have
spiders going up and down what about
instead of hardcoding 200 here each
spider will have a different maximum
movement range this.max length is a
random number between 100 and 300 for
example actually between 0 and game
height might be better
now i just replace hard-coded 200 with
this.max length here
i also want each spider to move up and
down at different speed
so this dot v y is a random number
between 0.1 and
0.2 i should also multiply it times
delta time so we get consistency across
different machines
i want the spiders to swing up and down
from a spider web so let's extend draw
method as well and draw it
first i will call draw method from
parent class from line 51.
here on line 88 i need to pass ctx as an
argument i forgot to do that we don't
want to use global variables inside our
classes so on line 114 i pass draw
method ctx i call draw from its super
class from enemy parent online 51 to run
all the code in there
and also i will draw a spider web here
so begin path to start a new shape
build in canvas move to method to set
starting coordinates of the line
let's pass it coordinates 0 0 for now
line 2 will be the ending coordinates of
my line so this dot x this.y i want it
to be where my spider is at the moment
i stroke the lines and here they are we
have spider webs coming from coordinates
0 0 2 coordinates of my spiders
let's change the starting coordinates to
be exactly on top of the spider
horizontally so this dot x horizontal
and 0 vertical this dot x position is
top left corner of my enemy rectangle so
if i want the web to come from the
middle i need to take this dot x
position and add half of enemy width to
it
i also do that for the starting
coordinates
i can see there is a small vertical gap
between spiders and the ends of their
webs so let's do this.y plus 10 pixels
to make the lines a bit longer
notice that i'm not actually animating
the sprite sheets we are just showing
the first frame for each anime type the
best thing about our code structure now
is that i can just write sprite
animation logic once and it will
automatically be applied to all spiders
worms and ghosts i go up to line 46
inside constructor on enemy class where
i declared properties and values that
are shared between all enemy types in my
game
we will need frame x property which will
cycle between 0 and 5 to specify which
horizontal frame from the spreadsheet we
want to show i also declare this.max
frame which could be specific to each
enemy but in this case all my enemy
spritesheets have 6 frames we count from
frame 0 so max frame is 5.
i also need to account for delta time
when animating frames to make sure it
runs at the same speed on slow and fast
computers we already done it once today
i will have a frame interval variable so
let's say 100 milliseconds and then i
will have one accumulation variable that
will be going from zero accumulating
delta time until it reaches my frame
interval value
i will call it for example this.frame
timer i set it to 0 initially
i check if this dot frame timer from
line 49 is more than frame interval from
948
if it is i do something
else i increase frame time variable by
delta time
now i just realized we need access to
delta time here so all this code
actually needs to be inside update
method
here
now i can say frame timer plus equals
delta time
remember that delta time is milliseconds
between frames so fast computers will
surf frames of our game animation very
fast but will have smaller delta time on
the other hand slow computers can't surf
frames so often but their delta time is
larger so as a result it evens out and
both fast and slow computers will reach
frame interval of 100 milliseconds at
the same time
this will ensure all the movement and
animation in our games has the same
timing regardless of speed of the
machine we run the code on
frame timer will start at zero it will
be increasing by delta time and when it
reaches frame interval we can move to
the next frame in sprite sheet
i have to check if current frame x from
line 46 is less than max frame from line
47. if it is slice we increase frame x
by 1.
else we set frame x back to 0.
at the same time i set frame timer back
to 0 so it can start accumulating delta
time again
on line 46 i set frame x initially to 0.
now i'm cycling between frame x 0 and
frame x 5.
to actually display that in game i have
to replace hard-coded source x and
source y properties in draw image method
which i set to 0 0. i have to replace
them with my new variables source y can
actually stay hard coded to zero because
our sprite sheet has only one row there
will be no vertical navigation within
this sprite sheet source x argument will
be frame x from line 47 times sprite
width from line 70. that way when frame
x is 1 we cut out this frame frame x2 is
this frame and so on i have entire
episode on this uh as part of this
series if you want more details about
how to animate sprites properly and in
that episode i also show alternative
techniques how to do this i can also add
more functionality here in update method
on enemy class and it will be shared
across all my enemy types it could be
for example collagen checks with player
some javascript generated sounds enemies
can have particle effects and so on
being able to write code here in one
place and share it for all my enemy
subclasses will save a lot of code
repetition that would happen otherwise
on line 53 i'm checking if enemies have
moved behind the left edge of screen and
i'm marking them for deletion
this check works for both ghosts and
worms as they move from right to left
the problem is that spiders never move
past that point they have no horizontal
movement so as you can see in the
console if i let my game run it will
just keep accumulating more and more
spiders i need a different check here to
mark spiders as ready to be deleted i go
inside update method on spider class and
i say if this dot y is less than 0 minus
this dot height times 2 then mark it as
ready for deletion spiders start at 0
minus distant height as declared here on
line 114 they will move down and then
they will move back up
when they reach point 0 minus this dot
height times 2 we delete them i will be
extending classes a lot in my games so i
hope you learned something new today
creating child classes is not only
useful for animations and game
development but it's a very important
javascript technique with many different
applications across all front and web
development i think sometimes it's
better to learn these concepts on fun
projects like this to learn more
fundamental javascript techniques on
creative coding projects check out
related videos in the video description
great job on completing today's course
say hi in the comments
[Music]
hey coders so i heard you like making
games me too
i think projects like this are great not
only for aspiring game developers but
also to learn and improve html css and
javascript skills in this class we will
build easy animated side squirrel game
completely from scratch with plain
vanilla javascript no frameworks and no
libraries the main goal today is to
learn about basic code structure how to
split responsibilities between objects
that make up our game how to make them
communicate with each other effectively
and how to put all of that together in
an easy to understand way this class is
a part of a longer series in each
episode we built a small standalone
project for beginners to learn about
fundamental building blocks of game
development with the javascript full
series is linked in the description in
this part we will build a simple version
of the game to learn the fundamentals in
the next part we will expand on each
element using the things we learned
across the series let's see how it all
comes together games should be exciting
full of secrets and special features i
hope this series helps you to bring your
creative ideas to life
we will work with three files in
index.html i link my css stylesheet and
javascript file i create html5 canvas
element with an id of canvas 1 and i put
all my game assets here in this area so
that we can use load event listener to
wait for these assets to be fully loaded
and available before we run the game
art assets were provided by this
talented artist you can find more on
their website i will have player image
background image and anime image here
you can download project files in the
video description
install css i give my body black
background i make canvas blue and i
position it in the middle of my web page
i also want to hide my image elements
because we will draw them with
javascript on canvas so player image
display none
same goes for background image and enemy
image
i want javascript to wait until all
images are fully loaded so i will wrap
my game inside an event listener we will
listen for load event
load event waits for all assets such as
sprite sheets and images to be fully
loaded before it executes code in its
callback function i will place the
entire code of our game inside this
anonymous callback function in
javascript anonymous function usually
means a function without a name by
placing all my code inside this
anonymous callback function i separate
scope of my game from a global scope to
make sure my custom class and variable
names don't clash with any other outside
code
when all the assets are fully loaded the
code inside will be executed line by
line i assign variable to my canvas
element i create context instance of
built-in canvas 2d api that holds all
drawing methods and properties we will
need to animate our game
i set canvas width to 800 pixels
and canvas height to 720 pixels i make
canvas transparent in this class i want
to make it very clear how we split
responsibilities between objects and how
these objects interact with each other
to create a complete game so let's just
write all the building blocks we will
need today our game will need input
handler class which will apply event
listeners to keyboard events and it will
hold an array of all currently active
keys
player class will react to these keys
as they are being pressed drawing and
updating the player
i will have a simple separate class that
will handle endlessly scrolling
backgrounds we will also need a class
that will generate enemies for us we
will have multiple active enemies in our
game so i will have a function called
handle enemies that will be responsible
for adding animating and removing
enemies from the game
i will have a utility function i call
for example display status text which
will handle things like displaying score
or game over message
and lastly we will have main animation
loop this function will run 60 times per
second updating and drawing our game
over and over
so that's it here we can see all the
building blocks we need to create a
complete game i could have wrapped
everything in a main game class for
example but i'm trying to keep it clean
and simple today
input handler class will apply event
listeners to the game and it will keep
track of all keys that are currently
pressed down inside constructor i
created this dot keys property and i set
it equal to an empty array the way i
want to handle controls today will be a
bit different from my previous courses i
want to have an array and i will be
adding and removing keys from it as they
are being pressed and released that way
i can keep track of multiple key presses
i will place event listener directly
inside the constructor when we create an
instance of a class all the code inside
constructor is executed because of that
just by simply creating an instance of
input handler class later all event
listeners will be automatically applied
i will have event listener for key down
event callback function on event
listener has access to this built in
event object i will assign it a variable
name for example e
and i console log it
now i create an instance of input
handler class which will run all the
code inside constructor so at this point
the event listener is applied
let's test it
when i click my canvas and i press key
on keyboard i can see this event object
here it contains all different details
about keyboard event that just occurred
what i care about today is this key
property it contains a string that
represents name of key that was pressed
so to get that value directly i say e
dot key
now i'm getting those values as console
logs
i care only about arrow keys right now
so i say if e dot key is arrow down
take this dot keys array from line 9 and
push that value inside
i move this console log here and i will
also console log this.keys
we will get an error this dot keys is
undefined
javascript cannot find it it's because
i'm instantiating input here and the
event listener is called from window
object
by the time that event listener is
called javascript forgot that this
keyword refers to this input handler
object and it's this.key's property to
make sure this keyword points to the
correct object i can use javascriptbind
method or i can use es6ro function
arrow functions don't bind their own
disks but they inherit the one from
their parent scope this is called
lexical scoping doing that will make
sure javascript doesn't forget which
object this keyword stands for and it
will work you can see pressing arrow
down adds an entry into this dot keys
array
i don't want to have multiple entries
for each key here we can see it added
arrow down 4 times i only want to add it
if that specific key is not in the array
yet so i do second condition here and i
say if this dot key's index of e dot key
key that was pressed is equal to -1 with
arrays if index off is equal to -1 it
means that element is not present in the
array
so i'm saying if key that was pressed is
arrow down and if that key is not yet
inside this dot keys array only then
push it into the array now you can see
that when i press arrow down multiple
times it adds it to the array only once
perfect i copy this code block and i
turn it into key up event
if key that was released is arrow down i
want to remove it from this dot keys
array so i call splice that takes two
arguments index of element we want to
remove and how many elements starting
from that index we want to remove so i
find index of arrow down inside this dot
keys array by using index of method
again
and second argument to splice i want to
remove one element at this index
so here i'm saying when we release a key
if that key is arrowed down find index
of that key inside this dot keys array
and use splice to remove one element
from that array
now when i press down arrow key it's
added to the array when i release it
it's removed from the array nice
let's also listen for other keys using
or operator
i start with arrow up
then we also need to listen for key down
on arrow left and arrow right
i'm gonna break this down on individual
lines for clarity and i use tab key to
make them vertically aligned be careful
here not to forget a bracket otherwise
the code will break
i will also listen for the same four
keys inside key up event
so we have this dot keys array here in
key down if arrow down up left or right
is pressed and that key is not yet
present in this dot keys array we push
it into the array
in key up when any of these four arrows
are released we find index of that key
inside this dot keys array and we use
splice method to remove it this dot keys
array now holds information about which
arrow keys are currently pressed down
sometimes it could be multiple ones at
the same time
i remove these console logs
by instantiating input handler class
here on line 50 all the code inside
constructor on line 8 will be executed
we have this.keys property as an empty
array and we use keydown and keyup event
listeners to add and remove specific
keyboard inputs from that array and now
we know how to handle keyboard inputs in
a game we will use them to move player
around in the next part
player class will define properties of
player object it will draw it animate it
and update its position based on user
input player object needs to be aware of
game boundaries we don't want it to run
off screen so i pass it game with and
game height as arguments and i convert
them into class properties like this
i'm using sprite sheet of specific size
here we have frames of width and height
of 200 pixels it's a good practice to
size your sprite sheets to the actual
size you will use in your game i can
also resize them with code but it's
cleaner to have art assets of the right
size
this.x will be 0 and this.y will be 0 at
first
player object will have public draw
method it will expect context as an
argument to specify which canvas we want
to draw on in case we want multiple
layers and multiple canvases in our game
i will start by calling build in fill
rectangle method to draw a rectangle to
represent our player i pass it x y width
and height
since i have black background i set fill
style to white so that we can see the
rectangle
on line 62 i create an instance of
player class using the new keyword here
on line 31 i can see player class
constructor expects game width and game
height as arguments so i pass it canvas
width from line 4
and canvas height from line 5.
i get an error game with is not defined
it's because i made a typo here on line
32
now it works and i can display our
player by calling its public draw method
we just wrote
it expects context as an argument so i
pass it ctx from line three
i can move player around by adjusting
its x and y coordinates let's make it
stand on the bottom of game area so this
dot game height
minus this dot height
we will also need update method to move
player around let's start by increasing
player's horizontal x-coordinate by 1
for every call of update method
if i call update method just like this
there won't be any visible movement i
put it inside animation loop and i use
request animation frame built in method
to make it loop i pass it animate the
name of its parent function to create
endless animation loop and i call
animate like this to start it
i also need to put draw inside
i delete this
we can see trail behind player rectangle
i want to only see the current animation
frame to delete old paint from canvas i
use built-in clear rectangle method it
will delete entire canvas between each
animation loop
perfect now we have player moving from
left to right as we defined in its
update method instead of drawing a white
rectangle let's draw a player image i
call build in draw image method
i need to bring player sprite sheet into
the project so this dot image property
is a document dot get element by id and
i give it id of player image
i pass this.image from line 38 to draw
method and i pass it x and y of 0 0 so
top left corner of canvas it will just
draw the entire sprite sheet at these
coordinates i pass it this this.x and
this.y instead you can see it just draws
the entire large sprite sheet with all
the frames draw image method can accept
optional fourth and fifth arguments for
width and height it will then stretch or
shrink the image to fill all available
area
like this
i actually just want to draw one frame
so i pass it another four optional
arguments source x source y source width
and source height
this defined rectangle we want to crop
out from the source sprite sheet and the
destination x destination y destination
width and destination height define
where on destination canvas we want to
place that cropped out rectangle onto
i pass it 0 0 as source x source y and
we are cropping to this dot with this
dot height so this area
now we can see top left frame in the
sprite sheet i can use source x and
source y to jump around the sprite sheet
by changing value of source y we can
jump between different rows by changing
the value we pass as source x we are
navigating within the sprite sheet
horizontally let's just turn these
values into class properties called for
example frame x and frame y
i replace them here and now we can
navigate around sprite sheet by changing
values of these properties perfect i
commented this line out the movement
will work this way we will have this dot
speed property initially i set it to
zero we will be adding this dot speed to
this dot x at all times when it's zero
there will be no movement when this dot
speed is a positive number player will
move to the right when it's a negative
number player will move to the left on
the negative direction on horizontal
x-axis
now we can connect keyboard inputs to
player movement update method will
expect input as an argument i take input
from line 69 and i pass it to
playerupdate method here
we are interested in this.key's property
from line 9 which holds all currently
active keys we can access that property
from input argument we are receiving
here so this section will deal with
horizontal movement
if input dot keys contains arrow up so
if index of arrow up is more than -1 run
the following code actually let's start
with arrow right and set this dot speed
from line 41 to 5. when arrow write is
found in this array from line 9 set
player speed to 5. it will make player 2
move to the right but there is nothing
to set speed back to zero so it never
stops moving i create an else statement
here and inside i set player speed back
to zero now player moves to the right
only when i hold down right arrow key
nice
i do else if statement here be careful
about the brackets it's easy to get it
wrong and get an error here
else if arrow left is pressed set player
speed to -5
now i can move player left and right
player can easily move off screen if we
hold the arrow for too long let's
introduce some horizontal boundaries
if horizontal x coordinate is less than
zero set it back to zero now we can't
move past the left edge of game area
else if player's horizontal coordinate
is more than game with minus player's
width meaning right edge of player
rectangle is touching the right edge of
canvas area also don't allow it to move
past this point
perfect
jumping is a bit more complicated but
it's not that hard i say if arrow up key
was pressed set velocity y property to
-30 i set velocity y property on player
object and initially i set it to zero
let's just move this around so that i
have controls in one place
horizontal movement separate and i
create a section for vertical movement
actually this line also belongs under
horizontal movement here
at all times i will be adding velocity y
property from line 42 to player's
vertical coordinate from line 37
initially velocity y is set to zero so
we will get no vertical movement when i
press up arrow key velocity y is set to
-30 and player just flies off screen i
need a force that will push in the
opposite direction i can call it gravity
or maybe weight i set it to 0 at first i
need a check to see if player is in the
air or standing on ground i will need
that check in multiple places so i might
as well make it into a utility method
like this
i call it for example on ground and it
will return true or false based on how
this statement evaluates if this.y is
more or equal to game height minus
player height we know player is standing
on solid ground here in vertical
movement section i say if on ground is
false meaning if player is currently in
the air take velocity y and start
gradually increasing it by distort
weight from line 43
i set this.weight to 1
we jump and eventually player falls back
down
size of the jump depends on how long you
hold up arrow key we don't want it to
work like that let's fix it when we
press up arrow key i set velocity y to
minus 10 so we can see it better
i create an else statement here and
inside we set velocity y back to zero so
if player is in the air gradually add
more and more weight to velocity y
else if player is back on ground reset
velocity y back to zero to stop vertical
movement if i jump too high player
partially falls through the floor before
velocity y is reset back to 0. to
prevent this from happening let's
introduce a vertical boundary on the
ground level if player's y-coordinate is
more than game height minus player's
height i set it the game height minus
player's hide player can never be below
this point
that works
the height of jump is still dependent on
how long i hold up arrow key because
each tick adds another -10 to velocity y
also if i press up arrow over and over
player will keep jumping higher and
higher we only want player to be able to
jump when it's standing on solid ground
here on line 55 i say if up arrow is
pressed and if player is on ground only
then decrease velocity y by -10
now we can't double jump anymore let's
do -30 for a bigger jump
maybe minus 32
so jumping works like this velocity y is
0. when we press up arrow key velocity
is immediately set to -32 this statement
on line 66 becomes true and weight of 1
is being added over and over to velocity
y
that will make velocity y go from -32 to
0 and then back to positive numbers so
player will go up it will gradually slow
down stop and it will start falling back
down again as the value of velocity y
goes from negative into positive numbers
when we hit the floor again line 69 will
set velocity back to 0 and the jump is
complete
when we jump we want to animate a
different row of sprite sheet i want
this jumping animation so i set this dot
frame y to 1.
when we land back on ground i set frame
y to zero
endlessly scrolling backgrounds are very
easy to implement i made a special
episode about different techniques i
like to use and how to split it into
individual layers for parallax effect
today we will just do a single endlessly
scrolling layer constructor will expect
the game width and game height and i
convert these arguments into class
properties
this dot image will be my background
image i gave it an id of background
image spelled like this
this dot x will be 0 this dot y will be
0 i check my image and i can see its
width is 2 400 pixels height is 720
pixels draw method will take context as
an argument to specify which canvas we
want to draw on i call built in draw
image method and i want to draw this dot
image from line 84. i pass it x and y
on line 109
i instantiate my background class by
calling the new keyword i pass it game
dimensions so canvas width and canvas
height
inside animation loop i call background
dota draw draw method from line 90 and i
pass it ctx as an argument we are
drawing everything on a single canvas
element so i need to draw background
first before i draw the player so that
the player is visible
now i want to make the background
animate to the left first i pass it
width and height here even though i
didn't have to do it since my art assets
are already correct final sizes there is
no need for resizing them with code
custom update method i create a property
i call speed and i set it to 20.
horizontal coordinate of the background
will be minus equals 20 pixels per frame
this will make it scroll to the left
inside animation loop i call background
update
and it just scrolls off screen
in update method i create a reset check
i say if this dot x is less than 0 minus
this.width from line 87 meaning if
background scrolled all the way off
screen set its horizontal x position
back to zero
to create an illusion of endlessly
scrolling background we need to use a
trick here i will be drawing the same
image twice i will position the second
image to the right next to the first one
by setting its horizontal x coordinate
to this dot x plus this dot width now it
looks like it's just one single and less
seamless image if i put a gap of 50
pixels you will see where the first
image ends and the second image starts
i remove the gap we never actually see
the full size of the second image they
are both scrolling at the same speed and
when we get to this point the image on
the right just fills the gap before the
first image can reset and start
scrolling again this happens very fast
so it creates an illusion of endlessly
scrolling seamless image i go much
deeper on this topic in a special
episode for now this is all we need to
know here sometimes you can still see a
small gap where the first image ends and
the second one begins you can easily fix
it by accounting for scrolling speed
when setting horizontal position of the
second image
i will comment out line 120 for now so
the movement doesn't distract us
you can do the same or keep it going
it's up to you
in our game player needs to avoid
dangerous enemies by jumping over them
enemy class will serve as a blueprint to
create a single enemy object
constructor will expect game width and
game height as arguments because enemies
need to be aware of game area boundaries
i check my sprite sheet and width of
single frame is
pixels
height is 119 pixels
this dot image will point towards image
element with an id of
enemy image
draw method will expect context as an
argument we call built in draw image
method i pass it this dot image from
line 107.
i will also need this.x and this.y
properties on my enemy
i pass them to draw method here
i create an instance of anime class
using the new keyword i pass it canvas
width and canvas height
i call enemy1 draw from inside animation
loop and i pass it cdx now we can see
what we are doing so back inside the
draw image method on anime class i pass
it width and height
i also need to pass it source x source y
source width and source height like we
did with player because we want to crop
out single frame from the sprite sheet
source x will be number zero times this
dot width source y could be zero times
this.height but since this sprite sheet
has only one row there will be no
vertical navigation so source y value
can stay hard coded to zero
i create frame x for horizontal
navigation in sprite sheet and i replace
it here inside the draw image method
vertical coordinate of the enemy will be
game height minus height of the enemy
and horizontal position is game width so
that it's hidden just behind the right
edge of canvas i create an update method
and inside we will just decrease x by
one per frame to make enemy move to the
left
i call enemy 1 update from inside
animation loop and we are animating one
enemy created with our enemy class i
don't want to just have one enemy i want
to have multiple active enemies on the
screen at the same time
up here on line 6 i create a led
variable i call for example enemies and
i set it to an empty array
i delete these two lines of code from
inside animation loop we will draw and
update our enemies from inside handle
enemies function on line 121
handle enemies function will also be
periodically adding new enemies to the
game so i take enemies array from line 6
and i call push on it we will push
instance of enemy class so new enemy
like this i know i have to pass it game
with and game height so i pass it canvas
width and canvas height here
then i want to call draw method and
update method from line 116 for each
enemy object in the array so enemies for
each
i call individual object in that array
for example anime and i use arrow
function syntax here for each enemy
object inside enemies array call their
draw method i pass it ctx and also call
their update method
i will be calling handle enemies
function for every animation frame so i
can't just leave
this line of code here like this i don't
want to push 60 enemies per second into
our game i take this line outside
temporarily so it will just run once on
the initial page load so it will add
just one enemy to the array at first
i call handle enemies from inside
animation loop here on line 143
perfect everything still works
let's say i want to add new anime into
the array every two seconds how do i do
that we can use timestamps and delta
time
i create a helper variable called last
time which will hold the value of
timestamp from the previous animation
frame inside animation loop i create a
constant called delta time
delta time is the difference in
milliseconds between timestamp from this
loop and timestamp from the previous
loop the value of delta time tells us
how many milliseconds our computer needs
to serve one animation frame usually if
we are running at 60 frames per second
delta time is around 16 milliseconds so
delta time is timestamp from this loop
minus timestamp from the previous loop
this time stem value is auto-generated
here request animation frame has a
special feature it automatically
generates a timestamp and passes it as
an argument to the function it calls
so because animate is being called over
and over by request animation frame here
it receives timestamp values as argument
each time it's called the first initial
call of animate here on line 149 doesn't
have auto-generated timestamp because
it's not being called by request
animation frame so i have to pass it
something here i pass it zero
when i calculated delta time difference
in milliseconds between timestamp from
this loop and timestamp from the
previous loop i set last time to
timestamp so that it can be used in the
next loop as the value for timestamp
from the previous loop our animation
loop is created by request animation
frame it automatically adjusts the
screen refresh rate so most screens will
run at 60 frames per second which means
if i control delta time i should get
1000 milliseconds divided by 60 frames
per second my delta time should be
around 16.6 milliseconds if you get a
different number here let me know i
wonder if we all get the same value
now that we have delta time we can use
it to time different things around our
code base we will use it to trigger
periodic events i pass delta time to
handle enemies
i comment this out i make sure handle
enemies expects delta time value to time
something periodically with delta time i
need two helper variables enemy timer
which will be counting milliseconds from
0 to a certain limit and every time it
reaches that limit it will trigger
something and reset itself back to zero
we will need enemy interval which will
be a value in milliseconds for that time
limit
i want to add new enemy in the game
every thousand milliseconds
every time timer reaches 1000
in handle enemies i say if enemy timer
from line 140 is more than enemy
interval from line 141 push new enemy
into enemies array then reset enemy
timer back to 0 so we can count again
else just keep adding delta time to our
enemy timer until the limit defined in
enemy interval is reached using delta
time like this will make sure our events
are timed the same on slow and fast
computers because faster computer will
have lower delta time so it will take
more loops to accumulate enough in its
timer that way fast and slow computer
will reach the limit at the same time i
explain this in more detail in a special
class i can also set enemy interval to
2000 milliseconds 2 seconds i create
this dot speed property on enemy class i
could give each enemy randomized speed
here using math at random i will give
all of them the same speed of 8 and here
i say this.x minus equals this.speed you
can see enemies come in a set interval
of 2 seconds very predictable maybe i
want to randomize that interval a little
bit
i can for example create a variable
called a random enemy interval and i set
it to a random number between 500 and
1500 milliseconds
i change enemy interval to thousand
whenever enemy timer reaches enemy
interval plus random enemy interval i
push new enemy and i set random enemy
interval from line 147 to a different
value
i could have also randomly set some
enemies further along x-axis to get the
same result now enemies are coming in
more random less predictable intervals
inside the draw method on player class i
can remove the white rectangle behind
the player i pause the background again
by commenting out line 154.
we are displaying just the first frame
in player and enemy sprite sheets let's
actually animate those sprite frames the
sprite sheets we are using are optimized
for speed between 15 to 20 frames per
second so i would like to be able to set
fps frames per second for sprite frame
animation while still allowing the rest
of our game things like player position
and background scrolling to update 60
times per second how do we do it with
delta time i'm passing delta time to
handle enemies here on line 157
i pass it along to enemy update method
and i make sure update method on anime
class expects that value update method
is being called from inside animate 60
times per second inside update method
here i will use the delta time to keep
track of how many milliseconds passed
between individual calls and only when
the right threshold is reached i will
swap frames in the sprite sheet to
animate sprite sheets horizontally i
will cycle between frame x of 0 and max
frame which in case of enemy sprite
sheet is 5. to time frame rate with
delta time i will need 3 helper
properties this dot fbs to set frames
per second let's do 20. keep in mind
this fps will affect horizontal
navigation within enemy sprite sheet how
fast we swap between individual
animation frames nothing else will be
affected i want the rest of the game to
run at 60 frames per second i could use
this technique to slow the entire game
down to 20 frames per second but then
player controls wouldn't feel very
responsive we would get delays in
collision detection displayed text and
so on i want to slow down only animation
of enemy sprite sheet nothing else i
will also need frame timer which will
count from 0 to frame interval over and
over and frame interval will define that
value we are counting towards it's a
value of how many milliseconds each
frame lasts so thousand milliseconds
divided by 20 frames per second in this
case
first let's cycle between frames at full
speed so if this dot frame x from line
111 is more than max frame set frame x
back to zero
else increase frame x by one
i have to do more or equal here so we
don't get empty frame
because of this source x attribute we
are pass into draw image method on line
119 cycling between 0 and 5 with the
frame x variable will animate sprite
sheet horizontally now you can see anime
sprite sheet is animating but it's very
fast these particular sprite sheets were
designed for lower frame rate we defined
fps of 20 on line 113
here i say if this.frame timer from line
114 is more than frame interval from
line 115 only then run this code that
manages frame x cycles at the same time
reset frame timer back to zero so it can
count again
else just keep adding delta time to
frame timer until the threshold of
milliseconds defined in frame interval
is reached now you can see enemy sprite
sheet is swapping between frames slower
at 20 frames per second while enemy
movement is still at original 60 frames
per second
inside update method on player class i
will do exactly the same thing first i
say if frame x from line 40 is more than
max frame
which i need to define here
we will start with this row and there we
have eight horizontal frames counting
from zero if frame x is more or equal to
max frame
set frame x back to zero else increase
frame x by 1.
run an animation on player is animated i
go down here to anime class and i copy
fps frame timer and frame interval
properties and i paste them here on our
player class
inside update method here we are dealing
with sprite animation here are controls
yes so if frame timer from line 44 is
more than frame interval run all this
sprite animation
code and reset frame timer back to zero
else keep increasing frame timer by
delta time
update method doesn't have access to
delta time so i make sure it takes it as
an argument when we call it here on line
181
up here i make sure update method
expects that argument now player sprite
sheet is animating at 20 frames per
second when i jump we get blink in
because max frame is set to 8 on line 41
and jump row doesn't have that many
frames so we are including empty frames
we have only two player states basically
jumping and running on ground so dealing
with that is easy down here we deal with
vertical movement when we are not on
ground we set max frame to 5 for jumping
animation else meaning we are on ground
set max frame to 8 for running
animation on line 151 we are adding new
anime to our game in a randomized
interval when i console look enemies
array i can see it's endlessly growing
and adding more and more enemies i
actually want to remove enemies that
moved off-screen from enemies array on
enemy class i create a property i call
marked for deletion and i initially set
it to false in update method i say if
horizontal x-coordinate on nma is less
than 0 minus enemy width meaning if it
has moved past the left edge of game
area set marked for deletion to true
inside handle enemies i say take enemies
array which we defined earlier as a let
variable and reassign it to the same
array but filter that array first and
only include elements that have marked
for deletion property set to false
filter is a built in array method which
creates a new array with all elements
that pass the test implemented by the
provided function in our case all our
elements are tested and checked if their
marked for deletion property is false
now you can see in console we have
between one and two enemies in the array
at any given time older enemies are
being removed
i want to display score on line 7 i
define a led variable called score and i
initially set it to 0.
on line 168 we have display status text
function i will use it to display
current score i pass it context as an
argument to specify which canvas we want
to draw on i set fill style to black
color
i set canvas font to 40 pixels helvetica
fill text built in canvas method will
actually draw the text it expects text
we want to draw and x and y were to draw
it i want the text to say score colon
space
plus value of score variable from line 7
x coordinate 20 y-coordinate 50. i call
this new function from inside animation
loop and i pass it ctx
inside update method on anime class i
will count score every time enemy moves
off screen assuming player successfully
avoided colliding with that enemy
and i increment score by one
that works nice i want to highlight the
font i can give it canvas shadow but for
some reason in firefox built in canvas
shadow property causes lock and frame
rate drops so i will do a trick here i
will draw the same message twice one
black one white the top one will have
two pixels offset so i kind of created
my own shadow manually let's check for
collisions between player and enemies
first we need to decide on the right
technique to use here the easiest ones
are collision between rectangles and
collision between circles where we give
elements like player and anime hitboxes
shaped as rectangles or circles we could
also do more complex and more precise
collision checks here such as collision
check between polygons called separating
axis theorem or we can base collisions
on color or opacity
our stroke rectangle around our enemies
so we can see basic collision hitbox
let's make it white
i do the same for player
you can see the rectangles now if i use
collision detection between rectangles
and i keep those hitboxes at their base
sizes whenever these two rectangles
touch or intersect we will get collision
between player and enemy i tried to
apply it before and i played with it and
sometimes we get really unfortunate
collisions like on this screenshot where
my player is landing from a jump
duck and worm images are clearly far
away from each other but you can see
that the corners intersect and we got
game over
i asked you in my community tab how you
would approach this challenge we spoke
about the different options we have here
some of you suggested separating access
theorem for collision between polygons
some of you think that we could use a
set of smaller rectangles that match
shapes of player and enemy sprites more
closely than one larger shape some of
you think that simple collision
detection between circles would be
enough in this scenario let's try to
draw circular hitboxes around our
objects to see what it would look like
it's also easy to offset these circles
by a specific pixel value horizontally
or vertically in relation to player and
enemy object we can also make them
smaller or larger if needed i agree with
you and i think that using circular
collision detection for jumping game
like this will get rid of accidental
collisions where two corners of
rectangles collide now i need to decide
where in our codebase we will run
collision checks i know i need to check
position of player against position of
all active enemies for each animation
frame so i might as well do it inside
playerupdate method i pass it enemies
array as an argument it contains all
currently active enemy objects
on line 59 inside update method on
player class i make sure update method
expects that argument we will calculate
collision detection here we need to run
it against every enemy object in enemies
array so enemies we passed as an
argument for each and then i do
collision detection calculation between
player circle hitbox and enemy circle
hitbox to do that we need to calculate
the distance between the center points
of these two circles and we compare that
distance with radius of circle 1 and
radius of circle two if the distance is
less than these two radii added together
we know we have a collision to get
distance between two points two center
points we use pythagoras theorem formula
we have a center point of player circle
and center point of enemy circle
we calculate distance on horizontal
x-axis dx
we calculate the distance on vertical
y-axis d y
it gives us imaginary right triangle and
we know hypotenuse of this triangle is
the distance between these two points we
calculate it as square root of dx
squared plus d y squared if distance
between center point of player circle
and center point of enemy circle is less
than radius of enemy circle plus radius
of player circle we have collision and
we set game over to true
upon line 8 i create a led variable
called game over and i set it to false
at first i want the game to pause when
game over is true so inside animation
loop i say only run request animation
frame and continue animating our game if
game over is false
you can see that when collision is
detected game stops perfect i also want
to display game over message so inside
the display status text function i say
if game over is true set text align to
center fill style to block
fill text game over try again and
coordinates canvas width divided by 2
and 50 200
make a copy again set fill style to
white and offset the second line by 2
pixels
i need to fix our collision detection we
are using enemy x and enemy y
coordinates as center points of
collision circle which means collision
area on each enemy is this blue circle
and same with the player since player x
and player y is at the top left corner
of rectangle area from which player
image is drawn i can't set it as center
point of collision circle because i did
do that we are not checking for
collisions between white circles we are
actually checking for collisions between
the blue circles i just drew the fix is
simple dx distance on the horizontal
x-axis between two center points needs
to be offset by half of enemy width and
half of player width to move these
center points from top left corner to
the middle of rectangle area
same goes for vertical dui check
brackets are very important here
now after this fix collisions are
correctly being detected between white
circle areas around player and enemies i
can offset these circles by specific
amount to move them around i can make
them smaller or larger we will expand on
this in the next episode in this class
we will learn how to use native
javascript full screen functionality how
to add touch support to our games and
how to measure length and direction of
swipes so that we can attach specific
events to them full series linked in the
video description let's make a mobile
game with html css and javascript let's
go
this is the game we built in the
previous lesson i will be using google
chrome browser as usual and if i right
click to inspect the page we have this
small mobile device icon here this tool
is great for designing responsive
websites keep in mind this is just an
estimate there might be some differences
when you run the same code on the actual
device this simulator is not 100
accurate as you can see canvas doesn't
even fit mobile screen on landscape
currently this project is not mobile
friendly at all it's actually very easy
to fix this i can click this icon to
toggle between landscape and portrait
view
i can choose different devices from this
drop down
so the first thing i want to do is to
make sure we can see the entire canvas
at all times on mobile i will do it with
css i give canvas max width property of
100
we are missing left border here let's
reset all default margins and paddings
and set box size into borderbox to make
sure elements border is included in its
total width modern css makes life so
much easier
so now in portrait mode you can set
canvas to any width and it will always
scale up or down to make sure we can see
all of it i switch to landscape and we
have the same problem how do we solve
this this is actually also very easy
barely an inconvenience
i give canvas max height 100
now canvas will scale until it hits
edges of screen vertically or
horizontally depending on aspect ratio
whichever boundary it hits first
look what happens when i make canvas
wider it still works i can switch
devices toggle between landscape and
portrait we can see all of canvas at all
times perfect there is also a way to
make canvas fit the entire screen with
no black edges but because of the
scrolling background we are using here i
would have to calculate aspect ratio i
want to keep this class beginner
friendly with no algorithms so i will
get back to that in more advanced
tutorial now you know a quick and easy
way to make canvas fit on mobile screen
without stretching and distortion
the only way to restart game right now
is to refresh browse window let's write
an actual restart game function so that
we can connect it to buttons or
keypresses or touch events we have to
think what needs to happen when game
restarts well first we need to restart
the player to its initial position
i will actually do it as a method on
player class i will call it restart and
inside we set x and y to the original
values
let's move player 100 pixels to the
right here and here
that's better after we start i want
player in running animation so max frame
will be 8 and frame y is 0.
down on line 200 inside our custom
restart game function i take instance of
player class from line 205 and i call
restart method we just wrote
i don't really have to restart
background or maybe i will just restart
its exposition back to 0 so that we get
some more visual feedback that we are
actually starting a new game again i
take an instance of background class
from line 210 and i call restart method
we just wrote
the last thing i need to do when game
restarts is to take enemies array score
and game over and send them back to
their initial values notice i'm removing
led keywords because i'm not declaring
new variables i'm just assigning new
values to existing variables where do we
call this restart game function from
here inside event listener inside key
down event we listen for arrows and we
push them into this dot keys array i
will create an else statement and if key
that was pressed is enter
and at the same time game over from line
8 is true we call the new restart game
function we just wrote
it's still not working and it's because
when game over is true i stop calling
request animation frame here since we
are setting game over back to its
initial false value i can call animate
again the start new animation loop like
this so we are playing game is running
i get game over
i press enter and reset function resets
our game awesome we are doing great so
far i should tell the user to press
enter otherwise how would they know you
can see after game reset score is off
screen it's because it's taking this
text align center we used for game over
message i need to set text align to left
here
and the message will be something like
game over
press enter to restart
this works ok touch events this will be
fun first i remove this console log from
line 175
up here inside input handler class we
will create a new event listener for
touch start event it will run whenever
user touches browser window when that
happens i console lock something i will
actually also need touch move and touch
end events
i'm gonna console start in touch start
moving in touch move and end in touch
end the way these work touch start fires
once as we start interacting with screen
then touch move fires over and over as
long as we are moving finger over the
screen and touch end just fires once
when user releases the touch this is
important to remember as we have to
consider these when we are structuring
our code code in touch start and touch
end will run once and the code in touch
move will run over and over as long as
the event is firing this is actually
very useful and we can use touch start
to set something up touch move to make
calculations such as direction and time
of the event and in touch end we do some
cleanup and discard or reset values we
don't need anymore there is no swipe up
and swipe down event so let me show you
how you can easily use these three touch
events combined to determine direction
of swipe let's have a look at auto
generated touch start event object by
console login e when i touch screen this
event fires and i can inspect it there
are many useful values here for example
it keeps track whether alt and control
keys were pressed at the time of the
event we have timestamp of the touch
here very useful and the main thing we
care about is x and y coordinates of the
touch x and y coordinates of touch event
are stored inside this read-only changed
touches property it's a list that stores
auto-generated touch objects that
contributed to this touch event with
touch start event we get just one object
so we have to open index 0 and here we
can see page x and page y properties
perfect we know where on screen this
touch event started
if i console touch move and i swipe
across my screen you can see that event
fires many times
let's go to one of the ones at the start
if i check inside change touches list at
index 0 i can see page y is 71 as i was
swiping the event was firing so let's go
to the last time it fired and here
i see page y is 104. i know this
particular swipe went vertically from
coordinate 71 to coordinate 104. we have
all these values we need to determine
whether user swiped up or down i put
this console lock into touch start event
and i remove all other console logs to
access vertical coordinate of touch
event i say e dot changed touches index
0 because this is a list and i want this
page y property
okay let's put that inside touch move
and touch end
i create a new property on input handler
class i call it for example touch y it
will store the initial start in vertical
coordinate maybe i also want the game to
only react to longer swipes to make sure
user actually swipes and the game
doesn't accidentally react to the simple
short tabs
i will call this property touch
threshold and i set it for example to
30. i wanted the starting touch point
and the ending touch point to be at
least 30 pixels apart to trigger the
event i could also make the player jump
higher here based on how long the swipe
is this technique is easy and very
powerful if you are designing mobile
games i hope you are realizing the
potential here in touch start event i
just want to set starting coordinate so
this dot touch y from line 13 is equal
to page y value from this event let's
delete all these
inside touch move i will compare current
coordinate and starting coordinate to
determine direction so let's have a
temporary helper variable called for
example swipe distance and set it to
page y value
of this tick of touch move event minus
the initial start in vertical coordinate
so minus this dot touch y from line 13.
keep in mind that touch move fires over
and over again as long as user is
swiping
i need more space
here if swipe distance is less than
minus this dot touch threshold from 914
so minus 30 we are swiping up so this
dot keys push swipe up this might be a
little bit difficult to visualize for
some of us so here's some animation if
it helps
at the same time i want to check if
swipe up is not yet in the keys array
so this is the distance between current
vertical coordinate and start in y
coordinate if this swipe distance is
less than -30 and swipe up is not yet in
keys array push swipe up into keys array
else if swipe distance is more than this
dot touch threshold so plus 30
push swipe down into this dot keys array
also here i need to check that swipe
down is not yet in the array before i
push it in there i don't want duplicates
of the same value in touch end i just
can't lock this dot keys
i can see we are getting many duplicates
in the array so something must be wrong
here i zoom out a bit so i can see the
whole thing on a single line these
brackets need to be here brackets are
important it's easy to make a mistake
and even a small thing can break the
entire project that's programmer's life
attention to detail and debugging
perfect now it gets added only once per
value
as i said i will use touch and event for
cleanup i will use splice method to find
swipe up in keys array and remove it and
i do the same thing for swipe down so in
touch start i save initial vertical
coordinate of touch event in touch move
i compare starting vertical coordinate
to the current vertical coordinate to
determine whether user is swiping up or
down and in touch end i clean up and
remove all touch events from our custom
keys array
let's remove this console log i want to
restart game when we swipe down i might
as well put it in here why not so if we
swipe down call our custom restart game
function we wrote earlier but only do it
if game over is true like this
so i get game over
i'm swiping up nothing happens i swipe
down and game restarts great
i can increase touch threshold if i want
some functionality to work only with
very long swipes i set it to 200 i swipe
down but only short nothing happens
longer swipe still nothing
i have to swipe almost the entire screen
from top to bottom to restart game now
so let's put the threshold back to 30.
i want player to jump when we swipe up
so here inside update method on
playerclass i put this part in brackets
because i want it to evaluate first
if keys array contains arrow up or if it
contains swipe up
and at the same time if player is on
ground make player jump
be careful about brackets it's easy to
create a bug here if you forget one
let's see reload game i run
swipe up and player jumps i swipe again
and again
this works touch events work really well
with simple games like this in the next
episode i will create a game with more
complex moves and special abilities game
like that is a bit more complicated when
it comes to touch events also in most
cases to make a mobile game like this
work you should resize your art assets
my player's sprite sheet has frames 200
times 200 pixels that's massive for a
mobile game and if i had many animated
objects on screen at the same time it
would start lagging very fast for a
bigger game i would have to create two
or more sets of art assets for different
screen sizes let's change game over
message so that user knows we can now
swipe down to restart
javascript also offers built-in native
full screen api that's easy to use it's
now well supported in all modern
browsers as far as i know only internet
explorer and mobile version of safari
don't fully support it we are web
developers here so i'm sure all of you
use updated version of a modern secure
browser on your machine
full screen api gives us methods that
allow us to present a specific element
and its descendants in a full screen
mode it will hide all browser user
interface elements sidebars and other
applications as long as full screen is
active let's create a button to toggle
full screen i give it id full screen
button for example and it will say
toggle full screen
in css i give it position absolute font
size 20 pixels but in 10 pixels
top 10 pixels
and transform translate x minus 50 to
center it horizontally
i bring it to my javascript project
using get element by id
i create a new function i call for
example toggle full screen let's
console.log
[Music]
document.fullscreenelement like this
and call toggle full screen function we
just wrote full screen element is a
built-in read-only property on document
object that returns the element that is
currently being presented in full screen
mode if it's null it means the full
screen is not active we can use this
property to check if we are currently in
full screen mode
i say if full screen mode is not active
take canvas variable from line 2
and call built in request full screen
this method is asynchronous it returns a
promise which means i can chain then and
catch methods to run some follow-up code
when the promise is fulfilled or
rejected i will just use cache today to
display potential error notice that the
request full screen is called on the
element i want to make full screen but
full screen element property sits on the
document object
today i won't put any follow-up code in
then method so i can delete it
in catch i will take the auto generated
error object if error happens we will
create alert and it will say some error
message
to concatenate message i can use
backticks instead of quotes this is so
called template literal syntax it's just
a simple way to combine strings of text
and expressions that need to be
evaluated into a single final line of
text i say for example error can't
enable full screen mode
and to insert variable or expression
inside template string we use dollar
sign and brackets like this here i just
put this auto generated error object and
its message property so we can read what
went wrong
so if full screen is currently not
active present canvas in full screen
mode else meaning full screen is active
call built in exit full screen method to
switch back to windowed mode
notice that exit full screen is again
called from document object if i save my
project and refresh browse the window i
get an error you can see catch method
worked and created alert pop-up window
with our message in console i can see
more information it says full screen can
only be initiated by user gesture here i
declared my toggle full screen function
and here i'm calling it on the first
page load we can't do that full screen
can only be triggered by user generated
events such as click or touch that's
what this error message is telling us we
can't just make javascript to
automatically trigger full screen it
needs to be triggered by a
user-generated event so instead of
running it on the first page load i
create an event listener for click event
on full screen button element we created
earlier when user clicks button then run
toggle full screen to exit full screen
on a computer you can also just press
escape key on mobile you can exit full
screen by swiping to reveal main
controls and press back or home key
depending on which phone you are using
sometimes we get unexpected collisions
and game over when player and enemy
images are not actually touching like
this it's because we are checking for
collision detection on circular hitboxes
around player and enemy and these
circles don't exactly match the sprite
sheet image collisions between complex
shape take a lot of performance and
especially for mobile games performance
is something we need to be more careful
about phones don't have as much
computing power as our desktop computers
do
it's usually not a problem when hitbox
doesn't exactly match sprite sheet shape
but it should be positioned in a way
that it's predictable when collision can
and cannot happen
i drew a simple circle around player and
now we can see its collision area let's
copy this code to display collision area
of enemies as well
you can see when these two white circles
touch we get collision and since the
circles are larger than player and enemy
image sometimes we get collision when
player and enemy images are clearly not
touching especially this one when we are
about to land from what seems to be a
successful jump how do we fix this
since player and enemy images are not
scalable in this game they are drawn at
fixed width and height we can shrink and
scale hitboxes by a value relative to
image size and we can also move the
hitbox left and right by specific pixel
amounts to try and match images more
closely and make collisions more
predictable we don't want surprise game
over like this i'm using a bit
unconventional technique here because
sprites are in a sense rectangular they
have start in x and y position and width
and height but i chose collision
detection between circles to remove
rectangular edges from sticking out
outside player and enemy shapes what i'm
about to do will work with rectangular
collisions as well if you prefer that we
are calculating collision detection
between player and all active enemies
here i explained it in the previous
episode we are basically checking
distance between center point of player
circle and center point of enemy circle
first horizontally and then vertically
we are drawing imaginary right triangle
and using pythagoras theorem to
calculate the length of hypotenuse which
is basically the distance between center
point of player circle and center point
of enemy circle
then we are comparing radius of player
circle plus radius of enemy circle to
that distance
if distance is more than sum of these
two radii circles are far apart
if it's the same circles are touching
and if the distance is less than sum of
radii circles are overlapping
here i'm just drawing white collision
area circle it's just a visual it
doesn't actually detect collision
collision is being detected here we are
inside player class and this is the
horizontal center point position of
player circle this is being used for
collision detection here
this is vertical coordinate of that
center point which is being used in
collision detection formula here
and this is the radius of collision area
circle we are drawing and that same
value is being used in collision
detection formula here i can simply
offset and resize that collision circle
visual in this area and then replicate
those changes inside the actual
collision detection calculation area
here let me show you what i mean
what if i want player circle to be
smaller maybe i don't mind that ears and
tail overlap let's say they are soft and
they don't count when it comes to
collision also maybe i want to make my
game a bit easier and forgiven this will
allow a small overlap between player and
enemy image what if i want to move the
collision hitbox downwards relative to
player image i change its vertical
center point position here plus 20
pixels seems fine now i compare changes
i made to the visualization and i make
sure i update the actual collision
detection formula to match these new
values
i didn't make any changes to horizontal
center point so that value stays the
same
i added plus 20 pixels to vertical
center point so i update it in collision
calculation here
i also made the circle smaller so i
update player radius value in this area
we successfully adjusted player hitbox
let's also do something about enemies i
can for example reduce the radius of
enemy circle
i also want to move it to the left to
cover head of the worm better
maybe -20 pixels for a horizontal center
point
i'm actually happy with this i want
collision to only happen when these two
adjusted smaller circles collide let's
take the changed values we used to
adjust enemy hitbox visual and transfer
them into collision detection formula
like we did with player i copy this line
just so i can look at it for reference
i put it here just temporarily collision
detection is inside player class so this
keyword here points to player object if
i want to point towards anime object i
can't use this keyword in this area we
adjusted horizontal coordinate of enemy
circle center point so i need to adjust
it here minus 20.
vertical center point of enemies stated
the same so i will not be making any
changes here
we did change enemy radius so i will
change enemy radius here and this is how
you resize scale and reposition hitboxes
in your game to make sure they match
your art assets more closely
i didn't plan to make this episode but
so many of you asked how to add mobile
support to our games so here we go
we can take it much further but i think
this was a good beginner friendly
introduction check out full series in
the video description if you want i'll
see you there
[Music]
when your games and applications start
getting bigger more exciting and full of
extra features it will be more and more
challenging to keep your code clean and
organized over time people came up with
the general reusable solutions to
commonly occurring problems these well
tested and widely used code structures
are called design patterns design
patterns are a tool kit of tried and
tested solutions to common problems in
software design you could split design
patterns into three main categories in
this class we will use state design
pattern to control player character in a
game it's a behavioral pattern that lets
an object alter its behavior when its
internal state changes why do we need to
manage player state let's say we have a
simple side scroller game our character
is standing and when i press up arrow
key i want it to jump this code has a
bug if i keep pressing up arrow while
jumping player character will fly off
screen so i have to do a check here only
run this code and jump if character is
standing on a solid ground great that
fixed it i also want to add sitting
animation but player can't enter sitting
state while it's in the middle of jump
player can sit down only when it's
standing or running on solid ground
maybe i also want a dive attack when
player tackles enemies from the air
again this move can only be entered by
pressing down arrow key while jumping
because when we are standing down arrow
key will make players sit down i'm sure
you can imagine how adding more moves
will create a very complicated if-else
statement and since all of that is
contained in a single piece of logic
adding one new move later on can break
all your other existing conditions and
you will have to review that single
massive logic tree every time you need
to fix a bug or add a new feature
since this is a very common challenge
game designers had to deal with for a
long time there is a tried and tested
way to do this right what if instead of
this complicated spaghetti code if else
statement we model our code structure
based on finite state machine we want to
have a limited set of states player
object can be in such as standing
jumping or sitting player object can
only be in one of those states at a time
and for each state it will only react to
a limited set of inputs we define
that way we have a class for each state
and in rules of that class i can say
that while player is jumping wait for a
certain time before switching it to
falling state or if you detect down
arrow key input transition player into
diving state other than that while in
jumping state ignore all other inputs so
pressing down arrow key while jumping
will switch player into diving state
pressing down arrow key while standing
will transition player into a seating
state in this class we will learn how to
implement state design pattern in a side
scroller game we will learn how to use
the native javascript modules to split
our code into multiple parts and many
other important game development tricks
and techniques as usual big like if you
are ready to start building bigger games
and learn how to make our code bases
scalable easy to navigate in easy to
manage and debug we are diving into more
advanced territory today the challenge
for beginners will mostly be to keep
track of what each class and function is
doing and how they interact with each
other check out some beginner-friendly
game development tutorials in the video
description if you just recently started
with html css and javascript i created a
simple web page this doc image will be
our spreadsheet you can download it in
the video description it was made by
this amazing artist check out his site
for more game development art assets i
include my image as img tag this time
that way i can wait for the image to get
fully loaded before i run any javascript
i include my javascript by using a
script tag but this time i will set its
type attribute to module like this this
will cause the browser to process any
contents of this particular script as
javascript module which will allow us to
split our code into multiple separate
files and use import export keywords to
connect the data inside you can see i'm
importing only the main script.js file
but we will also have player.js state.js
input.js and utilities.js splitting
files like this makes our project a bit
cleaner and easier to navigate in
javascript modules allow us to split our
programs into separate parts that can be
imported where they are needed node.js
had this ability for a long time but now
modern browsers support module
functionality natively use of native
javascript modules is dependent on the
import export statements and we will
cover how to use them today it's easy
don't worry there is only one catch when
using modules you need to run the code
in some kind of dev environment you need
to have a server if you just write index
html file and click to open it in
browser locally as you can do with all
my other course projects import export
keywords will not work you need to run
this code through a server there are
many ways to set up local server the
easiest one is to install a small plugin
to your code editor i'm using visual
studio code and when i click here on the
left side on the extensions icon and i
search extensions for live server i find
this plugin
it's been downloaded over 17 million
times so it's very popular mine is
already installed but if you don't have
it it will say install here after
installation you might have to close or
reopen your vs code when it's
successfully installed you will see this
go live icon right here if you never
used it it can act a bit unexpectedly
when you click go live it doesn't open
the file you are looking at at the
moment it will run code from the entire
project folder your vs code is currently
pointed at to make sure your live server
goes live with the correct set of files
you click file in the top left corner
and then click open folder and you
navigate to your project folder on your
local computer when you find it click
select folder and then when you go live
the correct project will open if you
can't see this new live server
notification area close your vs code
completely and reopen it and it will get
loaded the best thing about live server
extension is that when you save any of
the project files it will reload browser
window automatically you can always see
the latest preview of your code without
constantly manually reloading browser
on my windows computer i use control
plus s keyboard shortcut to save changes
to my file i use it a lot while working
in this environment so now we should
have a project folder running through
live server extension we have index html
file style css main script js file we
will have player js where we write all
the logic to control and animate our
player character state gs will be where
we write state design pattern to swap
between different player states input.js
will handle keyboard input and
utilities.js will have small useful
functions that for example display
status text or some other small tasks i
will speed up css setup because that's
very basic global reset to make sure the
page looks the same across different
browsers i will give canvas some
background so we can see it and i will
hide the sprite sheet image since we
will be drawing and animating it with
javascript i will also show you how to
create a very simple loading screen i
wrote this h1 tag with an id of loading
so i grab it here
i center it in the middle of the page
and i adjust its font size
script.js is my main module which will
connect all other parts into a final
piece of logic the spreadsheet we are
using today is a big image file so it
might take a second to fully load to
make sure javascript waits for all the
assets to be fully loaded before it runs
i will create a simple event listener
for load event
load event will wait for the entire page
to be fully loaded and available
including page content such as style
sheets images and so on in the meantime
this text that says load in will be
visible so if you add more art assets
user will see this loading screen for
however long it takes to load all assets
when everything is fully loaded this
event listener will run its code and
inside i will target this loading text
and i will hide it because the page is
fully loaded at the point when this code
runs
i will also set up my canvas so
document.getelementbyidcanvas1
i instantiate context object which
contains all built-in 2d drawing
properties and methods we will need
today
i set canvas width to window in width
and canvas height to window inner height
i can see canvas is now full screen so i
make it transparent
it's time to draw the player in
player.js i create a class i call player
player always needs to be aware of
boundaries of game area since we will be
running and jumping around and we need
to know when we reach the edges of
screen so i will pass it game with and
game height from the outside as
arguments and i will convert these
arguments to class properties like this
today we are learning about state
management we will be swapping player
between different states this dot states
will be an array and each position in
that array will be one possible player
state such as running jumping sitting
and so on
then we will have this dot current state
property because player can only ever be
in one state at one time current state
will be one of the options from this dot
states array so for example this dot
states index 0 will be standing state
index 1 will be jumping state and so on
this dot states is an empty array now
but we will fill it with states very
soon this dot image will be the docs
spreadsheet i already loaded it into our
project on line 12 in index html so here
i just point this variable towards it
using its dock image id i gave it the
dock image is a sprite sheet with
multiple frames when you divide width by
number of frames in the longest row or
you can think of these as columns you
will get width of one frame in this case
it's 200 pixels height divided by the
number of rows will give us the height
of a single frame in this case
181.83 pixels
let's first draw it at x and
y-coordinates 0 0 so from the top left
corner of canvas area
i create a public draw method that takes
context as an argument to specify which
canvas element we want to draw on i call
built in canvas draw image method i pass
it my doc image from line 7 and i draw
it at coordinates x and y
so this is our player class creating a
self-contained class that handles all
player functionality is a good example
of the first principle of
object-oriented programming called
encapsulation encapsulation means we rub
variables or data and functions that
operate on that data into objects
encapsulation can be used to protect our
data from unwanted outside access it
simplifies maintenance of our code by
keeping it organized and easier to
understand
since we are including our main
script.js file as a module and we are
running our code through a local server
we can use export import statements
native javascript modules are part of
es6 standard and allow us to split our
code into separate files so called
modules members of these modules so
classes functions and variables can be
exported and imported around our program
wherever they are needed i want to
export my player class there are two
types of exports named exports and
default exports each module each file
can have only one default export but
there is no limit on the number of named
exports namedexport looks the same just
without this default keyword to make my
player class available in main script.js
file i go up top and i say import player
from player.js
this dot slash means that player.js file
is in the same folder as script js
since player is a default export i don't
need brackets for named exports exports
that don't have default keyword in front
of them i would have to wrap them in
brackets like this but since player
class is a default export we don't need
brackets here and i can also refer to
player using default here but there is
no need to go into that much detail
about modules today i just want you to
understand the main idea and get
comfortable exporting and importing your
variables classes and functions between
modules
so now player class is available here
let's test if it works and instantiate
it i create a constant variable called
for example player and i set it to new
player here on line 2 in player js i can
see our player class expects game width
and game height arguments so i pass it
canvas width from line 8 and canvas
height from line 9.
if i consolidate player i can see my
object here and i can inspect it to see
all its properties and values
congratulations now you understand how
to use native javascript modules what
else should we learn today click the
like if you are getting any value
we created a public draw method on our
player class so let's call it here
i have an error because draw method
needs an argument for context otherwise
it doesn't know what canvas to draw on i
pass it ctx from line 7 because in this
project we only have one canvas element
nice we are drawing player image on
canvas what you see on canvas right now
is the entire sprite sheet on line 14
here we are telling draw method what
image to draw and what coordinates to
draw it at draw method will just take
the entire image at its original size
and it places it at these coordinates i
can change the coordinates here
built in canvas the draw image method
can take 3 5 or 9 arguments depending on
how much control we want to have over
the image we are drawing if i give it
optional fourth and fifth arguments
these stand for width and height and the
entire image will be stretched to fill
the rectangle defined by these starting
coordinates and these ending coordinates
the last longest version of draw image
method expects 9 arguments and it gives
us full control over the image we pass
it image we want to draw x y width and
height of rectangle we want to crop out
from the source image and x y width and
height of rectangular area where we want
to place that cropped out piece of image
on destination canvas
so right now i want to draw just a
single frame from player sprite sheet so
destination values will be this dot x
this dot y this dot width and this dot
height
and source values will be
let's start by cropping out this frame
in the top left corner so from
coordinates 0 0 two coordinates distort
with this.height
these two values determine start of
cropping rectangle so i can navigate
around the sprite sheet horizontally and
vertically just by changing these two
values
now i'm traveling along the sprite sheet
horizontally it's not very obvious on
this simple standing animation if you
watch doc's tale you will see we are
swapping between frames source y
argument here is for vertical navigation
now i jumped to this frame
i can swap between frames just by
changing these values
i might as well put them into separate
variables i create frame x variable for
horizontal navigation and i replace it
here i also create frame y for vertical
navigation and i replace it here
now i can jump between frames in our
sprite sheet by changing frame x and
frame y variables
wow we covered the main principles of
javascript sprite animation so fast
today i have a special glass about it if
you want to go deeper to finalize sprite
animation we just rotate between sprites
on each row endlessly using frame x
property and as we swap between
different player states such as running
and in we will be swapping between rows
of sprite sheet vertically using frame y
variable
before we do that let's place player in
the middle bottom of canvas to make it
seem like it's standing on the ground
this dot x is a game width divided by 2
minus player's width divided by 2
and middle bottom placement is game
height minus height of the player like
this
there are many ways to handle keyboard
inputs i want to keep our code clean and
modular so i have this input.js file
inside i create a default export again
and this time it will be a class called
input handler this class's job will be
to setup listeners for specific keys and
to keep track of the last key that was
pressed or released and it will have
only one class property called for
example this dot last key this value
will be updated every time one of our
selected keys is pressed or released
inside constructor i create an event
listener for keydown event callback
function on event listener in javascript
has this auto-generated event object
that is automatically passed as an
argument here i will refer to it as e
for example this e event object has all
kinds of different information about key
down event that just occurred you can
console e to see it i used it many times
before so i know this event object has a
property called key that gives us the
name of keyboard button that was pressed
i could use if-else statements here or i
can use a javascript switch statement
which is used to perform different
actions based on different conditions we
use it to select one of many blocks of
code to be executed based on which key
was pressed the syntax goes like this i
open switch statement and i pass it
expression to validate in this case i
wanted to check for value of event.key
which contains name of the key that was
just pressed in this keydown event i say
case arrow left and here some code to be
executed if e dot key is arrow left in
this case i will take this to the last
key from line 3 and i give it value
press left
make sure you spell it the same as me
it's case sensitive we can have multiple
cases here so far i just have one but i
will add more arrow keys in a minute
switch expression on line 5 is evaluated
once and it is compared with each case
in this case it will check if e dot key
is equal to arrow left
if it is code on line 7 will be executed
we can also give it default case with
code to run if there is no match but i
will not be doing that today let's copy
this event listener and i change it to
key up event
when arrow left is released i will set
this dot last key from line 3 to release
left this way i can keep track of
specific keys being pressed and released
i can't lock e dot key inside key down
event just to check if everything works
so far so i have this custom input
handler class and all this code is
inside its class constructor which means
all this code will get auto executed
when i create an instance of this class
using the new keyword instantiate an
input handler class will automatically
attach these two event listeners to our
browser window object
i'm exporting this class here and i will
instantiate it from a main script js
file by saying import input handler from
input.js
with input handler class available i
create a constant variable called for
example input and i set it to new input
handler that's it now when i click my
canvas and i start pressing keyboard
it will console log names of those keys
those names are values of key property
on auto generated event object coming
from e dot key here so creating an
instance of input handle class
automatically executed all the code
inside its constructor which added event
listeners to our project
we care only about certain keys we will
ignore others right now pressing and
releasing left arrow key will update
this dot last key property last key
stores the last keyboard input that was
pressed or released i will add more keys
in key down i add case for arrow right
and i set last key to press right
and in key up event listener we set it
to release right
i will add break keyword after each case
if we find a match we don't have to
check the others so we are listening for
presses and releases of left and right
keys let's see if everything works i
can't lock input from line 14
dot last key which is coming from line 3
and input js file
it's not working because we have a
problem with this keyword since i'm
attaching event listener to window
object from inside a class i need to
bind that reference to this keyword so
that when event listener runs this line
later it still remembers that this
keyword stands for this property on
input handler object i can use built
javascript bind method here or i can use
es6 arrow function syntax which has a
special built-in feature when compared
to regular function
arrow functions do not bind to their own
in this but they inherit one from their
parent scope this is so called lexical
scoping because of this behavior arrow
functions allow us to retain the scope
of the caller inside the function so we
don't need to use bind
in other words use an arrow function
here we'll make sure these lines of code
will correctly remember we are pointing
them to this class property
i will also need animation loop so
custom function i call for example
animate inside i will console
input.lastkey
request animation frame and i pass it
animate which will create an endless
animation loop
i start the loop by calling animate like
this
now when i click on canvas and i press
left or right arrow keys we get the
correct console logs for left
i misspelled arrow right on lines 9 and
19.
now everything works great
utils.js is just a place where i can
have my small utility functions i want
the function that will display the last
key that was pressed i want to draw that
text on canvas so that i don't have to
check console it will be very simple i
call it draw status text
it will take arguments for context to
specify what canvas we want to draw on
and input so that we have access to the
last key value
i set canvas font property to 10 pixels
helvetica for example fill text method
takes text we want to draw and x and y
where on canvas we want to draw it so i
pass it last input colon space plus
input dot last key and i want to draw it
at coordinates 10 20 i guess
let's export it and import it in script
js this time i'm not exporting it as a
default so i have to wrap it in curly
brackets like this
i import draw status text in brackets
from utils.js and i call it inside
animation loop here on line 19. it
expects context and input as arguments
so i pass it ctx from line 9 and input
from line 15.
let's make it larger maybe 30 pixels
and coordinates 2050
nice it works i need to make sure i
clear my canvas between frames to delete
old paint build in clear rectangle
method and i want to clear the entire
canvas from coordinates 0 0 to
coordinates canvas with canvas height
this will delete my player so i have to
redraw it for every frame by placing
player.draw inside animation loop
nice so far we only care about left and
right arrow keys when we press them
canvas gets updated let's delete this
console log
state design pattern allows objects to
change their behavior based on their
current state in this case we will start
very simple to demonstrate the main idea
we will swap player between stand and
left and stand and write state entering
each state will draw a different row in
sprite sheet and in each of these states
player will only respond to a limited
set of keyboard inputs when we are
standing left we will ignore additional
presses of left key and we will only
react when user presses the right key
which will swap us to standing right
state in the stand and right we will
ignore any additional presses of right
key and only pressing left arrow key
will swap us to standing left state in
each state we can limit what keys player
will react to and we can write logic
that defines behavior for each key press
separately i will keep all potential
player states in this dot states array
here and i will keep track of the
current one in this dot current state
here the way this is done is that each
state in this dot states array will be
its own object generated by a separate
class don't worry let's go through it
now and make sure we explain it properly
so that it's easy to understand in state
js i will define class for each state i
will have an object that will contain a
list of all possible states usually it's
a good idea to use enum for this in this
case we will use enum to define a set of
named constants we define a name for
each state and assign it a number the
order of these states must match the
order in which we add them to player
states array and that way swapping
between states will be more readable
because instead of swapping to state 0 i
will be able to swap to state standing
left for example it will make our code
easier to read that's why we're writing
this enum statement i will have just two
states at first to demonstrate the
entire logic on a simple example
standing left will be state 0 and stand
and write will be state 1. i create a
custom class called state its job will
be just to hold this dot state property
which will be passed to constructor as
an argument it will take this argument
and it will turn it into class property
this is just to keep track of name of
the currently active state so that we
can write that state name on canvas
in state design pattern each state is
usually defined by a separate class so
let's create a class called standing
left
and that class extends state class from
line
extends keyword is used to create a
child class by extending a class i'm
setting up a relationship between these
two classes this is parent and this is
child
extending classes is a good example of
one of four pillars of object-oriented
programming called inheritance
inheritance is a process where one class
inherits attributes and methods from
another class we use it to avoid code
repetition
i will create multiple child classes
that all extend this state class if i
want i can define a method on parent
state class and it will be inherited by
all child classes automatically so that
i don't have to define them on each
class separately
all child classes will also have access
to this.state property because if i
reference a method or a property from
inside a child class if javascript can't
find it on this class it will go look
for it automatically on the parent so
this is our parent class also called
super class and this is so called child
class or sub class it will have its own
constructor and that constructor will
expect player object as an argument
because i need access to player
properties on here since i want to be
changing things like player sprite sheet
row or player speed as we swap between
different states constructor is
automatically executed when we create an
instance of a class so the first thing i
will do is use super keyword we can use
super keyword in child classes to access
and call methods on object's parent when
super is used in a constructor like we
are doing here it must be used before
this keyword calling super here will
execute all the code inside the parent
constructor on line 7. in this case we
need to pass it name of current state
standing left and constructor will set
it as a value for this dot state class
property on this particular subclass
we'll just use that to write currently
active state on canvas a bit later now i
take player object passed as an argument
and i convert it to class property here
my standing left child class will have
enter method that will do everything
that needs to be done when player enters
this particular state for example it
will change its speed or sprite sheet it
will also have handle input method which
will listen for a predefined set of
inputs and swap to a different state
when the correct key is pressed enter
method will just run once when standing
left state is entered handle input
method will run over and over per each
animation frame
let's copy all this and make another
child class called standing right i pass
stand and write string to its super
class constructor
notice that we have two subclasses
extending one superclass both of these
child classes have methods that are
named exactly the same this is very
important
placing methods with the same names on
different objects is an example of one
of the core concepts of object-oriented
programming called polymorphism out of
these four concepts it's the most
complex one to fully understand since it
has multiple types in this case
polymorphism allows methods to display
different behavior depending on which
class calls it we will be calling enter
and handle input methods from player
class using the same line of code every
time but as player swaps between
different states different code will be
executed because enter method and handle
input methods will contain different
behavior for each player's state for
each class those differences will be
defined here so for this code to work
every player state class we define needs
to have enter method that runs once
every time we enter that state to set
things up and it needs to have handle
input class method that runs
continuously waiting for specific inputs
to be pressed to switch player object to
a different state handle input method
will take input as an argument player
object has this dot frame y property
which determines which row of player
sprite sheet we are animating
when we enter stand in left state i want
to animate row 1.
stand and write animation frames are on
row with index 0. the main principle of
state management pattern is that when in
specific state object will only react to
a limited set of inputs other inputs for
which we don't define behavior here will
be ignored so inside standing left class
if input is pressed right we will set
state to stand in right
when player object is in stand and write
state and input is pressed left we will
switch player to stand in the left state
and the final piece is the mechanism
that will actually allow us to swap
player to a different state that code
will come here i create a custom public
method on player class called for
example set state and it will take the
new state as an argument inside i set
this dot current state from line 6 to
distort states from line 5 and index
will be this state number we passed as
argument of course this will only work
if this.states actually contains some
states right now it's empty we will fill
it in a minute
we know that each of our states has
enter method which will run once when
player enters that particular state to
set up our sprite sheet to make sure we
are animating the correct row
back in set state we switch player to a
new state and we call that enter method
if we pass it 1 here enter method will
be called on standing left state if we
pass it 0 here method will be called
from and write state
because in our enum we gave standing
left state a value of 0 and standing
right state is value 1.
so now we have a public method that can
swap player between different states if
player is currently in standing left
state and handle input method detects
that we pressed right arrow key we call
it
this.player.setstate and on line 18 here
i see it expects state as an argument
that argument will be a number right now
we only have two states so either zero
for standing left or one for stand and
write will come here
you can see we say distant states
and index in square brackets so we are
referring to this dot states from line
5.
again we will fill this array with state
objects in a minute so i want to swap
player to stand in right state here i
can see stand right is 1 here so to pass
it number 1 i pass it states from line 1
dot stand and write from line 3. this
entire enum object is here just to give
me more readable values to these numbers
that represent states it would also work
if i just passed it number one directly
here but number one past the set state
method will be passed here on line 18 as
an argument and this dot current state
will be assigned this dot states from
line five index one this array will need
to have two elements as we have two
states element with an index of zero and
element with an index of one these will
not be just simple numbers like this
these will be entire instances of
standing left and standing right class
but before i can use those classes here
in player.js i need to import them
to import multiple classes from the same
file we need to wrap them in brackets
in state.js i export standing left class
from line 10
and standing right class from line 22.
in player.js i import both of them from
statejs like this
i need to make sure i save changes to
all files i made changes to
i have an error because i didn't finish
this other if statement if player is in
stand and write state and handle input
method detects we press left arrow key
call set state on player class and pass
it number 0 states that standing left
this stands for 0 so 0 is being passed
here to set state and this dot current
state is set to this dot states from
line 7 index 0 which is this now we can
finally define our states here properly
so index 0 in player states array will
be an instance of standing left class so
new standing left
and index 1 will be new standing right
we need to make sure that state objects
in this array have the same indexes as
numbers we defined for each of these
states inside enum here
now that we can swap between states i
also need to be calling a handle input
method over and over so that we can
listen for new inputs and change states
when needed i create update method on
player class and it will take input as
an argument inside this method i will be
periodically calling handle input from
this.currentstate property from line 8.
this property represents currently
active state because of logic we defined
on line 24 so player will be either in
standing left or in stand in write state
it will call either handle input method
from line 19 that reacts only to press
right or handle input method from line
30 that reacts only to press left
i call it like this and i pass it input
that we passed here as an argument that
input then comes through here so that
handle input method can check what was
pressed and if the right key is pressed
it will swap player states
we call playerupdate we just wrote from
animation loop and i pass it input from
mine17 dot last key from line 3 in
input.js
we are done we just wrote the entire
logic for state management of player
object let's quickly follow the logic
one more time to make sure it's clear
we are calling update method for every
animation frame and passing it
input.lastkey the last key from selected
inputs that user interacted with that
input last key is passed here this time
i call it just input and i pass it to
this.currentstate from line 8
dot handle input and i pass that same
input value along
this dot current state represents the
entire state object at first i am
setting it to distort states index 0
which is this standing left object so
for this animation frame handle input
will be called from standing left class
so from here i can see constructor for
standing left and standing right expects
player as an argument so that we can
then correctly set up our sprite sheets
here and here inside player.js i need to
pass it that player argument since we
are inside player class right now i pass
it this keyword which in this scope of
this class represents the entire player
object
okay so current state is this dot states
index 0 which means our standing left
class and we are calling handle input on
it so handle input from line 18 will be
called
if the initial current state is index 1
that would be stand and write state so
this handle input method will be called
from line 30 instead
if handle input is called from standing
left class it will only react if right
arrow key is pressed and it will swap
player to stand in write state if player
is currently in stand in write state
handle input will only react to left
arrow key being pressed and it will swap
player to stand in left state whenever
we set a new state it will update which
of these two states this dot current
state is pointing towards and then from
that new state it will call this enter
method enter method was defined on lines
15 and 27 and depending on the current
state it will set sprite sheet to
animate a different row i save changes
to all my files and when i click my
canvas and press left and right arrow
keys we are correctly swapping between
standing left and standing right state
let's display what state player is
currently in on canvas as well here on
line 24 every time set state is called
we set this dot current state from line
8 to one of our available states so far
we have standing left at index 0 and
standing right at index 1.
parent class of all our states has
this.state property in its constructor
we are given that property a different
value from each child state by calling
superclass constructor from each
subclass basically all that this is we
are declaring this.state property on
parent class that property is being
inherited by all child classes and it's
set to standing left on this class on
line 12 and to standing right on this
class on line 24. i just wanted to draw
this value on canvas so that we know
currently active state
i will use our existing draw status text
function for that we are calling it from
inside animation loop here and i need to
pass it player object so that we can
access current player state
here i make sure my function expects
that argument the same as we did with
input last key
i will call fill text and i say active
state
colon space plus player we passed as
argument dot current state dot state
when current state is set to standing
left this dot state here will be set to
standing left and that's what will get
displayed for standing right it will
display this line
as i said before using super keyword
inside child class constructor will call
constructor of its super class its
parent class and it will execute all its
code in this case this code will assign
value of stand and write to this
inherited state property when using live
server in vs code watch for these dots
here it means you have unsaved changes
in your file so just make sure you save
all your code in each file if you're not
getting the same result as me i save my
changes i also have to give fill text
some x and y coordinates how about 2100
maybe 90 and i reduce font size to 28
pixels
when i save my changes and interact with
canvas now when i press left and right
keys we see status text that tells user
the last input that was pressed or
released and currently active player
status that's it state pattern is
complete now we just add more states by
extending it before we add sitting and
running state let's recap the logic
because i realize this must be lot for
beginners to follow if you are following
so far well done you are doing great
it all starts by calling playerupdate
and passing it the last key that was
pressed or released
inside update method we take that input
and we pass it along to handle input
method
the whole trick here is that we are
calling handle input from this dot
current state property which swaps
between different states
when we pass it 1 it points to state
with index 1 inside this dot states
array so in this case stand and write
object if it's zero it points towards
standing left state object both of these
objects have their own version of handle
input method so that as we point current
state towards different state objects
behavior of player will change even
though we are always calling the same
handle input method it's important that
all our state objects have their own
definition of enter method and handle
input method i could also created a
backup enter and handle input method on
their parent class here
in case child class doesn't have methods
with these names but let's not over
complicate things i like to think of
this type of state management as we are
locking player in different states while
player is in a specific state it will
ignore some inputs and it will only
react to inputs we define in its handle
input method
here we can see that while in standing
left state player will only react to
pressing right arrow key and it will
make it switch to stand and write state
while in stand and write state player
will ignore all inputs except for
pressing of left arrow key which will
make it swap to standing left state
you might notice that state design
pattern has some code repetition but the
code is easy to navigate in and if we
get a bug it will be limited to a
specific state making larger projects
much easier to manage and debug if we
get some unexpected behavior we can see
what state was our player object in when
that unexpected thing happened and what
was the last input key that was pressed
or released and we check our code inside
handle input method on that particular
state to see what went wrong structuring
your code like this comes very useful
when you want to give your player
multiple abilities weapons and special
moves
we are capturing the last key that was
pressed here inside our input handler
class i'm importing and instantiating
that class here in script.js and passing
it to playerupdate method
we pass that input value along to
handleinput method and value of that
input gets checked against the set of
specific values we define for each state
and based on that we swap player to a
different state using our custom set
state method
setstate method takes a single number as
an argument as we defined them inside
enum state that standing right is one
state dot standard left is zero so right
now i'm basically passing it number one
here
that number travels as an argument past
the set state here
it's passed along here and it represents
index of that state inside this dot
states array on player class so number
assigned to each state inside enum
object in state js have to correspond to
index of each of these particular states
inside this dot states array on player
class
that way when it receives number 1 here
it swaps to stand in write state if it
receives number 0 it will set state to
stand in left after swap into a specific
state enter method will run once to set
up player object for entering that state
in our case we just adjust spreadsheet
row for now
and then it continuously calls handle
input method from that state class which
listens to specific set of keyboard
inputs that's why we have enter and
handle input methods with the same names
on each state so that we call them from
the same place but we get different
behaviors depending on which state
object is player dot current state
pointing to words at that particular
moment
let's add sitting state i copy this code
block and case will be arrow down if you
want to know what are the values of e
dot key so that you can check for
correct spelling of key names you can
just console log it here
i'm going to say if e dot key value is
arrow down set this laplace key from
line 3 to press down
in keyup event we set it to release down
in state.js i copy this code block i use
it to create a new class called sit in
left i pass it sitting left here i check
my spreadsheet and i see that sitting
left animation is on row nine
we are counting from zero while in sit
in left state if we detect that user
pressed right key we will swap player to
sit in right state which we will create
in a minute else if we detect that user
pressed up arrow key we will make it
stand up again
i need to create these new key value
pairs in my enum object up here so
sitting left will be 2 and sit and write
will be 3.
in input js i will check if pressed key
is arrow up and i set last key to press
up in key up event i set it to release
up
so now we are tracking presses and
releases of all four arrow keys perfect
in my new sitting left class when we
press right we set state to sit and
write and when we press up
our dock will simply stand back up so
here i need to do standing left because
we are going from sit in left state
i copy this code block and i turn it
into sit and write class we set name of
state to sit and write so that it
displays correctly here
while in sit and write state if we press
left we set state to sit in the left
if we press up we set state to stand and
write
in player.js i import these two new
state classes i instantiate them inside
this.states array while making sure i am
adding them in the right order
nice so we have two new state classes i
hope you can see now how state pattern
limits the number of inputs player
reacts in each state
we have logic that defines how player
behaves while in these two new sitting
states but we have no way to actually
enter these sitting states i go inside
standing right class and i say if input
is pressed down
we set state to sit in right
if we press down while in standing left
class we set state to sit in left i also
need to make sure enter method on the
seat and left class sets player sprite
sheet to the correct row
sitting left is row with index 8.
actually sorry sitting left is row index
9 sitting right is row index 8. now it's
correct i will also set the initial
state to stand and write so distort
states index 1 just for the first page
load before we start pressing keys and
swapping player states now when we press
the down arrow key player will sit we
can press left and right keys to make
player turn left and right while sitting
and pressing up arrow will make it stand
up and face the correct direction
this is going really well we can also
change how the entire sitting state
works by only making the player sit
while arrow down key is being pressed
and when it's released player will stand
back up automatically so inside sitting
left state if input is released down we
set player to standing left and inside
sit in right we set player to stand and
write
it well depends on what kind of game you
are building and what player behavior
you want i hope you can see that you get
a lot of freedom and flexibility with
this code structure you can easily
control every detail of player behavior
when you structure code like this the
way i wrote this code we only react to
the last key pressed i'm not keeping
track of multiple key presses in memory
since i want to keep this simple but i
will cover how to handle pressing
multiple keys at the same time in a
special episode as well probably
added running states will be similar but
we will have to handle horizontal speed
so let me show you how to do that again
i start by adding new states inside my
enum running left will be state number
four running right will be number five i
make a copy of this block and name it
run and left
i put running left here i check my
sprite sheet and the row for this
animation is 7. when we release left
while in this state we will switch
player into standing left state and when
we press right we will switch into run
and right
i also copy this line of code from here
and when we press down from running left
state we will go into sit in left state
duplicate this and turn it into run and
write state if we press left arrow key
while in run and write state we will
switch into run and left
if we release right key we will go into
stand right and pressing down arrow key
will make players sit to the right
not every game needs to have left and
right version of each state also there
are other ways to write code when you
have a set of states that each has left
and right version or maybe each state
has a version with weapon ready and
weapon hidden for example again i'm
doing it like this for simplicity and to
demonstrate the main idea of my version
of state management pattern
so we defined behavior for player while
in running states now we need a way to
actually enter these states we can enter
running from standing state for example
while standing left if we press right we
set state to run and right
here inside run and write state we see
that when we release right key it will
switch back to stand and write state
so we are only running as long as the
key is being pressed down if we press
left while in standing state we will
start running to the left i get this
error because i refreshed my project
before i finished adding new state on
player class don't worry about that
while in standing right state if we
press left we will start running left
if we press right we will start running
right
so here we are exporting two new state
classes we just wrote
here we are assigning them values four
and five these numbers need to
correspond to indexes
to order in which we add these states
inside this dot states array here first
i import them on line 1 as usual and
then i add instance of running left
class as index 4 in this array and
running right will be the fifth item in
this array counting from 0.
i save changes to all my files run in
right animation is row 6 in our sprite
sheet perfect it works and swaps between
running and standing states correctly we
also want player to actually move when
in running state so let's give it this
dot speed property and set it to zero
then i create max speed property and i
set it to 10 pixels per frame for
example when we enter running state we
set player speed to player max speed and
in running left we set player to minus
player max speed because moving left is
in the negative direction on horizontal
x-axis inside update method on player
class i will be adding player speed from
line 16 to horizontal position from line
12. problem now is that player will just
move off screen because even when we
switch away from running state nothing
is setting player speed back to zero
so when we enter standing left state we
set player speed back to zero
we do the same thing inside enter method
on stand and right
sitting left and sit in right state
perfect
player now stops moving when we enter
standing or sit in a state i will also
introduce horizontal boundaries so users
can't move player outside the canvas if
horizontal position of player is less or
equal to zero i set the position to zero
else if the position is more or equal to
game width minus player with meaning
player's right edge is touching right
edge of canvas i will also not allow it
to move past that point
this is going so well we applied state
management to our player and we have
granular control over its behavior
separated for each state we can do so
many things with this
common thing you will see in games is
jumping again there is a new small trick
we have to use here if you never coded
jumping in a 2d side scroller game we
will learn how to do it properly right
now and we will make it look really good
by switching player to a separate
falling animation after it reached peak
height of its jump let me show you that
swapping between states doesn't always
have to happen on user input we can also
tie state swapping to other game events
in this case we will swap a player from
jumping into falling state after it
reached maximum height of its jump
we are creating new states as usual i
will first add them up here to our
states object which we are using to pair
readable state names with numbers that
represent each state i copy already
exist in state class and i turn it into
jumping left class i check my
spreadsheet to see which row has a jump
in left animation frames i delete player
speed i think because i want the speed
to be inherited whether we enter jump
from standing on running state
we will see about that
i delete all these inputs for now i copy
this block and turn it into jumping
right class
frame y for jumping right is row with
index of 2.
i go up to standing left state and when
input is pressed we switch player to
jump in left
inside stand and write state when we
press up arrow key we set state to jump
in right
i'm exporting these new state classes so
in player.js i can import them
and i instantiate them inside player
states array
i'm getting an error
it's because up here in my enum i
skipped some values let's assign my new
states to the correct values now we
correctly enter jumping state when i'm
in that state it doesn't matter what i
press we are locked in that state
because inside handle input method i
didn't give it any way to switch off to
a different state first when we enter
jumping state let's push player upwards
on minus direction on vertical y axis
when we enter i say this.velocity y
minus equals
i do the same for jumping right state
in player.js inside update method we
will deal with vertical movement here
i give player v y velocity y property
and i give it property i call for
example weight i could have also called
it gravity or something i will use
velocity y to pull player upwards and
wait to pull player down
as the ratio between these two values
changes during the jump it will create a
nice jumping curve
for every frame we will add
this.velocity y from line 14 to player's
vertical y position from line 13.
right now velocity y is zero so even
when we are adding it there will be no
vertical movement
if player is not standing on the ground
so if player y is less than this.game
height minus player height gradually add
value of player weight to velocity y
else meaning player is standing on the
ground set velocity y back to zero give
me a second to figure this out to make
sure i'm doing it correctly
in state gs here i actually want to
access the velocity y property on player
object so this dot player v y minus
equals 20.
i get small jump and it stops moving
again
oh yeah this is a typo this needs to be
game height
now it's working we have multiple places
in our code where we need to check if
player is standing on the ground or if
it's currently in the air this is a good
time to create a small utility method on
our player i will call it unground
and its job is to check if player is
standing on the ground
i will just make it return true or false
directly like this
based on how this expression evaluates
if player's y coordinate which is the
top edge of player image rectangle if
it's more or equal then game height so
this point minus player height so if
this point is more or equal than this
point we know player is standing on the
ground so this method will return true
else it will return false now i can just
call this method whenever i need to do
this check and it will also make the
checks more readable
here on line 32 i'm checking if player
is not on ground so i say if on ground
is false
actually if this dot on ground is false
now it's working
i want player to be able to switch sides
while jumping so in jump in left state
if we press right arrow key we set state
the jump in right
in jump and write state if we press left
arrow key we set state the jumping left
player is flying off screen really far
let's change this to minus equals 10.
that's a very small jump but you will
notice a bug here if i swap between
jumping left and jumping right quickly
each time we enter these states we are
running their enter method so each time
we push player further and further up i
want the player to only be able to
propel itself further up if it's
standing on the ground so in enter
method on both jumping states i will
first check if player.on ground is true
before we push it upwards
if it's already in the air this will be
false and player will receive no
vertical push i change these values to
minus equals 40.
i just make sure i spell on ground
correctly
perfect we are able to turn to sides
while jumping i will actually give it
some horizontal speed as well when we
enter jumping left set player's
horizontal speed to half of player's max
speed
and the same for jumping right
in jumping left it actually has to be
negative number since we want to move in
minus direction on horizontal x-axis
that works awesome i can switch between
jumping left and jump and right states
but otherwise i'm locked in jumping i
didn't give it any way to get back to
running or stand in state inside jumping
left i check if player on ground is true
and when player gets back on the ground
we set its state to stand and left
in jumping right again we check if
player is back on ground and we set it
to standing right
we are running standing sitting and
jumping well done if you followed this
far let's polish this and make it look
even better jumping works this way we
are always adding velocity y to player's
vertical position here on line 31. most
of the time that velocity y is zero so
there is no vertical movement when we
enter jumping state we set velocity y to
minus 40 which will push player upwards
in minus direction on vertical y axis
when that happens player is no longer
standing on the ground so this if
statement triggers and we start
increasing velocity from line 14 by
player weight from line 15. this happens
for every frame step by step so actually
velocity y goes from -40 to zero making
player move up slower and slower when
it's zero player will stop moving at
that point we are still not on the
ground so this line of code keeps
increasing and it moves velocity y from
negative to positive numbers which will
make player reach peak of its jump and
it will start falling back down when we
touch the ground this else statement
triggers velocity y is set back to 0 and
vertical movement will stop
understanding how velocity y goes from
-40 to zero and then into positive
numbers gives us ability to tie player
state change to it i can tell that
player is at its peak of its jump
because its velocity y switched from
negative to positive values i will just
add a quick check here to make sure
player doesn't fall through the floor it
shouldn't happen but this is kind of my
insurance if player y is more than game
height minus player height set player y
to gain height minus player height this
line will make it impossible for a
player to move below ground level under
any circumstances i don't think this
check is needed even when i increase
player weight to 10 we still don't fall
through the floor maybe you can just
comment it out it's up to you
it's just the check to be secure
i created falling states falling left is
8 and fall in right is 9.
i copy one of my state classes and i
turn it into fall and left enter method
we'll just set frame y to five
inside handle input method while in fall
in left if we press right arrow key we
want to turn so we will switch to fall
and right
i also want to keep this check when we
fall all the way to the ground we will
switch player to standing left state
i copy this and turn it into fall and
write class
frame y here will be 4 and when we press
left we set state to fall in left
i import these classes in player.js and
i instantiate them inside player states
array so how do we enter fall in state
as we said when we enter jump velocity y
is set to -40 and we start adding player
weight to it so it goes all the way to 0
and into positive numbers i know at the
point velocity y reached 0 we are at the
peak of jump and as it goes into
positive numbers player is falling back
down
bear with me a second here please
so inside the jumping left state if
velocity y on player object is more than
zero we set player state to fall in left
inside jump in right state if velocity y
is more than 0 we set state the jumping
right so this is one example of how you
can switch states based on other
conditions state changes don't always
have to be triggered by user present
keys on keyboard this works really well
we created standing sitting running
jumping and falling states we are just
drawing the first frame in each sprite
sheet row let's actually animate the
frames horizontally we have frame x
property for horizontal navigation
within our sprite sheet for every
animation frame i check if frame x is
less than max frame and i increase frame
x by 1.
i set frame x back to 0. some rows have
different maximum number of frames but
that's easy to deal with initially i set
max frame to 5 we are counting from 0
you can see that sit in animation has
less frames so it's blinking since we
are animating empty frames we will start
with standing animation so the initial
max frame is 6. every time we enter a
new state we set max frame to a
different value
when we enter standing left we set max
frame to 6.
probably i should be set in max frame
before i set frame 1 because in some
cases if i switch row at first we can
get blinking before the right max frame
is applied
or maybe i could also set frame x to
zero every time we enter a new state i'm
not gonna go deep into this today i made
other episodes about sprite animation
this is just a quick solution
running left and running right we'll set
max frame to 8.
jumping and falling have max frame six
awesome we are correctly animating all
our rows
if you want to make player move faster
you can change max speed property here
on line 20. this value affects
horizontal movement
the sprites are animated very fast maybe
i want to slow them down a bit without
changing fps of the entire game how do i
set fps for how often we switch between
horizontal frames in sprite sheet while
still keeping everything else running at
maximum 60fps as always we can use
timestamps and delta time last time will
be the value of timestamp from the
previous loop animate takes this auto
generated timestamp argument which was
produced and automatically passed to it
by request animation frame from line 23
delta time is the number of milliseconds
that passed between the last animation
loop and this animation loop it's the
difference between timestamps from each
loop so delta time equals the timestamp
from this loop minus timestamp from the
previous loop when we have that
calculation i set last time to the
current timestamp so that it can be used
for the next loop i also have to pass
animate the initial timestamp just for
the first loop because request animation
frame also generates it from the second
loop onwards so now we have delta time
we know how many milliseconds it takes
for our computer to serve the next
animation frame it depends on power of
our machine how much animation and
calculations our game is doing per each
frame as well as on refresh rate of
screen we are using this number can be
different for every computer but we can
use it to unify how our game runs across
different machines today i will use it
to control how often we serve the next
horizontal frame in doc's sprite sheet i
pass delta time to player draw method
here and in player js i make sure draw
method expects that argument
damning things with delta time needs
three helper variables
one variable to set fps frames per
second one timer variable that will
accumulate delta time until it reaches a
certain value
and one variable that defines that value
we want to reach i call that value frame
interval and it will be thousand
milliseconds divided by frames per
second which will give me number of
milliseconds i want each frame to be
displayed on the screen before we switch
to the next one so if frame timer from
line 22 is more than frame interval from
line 23 only then switch frame x
variable
at the same time set frame timer back to
0 so that it can count again
else just increase frame timer by delta
time and wait until it accumulates
enough milliseconds
it's not working
i see here in animation loop i need to
correctly assign last time to the new
timestamp value after we used it to
calculate delta time so that it can be
used to calculate delta time in the next
loop if i change fps it affects how fast
we serve horizontal sprites while still
allowing player to move around at
maximum 60 frames per second or whatever
your request animation frame can handle
on your computer if i give it fps that's
higher than my screen's refresh rate
request animation frame will
automatically copy it so it won't
animate faster past a certain value that
maximum value of frames per second is
limited by your screen's refresh rate
making games with javascript is one of
my favorite ways to practice coding
today we will build a 2d game and we
will animate everything to bring it to
life i want to show you how to make
keyboard controls feel quick and
responsive we will apply animated sprite
sheets and parallax backgrounds we will
learn how to give our game different
skins we will explore a new technique to
make particle effects and we will
challenge our players by giving
different enemy types different
behaviors on my community page i asked
you to choose between three super powers
and you chose the fireball tackle so let
me show you how to turn into a flaming
ball of plasma and vaporize enemies to
earn points come join me and learn how
to create your own 2d adventures with
html css and plain vanilla javascript no
frameworks and no libraries click like
if you want more games
[Music]
to keep the code organized and easy to
navigate in i will split javascript into
multiple files so called modules and i
will export and import them around the
code base as needed to enable this
functionality we have to run our code in
some kind of dev environment they need
to be run through some kind of server
you might already have a preferred way
to run a local server you can go ahead
and do that for the rest of us the
easiest way to create a simple local
server is to use vs code editor which
has a built-in one when you open your vs
code check if you have this notification
area down here that says go live if you
can't see it you can just come here to
extensions and search for live server
it's this one mine is already installed
you can just click install here when you
install it close your vs code and reopen
it and you will see go live down here
one last thing to do we have to point vs
code to the correct folder with the
files we want to run through this live
server we do it by going to file open
folder and in there you navigate to the
folder you will work with today on your
local computer and click open now when i
create new files they will be
automatically created in that folder so
i create index html style css and main
js
in index html i create a basic blank web
page markup in vs code you can just
press exclamation mark and tab key and
it will create it for you let's give it
some title and link style css file like
this
i create a canvas element with an id of
canvas one
down here i link my javascript using a
script doc i give it type attribute and
set it to module to specify that this
file will be a javascript module it will
be my top level module and we will be
importing other javascript modules
inside i click this go live button and
the live server plugin will
automatically open my default browser
and it will run our project in it it
will also automatically reload the
browser window whenever we save any of
the project files you don't have to use
vs code and live server plugin if you
know how to create your own local server
in a different way feel free to do that
so now i can see my live server is
running on port 5501 it will reload
browser window whenever i save any
project file i usually use control plus
s keyboard shortcut to save sometimes
you have to manually reload the browser
page for the first time and then it will
start doing it automatically in style
css i reset margin and padding to 0 on
all elements and i set a box size into
border books this is so called a global
reset and we do it to make sure our page
looks the same across different browsers
canvas 1 will have border 5 pixels solid
black and i center it in the middle of
the page so the usual four lines of css
position absolute top fifty percent left
fifty percent transform translate minus
fifty percent minus fifty percent i will
provide you with game art assets you can
use to code along with me and at the end
in the experiment sections i will show
you how to apply different skins to your
game so that you can make it unique
based on your own creative preferences
check out this website for more
beautiful art assets that are already
compatible with today's project today we
will be using images for player
backgrounds enemies and other things the
easiest way to make sure our code runs
only after all art assets are loaded is
by placing the images inside index.html
which we will do in a minute and we will
put all javascript inside a callback
function on event listener for window
load event that way javascript waits for
all dependent resources such as
stylesheets and images to be fully
loaded and available before it runs when
the page is fully loaded we will point
javascript towards our canvas element
using its id i create an instance of
built-in 2d drawing api using getcontext
method and i save it as ctx shortcut for
context canvas width will be for example
500 pixels and height 500 pixels as well
you can make your project wider but keep
the height at 500 pixels for now because
i optimized the background images for
that size we can make canvas scale up
and down to make sure it's always fully
visible if i set width to 1500 pixels we
can only see the middle it's cut off on
left and right i can give it max width
100 percent and it will make it scale
down until it's fully visible whenever
the width of the page is less than the
width of the canvas element i can also
give it max height 100 in case that the
restricting factor is page height now we
can always see the entire canvas
regardless of its width and height i set
it back to 500 500 for now
the main brain of our project will be
this game class all logic in our project
will somehow go through it it will
expect width and height as arguments and
inside we convert these to class
properties like this it will have update
method that will run for every animation
frame and trigger all calculations that
need to happen and draw method will draw
our images score and so on right now we
don't have anything to update or draw
yet
i create a new javascript file called
player.js if you are a beginner it will
be easier for you if you follow my code
exactly and use the sprites and images i
provide you and only once you have a
working project then you can modify it
and add your own art assets and game
features if that's what you want to do
inside player.js i create a class called
player its job will be to draw and
update our superdog character
constructor will take the entire game
object as an argument through it we will
have access to some things we will need
such as width and height of the game
area and so on javascript objects are so
called reference data types which means
when i pass the entire game object to
other classes like this i'm not creating
a copy of the game object i'm just
pointing to it so now it's time to bring
player image to the project it was
provided by this talented artist and you
can download it for free in the video
description and use it for learning
purposes to follow along with this class
check out their website for more game
art assets if you want to make your
projects unique so we have some images
and sometimes it can take a while maybe
even a couple of seconds for the images
and audio files to load in javascript if
you try to use an image that hasn't yet
been fully loaded you will get an error
we need to make sure our images are
loaded and available before we draw them
one way to do that and the simplest way
to do that is to actually include those
images on our web page i simply create
an image element
and as a source i point it towards the
image file i have a folder called assets
in the same place where my index.html
file is and in there the image i want is
called playerpng i give it id player
like this
i will draw that image on canvas with
javascript so i don't really want to
display it on the web page like this
install css i target it using its id and
i set its display to none it's a good
practice to make your images the exact
size you will use in your projects we
can scale it down with javascript but
for maximum performance it's better to
size your images in photoshop or some
other graphics editor i already did that
with the images i gave you today and i
sized each frame to the same size we
will display in game the width of each
single frame in the sprite sheet will be
100 pixels and height will be 91.3
pixels if you are using your own sprite
sheets you can get the width of a single
frame by taking the width of the entire
sprite sheet and dividing it by the
number of horizontal frames and height
is the height of the entire sprite sheet
divided by the number of vertical frames
the number of rows player will also need
to be positioned somewhere on canvas so
it will need x and y position it will
have update method that will move it
around based on user input and it will
cycle through the sprite frames and the
draw method will take those values and
it will draw currently active frame and
the current coordinates
it will need context as an argument to
specify which canvas element we want to
draw on let's start by calling fill
rectangle first and we draw it at
coordinates this dot x this.y and we
also specify its width and height if i
want to use this javascript class in a
different module in a different file i
need to export it i can just say export
like this each file can have unlimited
amount of exports or i can say export
default each file each module can have
only one default export in main.js i
import playerclass by going up top and
saying import player in brackets like
this from dot forward slash player.js in
quotes class constructor on javascript
class is a special type of method it
gets automatically executed when we call
this class using the new keyword it will
create one new instance of this class
and as a side effect all the code inside
the constructor will run we can take
advantage of that by putting in any code
we want to run at that point when i
create an instance of game class i also
want to automatically create an instance
of player class since i'm importing
player class on line 1 i can instantiate
it here this dot player property on game
class will be new player like this
inside player js on line 2 i can see
that player class expects game as an
argument
so here since we are inside that game
class i will pass it this inside game
class this keyword means this game
object
now that we have access to the player
object from within a game class here
inside draw method i can take this dot
player from line 13 and i call its draw
method we declare that draw method here
on line 12 inside player js and i can
see it expects context as an argument my
main public method will be this draw on
game class it will get context pass from
the outside in a minute and we will just
pass that reference along to player draw
like this
our game class is complete let's create
an instance of it i need to pass it
width and height so i pass it canvas
width from line 6 and canvas height from
line 7.
so now we created an instance of game
class which triggered class constructor
and that automatically triggers class
constructor on imported player class and
also creates our player make sure you
save changes to both player js and main
js file every time you make any change
if you have any unsaved changes in
player js at this point you will not get
the same result as me i console log a
game and i can see it has height
width and it contains player object as
we defined in the constructor perfect
we will also need animation loop because
i want the game to update and draw over
and over 60 times per second i create a
custom function i call for example
animate inside i call game.draw from
line 18 and as context i pass it ctx
from line 5.
then i call request animation frame and
i pass it animate to create animation
loop when i call it we are drawing this
black rectangle representing player
object nice this code inside draw method
on player class will determine what the
player looks like i can make it red for
example
i can move it around by changing its
coordinates if i want to align the
player on the bottom of the game area
player object needs to be aware of game
height i have width and height of the
game area here as properties on game
object and i'm passing a reference to
the entire game object to the player
here inside player js i convert that
reference to a class property called
this.game and i can extract width and
height of the game from that so to
position the player on the bottom of
game area i set its vertical y
coordinate to this.game.height minus
distort height height of the player i
don't really want the player to look as
a red rectangle we have a special sprite
sheet with our superdog to use here we
are about to learn how to use built-in
draw image method to animate a game
character from a sprite sheet if you
want to go deeper on sprite animation
the very first episode in the series
linked below will explain it in a
beginner-friendly way this is an
advanced video if you feel it's too
challenging for you at some point don't
worry it will make more sense if you
keep going and you can always watch a
special episode describing each
technique on a simpler project so draw
image is a special html canvas method we
can use to draw and even to animate an
image it's simple i have my player
sprite sheet here in html and i gave it
an id of player i create a property on
player class called this.image and i
point it towards that image element
using getelementbyid
now i can draw that image draw image
method needs at least three arguments
image we want to draw and x and y where
to draw it
by the way i'm not sure if you know but
i don't really have to use get element
by id here i give my image id of player
here and javascript automatically
creates references to all elements with
ids into the global namespace using its
id as a variable name so i can simply
just use that id as a variable name here
and it will still work
it's a bit strange and for some reason
nobody uses this feature but it will
work
i will go back to getelementbyid here
even though it's kinda redundant
draw image method can also accept
optional fourth and fifth argument for
width and height and it will shrink or
stretch the image to occupy these
dimensions now it's just squeezing the
entire sprite sheet into the small space
the longest version of draw image method
takes nine arguments and that's the
version we need we pass it image we want
to draw source x source y source width
and source height of the rectangle we
want to crop out from the source image
in our case a single frame of the sprite
sheet and destination x destination y
destination width and destination height
will define where on destination canvas
we want to draw that cropped out
rectangle onto at first i just want to
crop out the top left frame in my sprite
sheet so i crop from coordinates 0 0 and
the area will have a width of 100 pixels
and height of 91.3 pixels i'm cropping
out exactly one frame i don't need the
red rectangle anymore we are redrawing
the same image over and over 60 times
per second but it looks static let's
check if we are actually animated by
putting some code inside playerupdate
method for every animation frame i want
to increase player's horizontal x
coordinate by 1 pixel to actually run
the code i need to go to update method
on game class and i take this.player
from line 13 and i call update on it
like this finally i call game.update
from inside animation loop and we have
some emotion congratulations you are
javascript animation master
okay we can do a bit more with this if
you want
the dog is leaving a black trail behind
that's old paint we can just see all the
previous frames if you want to see only
the current animation frame we need to
clear canvas each time we update and
draw i call built in clear rectangle
method and i want to clear the entire
canvas from coordinates 0 0 to canvas
with canvas height now we can just see
the current animation frame
i don't really want the player to move
like this let's comment this out i want
the player to move left and right jump
and to use super powers based on
keyboard inputs i create a new
javascript file a new module i call it
input js its job will be to capture and
keep track of user input again i will
create a javascript class here i will
call it for example input handler inside
its constructor i create a property
called this dot keys and i set it to an
empty array at first i will be adding
keys that are pressed down into this
array and removing the keys that are
being released
that way we can always check if a
specific key is pressed by chicken if
it's included in this array as we said
before the code inside a class
constructor is executed automatically
whenever we create an instance of this
class so i will take advantage of that
and i will apply key down event listener
from here
event listeners return an auto-generated
event object which contains all kinds of
information about the event that just
occurred
the property that holds the name of the
key that was pressed is called key so
let's console.log e dot key
i export input handler up here
inside main.js i import my new input
handler class same as i did with player
i will create an instance of input
handler class inside gamer class
constructor i will call this property
this dot input
this way input handler class gets
automatically instantiated when i create
an instance of game class it will create
this dot keys array from line 3 and it
will also automatically apply this key
down event listener
now when i press keys on my keyboard i
can see their values
i don't want to react to every key we
will ignore some and we will only
respond to specific controls defined
here we will also make sure each key can
be added to this dot key's array only
once so when the user holds down a
specific key it will not be added 20
times it will just be added once let me
show you i say if e.k meaning the key
that was just press has key value of
arrow down and at the same time this key
that was pressed is not yet included in
this dot keys array so this dot keys
index of e.k is equal to -1 you can also
say is more than -1 in javascript when
element has index -1 it means it's not
present in the array then i just do
this.keys push e dot key so if the key
that was pressed is arrow down and if
arrow down is not yet inside this dot
keys array push arrow down into this dot
keys array i can console lock key that
was pressed and this dot keys array you
can see it will stay empty until i press
arrow down if i press it it will be
added to this.keys array once i will
also create an eventlistener for keyup
event if e dot key is arrowdown meaning
if the key that was released is arrow
down i will use splice method to remove
it from this dot keys array splice
method takes at least two arguments
index of the element we want to remove
and how many elements to remove at that
index
let's test it
actually to test it properly i want the
console log after the if statement now
when i press arrow down it gets added to
this dot keys array through the code
inside keydown event when i release it
keyup event removes it from the array
perfect
i also want to listen for arrow up key
so i use or operator
be careful about brackets here i have to
wrap this block in brackets like this
if key that was pressed is arrow down or
arrow up in brackets and at the same
time the key is not yet present in this
dot keys array only then push it inside
i also need to make sure i remove that
arrow up key on keyup event again pay
attention to how i use brackets here
it's easy to make a mistake here and
break your code
we will also listen for arrow left so or
operator e dot key is arrow left and
another or operator and i check for
arrow right
i will check for one more key for now i
will use it for a special move and
attack and you can use alt ctrl but be
careful mac and windows call alt and
control keys differently they might have
a different value console e.k and press
them on your machine to check for that
value in this case i will use enter key
which should be more universal and
compatible with both mac and windows
systems let's add all these keys to key
up event as well and i have to make sure
my syntax is correct now it should work
i click my canvas to select it and when
i start pressing arrows and enter i can
see they are correctly being added and
removed from the array
you can see we are also keeping track of
multiple key presses at the same time
great
so now this dot key's property on input
handler class always contains all
currently active keys
i have an instance of that class here
saved as this dot input for every
animation frame i want to pass the
current list of active inputs to
playerupdate method as an argument so
that it can react to it i will pass it
this.input.keys
inside player.js i make sure the player
expects that input value i will call it
for example input it still refers to
this.keys array we have on our input
handler class
inside update method on playerclass i
want to check if it includes specific
values i use built-in array includes
method i could also use index off method
here it would work the same if input
includes arrow write increase horizontal
x-coordinate of the player by 1.
else if it includes arrow left decrease
x by one making the player move left on
the negative direction on horizontal
x-axis
i actually need to say this.x to
correctly refer to the property from
line six
the error i'm getting now is because i
didn't save my changes to input js or
main.js files with file structure like
this when we're using modules we always
have to make sure we save every file
whenever we make any changes to it
now when i press right arrow player
moves right
when i press the left arrow key the
player moves left
let's refactor this i give player a
speed property and initially i set it to
0. i also give it max speed property
which will be its speed in pixels per
frame when it's moving so this section
of code will handle horizontal movement
for every frame i will increase player's
horizontal x position by its current
speed
so right now the speed is zero so the
player is not moving
down here i say if input includes arrow
right set this dot speed to mark speed
if it's arrow left set speed to minus
max speed now i can move left and right
again but i can't really stop there is
no condition when the speed returns back
to zero i can fix it by saying else
this.speed is zero meaning if input
array doesn't include arrow right or
arrow left stop the horizontal movement
i also don't want the player to be able
to move outside of the game area so i
need to introduce some boundaries i say
if this dot x is less than zero set this
dot x to zero
now i can't move past the left edge i
also say if this dot x is more than this
that game width minus the width of the
player set x to game with minus player
with now i can't move past the right
edge of game area as well perfect
it's time to handle vertical movement
which will include the jump in and also
a special dive move where we crush
enemies from above i create a new class
property called this dot v y velocity y
basically a vertical speed initially i
set it to 0.
for every animation frame we will add
the current vertical velocity
v y to player's vertical y position
currently v y is set to zero so there
will be no vertical movement at first
i will have to check in multiple places
in my code whether the player is
standing on solid ground or if it's
currently in the air to make our code
more readable and to avoid code
repetition i will put that check into a
small utility method i will call it for
example on the ground and i just want it
to return true if the player is on
ground or false if the player is in the
air i do that simply by say in return
this dot y is more or equal to height of
the game minus the height of the player
let's start by saying if input includes
arrow up set this.velocity y from line 8
to -20 i press up arrow key and the
player just flies up off-screen okay
that worked
i only want the player to be able to
jump while it's standing on ground i
don't want it to jump higher and higher
in the air when we are pressing up arrow
repeatedly
i add one more check here to see if on
ground from line 28 is true
i set velocity y to -2 nice
if you want a nice jumping curve in a 2d
game we usually do it by making the
power of the jump in our case v-y
property work against the gravity or
weight of the object and while that
object is in the air we keep increasing
its weight until it eventually is higher
than its jump power and it will make it
slow down and start falling down let me
show you exactly what i mean this used
to be a bit confusing for me but it
becomes easy when you use it a few times
i create a new property called this.wait
for example and i set it to one so we
have velocity y property on line 8 and
when we press up arrow key we set it to
-10 this will be the power pulling the
player upwards at the same time i want
the weight of the player from line 9 to
be pulling it down and i want that pull
to be stronger the longer the player is
in the air to get that smooth curve when
we jump i do that by saying whenever
this dot on ground is false whenever the
player is not standing on the ground
increase its velocity y by this.weight
nice we kinda jumped
i also need to make sure that when the
player lands back on the ground velocity
y is reset back to zero to stop all
vertical movement i say else this dot
velocity y is a zero for this to
actually work as intended i need to
first run this line of code and then
this one
and we are jumping velocity y is
constantly being added to player's
vertical y position at first it's zero
so nothing is happening when i press up
arrow key i give it a push in the
negative direction on the vertical y
axis so upwards at that point the player
is currently not on the ground so this
line of code will start running and
velocity y which is currently set to -20
and which is moving the player 20 pixels
up per animation frame will start
decreasing by this dot weight from line
9 so minus twenty plus one is minus
nineteen minus eighteen minus seventeen
all the way to zero
when we reach velocity y of zero player
is at the peak of its jump but it's
still not on the ground so this line is
still adding weight to velocity y making
the player fall down faster and faster
when the player hits the ground this
else statement will set velocity y back
to zero and the jump is finished the
ratio between weight and this minus
value will determine the curve height
and speed of the jump i will keep weight
at 1 and i will adjust velocity y to
make the player jump all the way to the
top of the game area we have run in and
jump in i would like to add more player
states and properly animate them we need
a fireball attack and when the player
sits down i want the game to stop
scrolling how do we organize and manage
this functionality by structuring our
javascript code in so-called state
design pattern i will show you exactly
how to do that in the next part we are
building a fast-paced animated side
scroll game with vanilla javascript and
html canvas in the first episode we
created the main game logic animation
loop and the player let's continue
building our game in this class we will
apply state design pattern to our player
to make it switch between the states
properly we will learn how to control
fps how to animate sprite sheets and how
to implement multi-layered seamless
backgrounds with scrolling speed that
reacts to player movement part 1 is
linked in the video description let's go
i like writing my code like this for
small simple games as you can see there
are quite a lot of if else statements in
here already i want to add some special
moves this single code block already
does so many things and we have just run
in and jumping if we keep adding more
and more in here we can get to the stage
where changing one line of code can
break something else unexpectedly for
small games it's fine to have all logic
in one place like this but for this game
we will go ahead and structure our code
a little bit better i will manage player
states separately in its own file i call
it player states js at first i will
create a simple enum object that will
pair values and names of each state it
will help with code readability rather
than swap into state 2 i will swap the
state.jumping which has a value of 2
behind it it will be easier to see what
our code is doing this episode might be
a bit challenging for beginners we will
be passing values around between
javascript modules and classes and i can
imagine if you are a beginner it might
take some effort to keep track of which
values are coming from where i will
guide you through all the steps and we
will make our code easy to navigate in
but this is the finale of my vanilla
javascript 2d game development series so
i expect you either already watched my
beginner-friendly episode on state
management linked in the description or
that you have already done some
javascript coding before i will explain
everything today no previous knowledge
is needed but it will be easier if you
watch the beginner class first it's up
to you today's tutorial is mainly to
show you how i put everything together
to make a polished animated game that
feels good to play check the video
description for the full series i create
a class i call for example state each
state will have its own class so that i
can give each state a different entry
method to set the player up when it
enters that particular state
and handle method that will react to
different user inputs depending on which
state the player is in at that moment in
time for example when the player is in
the running state and i press arrow down
i want to switch to sitting state but
when the player is in jumping state and
i press arrow down i don't want the
player to sit in the air i wanted to do
a crushing dive attack from above state
design pattern is perfect for changing
how the object behaves depending on its
current state i will show you exactly
what i mean as we write the code
constructor will take a single argument
called for example state it will be a
simple line of text with the name of the
state such as sit in run-in jump jumping
and so on inside i converted that
argument to a class property i will use
this value only so that i can console
the name of the currently active state
for debugging purposes it's not
important for the logic of state
swapping we will have one class for each
state the first state will be sitting
which will also be special because it
will stop the game from scrolling as the
player sits down we will export it so
export class sit-in constructor will
take a reference to the player object as
an argument so that it can access
properties on the player class i am
extending a class and i want the code
from this constructor on the parent to
run as well so i have to call super
keyword here the trigger constructor of
its parent class also known as a super
class we can see that the parent class
constructor expects a value for state
this is simply for monitoring purposes i
will pass it word sitting and it will
get converted to this dot state property
here only after we called super we can
use this keyword here in a child class
if we use this keyword before using
super we will get an error super on
child class always needs to be called
before this keyword is used each class
will have enter method that will run
once when this state is entered and
handle input method that will take input
as an argument and it will keep checking
if the correct key is pressed and it
will switch player to a different state
when that happens for example it will
switch to jumping state when we press up
arrow key in player js we will need
three helper properties to apply state
design pattern let's just write them and
i will explain in a minute we will need
a property called this dot this.states
which is an array of values we will also
need this.currentstate which will point
to indexes in this array
when the player object is initialized
for the first time we will call its
entry method to activate its initial
default state
i'm exporting my sit-in class here let's
import it up here in player.js i import
the entire sitting class from
playerstate.js
quick overview of how we will apply
steady design pattern into our code base
today player object will have this dot
states property which will be an array
containing individual states such as
sitting running and so on the player can
only be in one state at a time so we
will have another property here called
this dot current state
when this.current state is equal to this
dot states index 0 player is sitting
when it's this dot states index 1 the
player is in the running state and so on
the final piece of logic will be that
each player's state is actually its own
class we will have a class for sit-in
another class for run-in there will be a
separate class for every state the
reason for that is that each state needs
to have its own separate enter method
that will set speed animation row and
everything else that needs to be done
whenever the player enters a new state
each state class will also have handle
update method which will listen for
keyboard inputs and it will be ready to
switch the player to a different state
whenever the correct key is pressed
because all state classes have their own
enter and handle input method and
because this dot current state points to
different states as the player switches
from one state to another we can just
keep calling
this.currentstate.handleinput
and we will get different behaviors
depending on the current state the
player is in at that point in time and
this is the entire logic behind state
design pattern if it's still not clear
don't worry i will go over it today step
by step as we write the code it will
make more sense if you practice and code
with me inside this.states array i will
instantiate each state class right now
i'm creating an instance of sit in class
here on line 14 in playerstates.js i can
see that it expects a reference to the
entire player object as an argument
because here we are inside playerclass i
pass it this keyword which references
this entire player class
when we enter sit in state i want to
draw a different animation row in player
sprite sheet let's set up sprite
animation
we will have frame x horizontal frame
that will cycle from left to right
animating the player and we will have
frame y which will travel in the sprite
sheet vertically whenever we switch to a
different state you can see that frame y
0 is standing frame y 1 is jumping and
so on changing the values of frame x and
frame y will jump by the width and
height of a single frame so that we can
animate the sprite sheet in draw method
i replace hardcoded coordinates 0 0
which are currently displaying this top
left frame to dynamic values source x
value will be this dot frame x times the
width of the player frame
source y will be dot frame y times the
height of the player frame
i'm getting a console error it's because
i forgot a forward slash here on line
one in player js
now it's fixed
so now frame x cycles horizontally frame
y travels around the sprite sheet
vertically i can see that the setting
animation is frame y5
when we enter sitting state i take this
dot player from line 16 which points
towards the player object and i set its
frame y property to 5. i could have
defined getters and setters on the
player object to do this by the book but
i don't think it's necessary for our
purposes today this code will work well
back in player.js i set the initial
frame y to 0 which is this standing
animation now i need a method that will
allow us to switch player between the
states
i define it down here on the player
class i will call it for example set
state it will take this new state we are
about to switch to as an argument it
will be a number corresponding to
indexes in this dot states array from
line 17. inside i set this.current state
from line 19 to one of the states from
line 17 depending on which index i
passed to it right now we only have one
element in the array the sitting state
that's index 0. if we have more state
classes in the array on line 17 i will
be able to swap to index 1 2 and so on
to switch player to those states keep in
mind set state will take one argument
called state which will be a number
corresponding to the index in this dot
states array
then we call enter method on the
currently active state to set up things
like speed sprite animation and so on
there's also handle input method we
defined here enter method will run once
every time we enter that state handle
input method will be running 60 times
per second waiting for keys to be
pressed so it can switch the player into
a different state when the user requests
it by pressing the right set of keys in
our case mostly arrows so far
i will be calling it from inside update
method on player class here so this dot
current state dot handle input and pass
an input value as an argument to the
update method here
the value of input is coming from update
method on game class pointing to keys
array on an instance of input handler
class from line 15. this way
playerupdate method can always see what
keys are being pressed in our game by
checking if they are present in this
input keys array we defined it before
here on line 3 in input js if you
remember
we pass it through game class to update
method on player class
and i will just pass that argument along
to handle input method like this
this code will be run in 60 times per
second constantly checking what keys are
present in input keys array handle input
expects keys array here as an argument
i called it input and we will be
checking and waiting for specific keys
to be pressed the main function of state
design pattern is that we are basically
locking player object in one state at a
time and while the player is in a
certain state it will only react to a
limited number of keyboard inputs while
the player is in the sitting state we
will react to arrow left and arrow right
keys and when they are pressed we will
switch into running state
so i say if this input value that was
passed as an argument which points to
this dot keys array on input handler
class if that array includes arrow left
key or if it includes arrow right key
call set state method on player object
here we can see that setstate method
expects state as an argument and it will
set the current state of the player to
that index in this dot states array from
line 17.
right now that array has only one
element so it will only work when i pass
it index 0 as a value of this state
argument here
it will then call enter method on that
new state we just switched to
back to player states js
so now we know that we have to pass this
set state method a number that will be
used as an index in player states array
to correctly switch it into that state i
can pass it number 0 here but we have
this enum object here to convert numbers
to words like sitting and running to
make our code more readable
the order of states in this enum must be
exactly the same as the order of states
in this dot states array on line 17
inside the player class index 0 is
sitting state because it's the first
element in the array this enum also
needs to have the value of 0 paired with
sitting which it does now i can call set
state
and instead of passing a number 1 which
would also work but it would be less
readable i pass it states from line 1
dot run in which has a value of 1 behind
it as well
i hope it's a bit more clear this is the
most complicated part and we just
covered it just keep coding with me and
it will start making more sense right
now there is no index one in this array
yet we need to create running class to
add it
i copy this code block and i rename it
to run in
and i also put a run in here i check the
sprite sheet and i can see the fourth
row in the sprite sheet is run in so i
set frame y to three because we count
from zero
in handle input on running class we will
listen for arrow down and when it's
pressed we switch player to the setting
state
we are exporting running class here i
import it up here in player.js
and i instantiate it as an element with
an index of 1 inside this dot states
array
nice so now when we are in the sit in
state and we press left or right key we
switch into the running state when we
are in running state we listen for arrow
down key and when it's pressed we switch
back to the seating state
perfect we have all the logic for
swapping states in place let's add a
jumping state again i copy this code
block i rename it to jump in
and i put a jump in here
i comment outline 31 inside player js
that we used for jumping before let's
refactor it
when we enter jumping state we set frame
y to 1.
if the player is on ground that method
comes from line 39 in player js
we set velocity y on the player to -30
pushing it upwards
as we discussed in part 1 during a jump
velocity y goes from -30 to 0 moving the
player upwards and then as it moves into
positive numbers the player will start
falling down we have a nice falling
animation row in our sprite sheet so
let's switch the player into falling
state when it reaches the peak of its
jump instead of listening for key
presses we can also check for values of
properties on the player
when velocity y switches to the positive
values and is more than player weight
more than one we know the player is
falling down at that point so we set
state the states dot falling that will
point up here so i add fallen in our
enum and i give it a value of 3.
we have our new jump in state but there
is currently no way to enter jumping in
our game we can enter it from running
state for example when the player is in
the running state we already listen for
down arrow key we will also be checking
for up arrow like this if input includes
arrow up while the player is running set
state to jump in so value two
now i copy jump in state
and i rename it to fall in
i give it a text value of fallen in here
while we are falling we won't be
listening for any keys
we will just wait for the player to be
back on the ground
and then we set state to run in
we are exporting jumping class on line
46 and falling class on line 62. i
import them up here inside player.js
then i instantiate both of these classes
inside this.states array the order in
which you do that is important and it
needs to be the same as states enum we
have on line 1 inside player states js
those indexes have to match you can see
i'm importing jump in as index 2 in this
dot states array falling is index 3
and here inside enum object jump in has
also the value of 2 and falling has a
value of 3. it needs the match
while we are inside the sitting state we
can press arrow left and arrow right and
it will switch player into running state
while we are inside run in state we can
press arrow down to sit or arrow up to
jump to keep things simple i can also
check for arrow left and arrow right
here inside update method because i want
the player to be able to move left and
right in basically all states when the
arrows are pressed the controls feel
better that way that means we can move
left and right in the air even while we
are jumping or falling or rolling
when i'm in the running state if i press
up arrow key we jump and when we reach
the peak of the jump we get
automatically swapped into a falling
state
when we hit the ground we automatically
switch into running state great
i adjust this minus velocity y value to
change the height of the jump
well done if you follow the code all the
way here now you know how to apply state
design pattern which is quite an
advanced technique especially if you are
a beginner we will add more states to it
soon but before we do that let's
properly animate the sprite sheet of our
dock i want it to animate and move
i delete this line of code
we will handle sprite animation in this
area inside update method on player
class
we have frame x property which holds the
index of horizontal frame we have frame
y which refers to the vertical position
in the sprite sheet you can see that
different rows have different number of
frames i want to rotate between frame 0
and max frame on that row depending on
which row we currently are on sitting
state and running state have different
number of frames we will hold that value
in this dot max frame property and we
will adjust its value every time we swap
states since we have our code nicely
organized in state design pattern it's
easy to do that and to keep track of
each state separately let me show you so
to animate each row we will always cycle
between frame 0 and max frame on that
row
if frame x is less than max frame
increase frame x by 1.
else reset frame x back to 0.
it's going too fast and it's blinking
for sit in state because we are
including empty frames it's animating so
fast because this particular sprite
sheet was designed for lower frame rates
it really depends on which art assets
you are using but it's also easy to
control fps of sprite animation
independently of the fps of the entire
game i can for example have the docs
spreadsheet animate at 10 frames per
second while the entire game is still
updating at 60fps you can do it by
checking animation timestamps and
calculating delta time it's easy let me
show you i will explain it right now
we will need a helper variable here last
time we'll hold the value of the
timestamp from the previous animation
loop request animation frame method has
two special features first it
automatically adjusts the screen refresh
rate so most of us will get 60 animation
frames per second unless you have some
game in high refresh screen request
animation frame also auto generates a
timestamp value and it automatically
passes it as an argument to the function
it calls in our case animate i can
assign it a variable name here i will
call it timestamp for example
so this timestamp is also generated by
request animation frame every time it
serves a new animation frame every time
it loops i will use it to calculate so
called delta time
delta time is the difference in
milliseconds between the timestamp from
this animation loop that was passed here
and the timestamp from the previous loop
it will give us the value of
milliseconds for how long each frame
stays on the screen before it gets
redrawn
last time we'll always hold the value of
the timestamp from the previous loop so
when we used it to calculate delta time
we override the last time with the value
of timestamp from this loop so that it
can be used to calculate delta time in
the next loop
this might be a bit complicated to
understand at first but don't worry it
will make more sense as you use it more
often for this to work timestamp gets
auto-generated only when it's called by
request animation frame so for the very
first initial call of animate i have to
pass it some value for timestamp i will
pass it zero
i console delta time and i can see that
it's around 16.6 milliseconds which is
around 1000 milliseconds divided by 60.
my frame rate is 60 frames per second
perfect yours should be similar the
value of delta time calculated this way
depends on the power of your computer
and on the refresh rate of your screen
so as the animation loop runs we are
recalculating delta time over and over
every time we calculate it we pass it
the game update method
up here on line 17 i make sure update
method expects that argument
i want the delta time value to be used
inside player class so i pass it along
to playerupdate method as the second
argument here inside player.js we make
sure that it's expected
so now the player class has access to
delta time value we know how many
milliseconds it takes to serve the next
frame we can use that value to adjust
sprite animation speed for example we
can say only serve the next horizontal
frame in the sprite sheet every 50
milliseconds or something like that we
can get complete control over that frame
rate it's simple let me show you how
this particular dock sprite sheet works
the best when it's been animated at 20
frames per second i will need a number
of milliseconds for how long each frame
should stay on the screen if the frame
rate is 20 frames per second one frame
should stay for a thousand milliseconds
divided by this dot fps divided by 20.
frame timer will cycle between zero and
frame interval increasing by delta time
for each frame every time it reaches the
interval it will trigger the next frame
and it will reset we will handle that
logic here
if this frame timer which starts at 0 is
more than frame interval
set frame timer back to 0 so it can
count again
when that happens also serve the next
frame x horizontal frame in the sprite
sheet
else keep increasing frame timer by
delta time until we reach that frame
interval value
perfect now you know how to control fps
in the game the sprite sheet of our dock
is animating at 20 frames per second you
can see it's blinking it's because we
are animating this empty frame here for
sitting animation max frame isn't 5 so i
remove this value when we enter sit in
state we set max frame on player class
to 4 we count from 0.
when max frame is 4 we are not seeing
the whole running animation so i set max
frame inside running state to 6.
i will also swap max frame and frame y
to prevent occasional blinking if we
swap states too fast
in jumping max frame is 6 and falling is
also 6.
now we are correctly animating each
state do you see how it's easier to keep
the code organized when we separated
each state into its own class
occasionally we can get a situation
where we swap state and frame x is
currently too high and that row doesn't
have that many frames so we get a quick
blink to prevent that from happening
every time we enter a new state we set
frame x back to 0 before we swap to a
different vertical sprite row with frame
y
it's just a small thing
we have complete control of fps how fast
we serve frames in player sprite sheet
i can come here and set it to 5. the
great thing is that the player still
moves at 60 frames per second but the
sprites are animating at 5 frames per
second
we can control these two things
separately
it would be very bad if controls reacted
so slowly but maybe you have a sprite
sheet in your game that was designed for
lower fps our sprite sheets were
designed for speed around 20 fps
depending on what art assets you are
using for your game level you might not
want the player to be standing all the
way at the bottom of the game area
sometimes you need to adjust this value
today i will give you all art assets to
use so i know we will need to create
some margin on the bottom that margin
will have to be considered in more than
one place around the code base so let's
put it in the main game class so it's
easy to access i want the ground level
to be 50 pixels from the bottom edge of
canvas this dot ground margin is 50.
inside player gs we have access to it
through this dot game reference so the
initial vertical coordinate will be
height of the game minus the height of
the player minus ground margin like this
this will not work because here i am
creating player before i declare that
class property i need to put it up here
so it's available at the point when the
player is created that worked i also
need to adjust this on ground check
because being on ground now also
involves this ground margin
perfect you can adjust ground margin
value to match the environment in which
your character is currently moving in
our environment will be an abandoned
monochrome city you can download all art
assets in the video description if you
are a beginner i suggest you use my art
assigns first and get the game to work
before you start adjusting it to your
own version it will save you a lot of
headache if you encounter some
unexpected challenges because you can
just look at my code to fix it
we will be animating a parallax
multi-layered background i made a
special episode about this if you want
to go more in depth at a
beginner-friendly pace we build a small
standalone project in there showing all
the concepts and alternative approaches
let's use the quickest version here
so we have a new file i called
background.js i will need two classes
here helper layer class that will handle
logic for each state separately and main
wrapper class i will call for example
background that will be exported and
animated from the main game class it's
actually quite simple let me show you
layer class will need access to the game
object because we need to be constantly
aware of width and height of the
available game area we will also need
the width and height of the actual
background image
we will need speed modifier argument
because each layer will move at a
different speed but relative to the
current game speed the last argument
will be an image each layer will have a
different image all five images are
available to download in the video
description i might also include some
alternative art assets in there for
experiments later as usual we convert
the arguments that are passed to layer
class constructor into class properties
each layer will also need x and y
position update method to move it and
draw method to draw it on canvas you
know how it goes now i try to keep
similar code structure across all
classes for clarity i could also name
these methods something else if i wanted
to the background images we used today
are seamless which means that when they
are scrolling from left to right
continuously we can't see where they end
and where they begin there is a small
simple trick to create an illusion of
endless background in a side scroller
game and we are about to learn it right
now click like if you are getting any
value today we will be updating
horizontal x coordinate vertical y
coordinate will always be zero
if this dot x is less than minus its
entire width which means it has scrolled
all the way behind the left edge of the
game area and now is hidden reset it
back to 0 so it can scroll again
else keep decreasing x by the current
game speed times speed modifier because
i want each layer to move at a slightly
different speed for parallax effect
gamespeed doesn't actually exist yet so
i declare it here on line 15 inside main
js let's set it to 3 pixels per frame
for example draw method will need
context as an argument to specify which
canvas element we want to draw on
we call built-in canvas a draw image
method again this time we don't need the
longest version with nine arguments for
backgrounds we just need to pass it five
arguments image we want to draw
x and y where to draw it and width and
height of that image
so this is a helper class that will
handle logic for each individual layer
our parallax background will have five
layers we create and combine them
together in another class i call for
example background
and i will be exporting that class
it will need access to the main game
class because we need its width and
height and gamespeed properties i'm
providing new images of a specific size
for this project
the width of each layer image is
1667 pixels and height is set to 500
pixels i made those images the exact
size we will draw on canvas for
performance optimization reasons you can
also use larger images and you can scale
them down with code but that will take
more computing power and it can affect
the fps of your game let's bring all 5
images for our layers into the project
this dot layer 5 image is equal to layer
5.
if you downloaded the project images and
place them inside your assets folder you
can go ahead and inside index.html bring
them into the project image element with
an id of layer 5
and source assets slash layer
5 dot png
i also bring layer 1 2 3 4 5 like this
in style css i give all of them display
none we don't want to draw the actual
image elements on the website we want to
draw them on canvas as i said before
javascript automatically creates
references to all elements with an id in
the global namespace so i can just pull
the images in using its auto-generated
variable name like this it would work
like this but i noticed more people are
comfortable using get element by id in
here so i will do that we will also need
an array that will hold all background
layers so i created here
and here inside background class
constructor i will create an instance of
layer class from line 1. i call it for
example this dot layer 1 and it will be
equal to new layer
you can see it expects 5 arguments so i
pass it this dot game this dot width
distort height speed modifier will be 1
for now and the image will be this.layer
5 image from line 25.
now we have one instance of our layer
class let's put it inside background
layers array
i give it update method and inside i
take that background layers array and i
call for each array method on it for
each layer object in the array i call
its associated update method
i also do the same for draw method
and i pass it context because we know it
expects it up here on line 15.
let's see if it works i import the new
background class up here in main.js
i instantiate it inside game class
constructor and i pass it this keyword
as a reference to the entire game object
because i know it expects it
here i have my background now so i can
call its update method
i get an error we will fix that in a
second i will also call draw method on
the background and i call it before i
draw the player because i want the
background to be behind the player and i
pass it context
so we have an error somewhere inside our
background class
the first typo i made here probably
already noticed i need to use this dot
here to correctly point to the instance
of layer class
now we get draw image error so i know
something is wrong with the way i'm
linking my image
if i check here i can see i misspelled
the name it's supposed to say this dot
layer 5 image nice we are animating our
background layer i can adjust ground
margin to move the player a bit up to
match the background artwork
the trick to create seamlessly scrolling
backgrounds is to draw the same image
twice next to each other so one at the
position x and the other at the position
x plus this dot with like this
i give it additional plus 20 so that we
can see where the second one starts
here
so what is happening here we have two
identical images scrolling side by side
when the main image one scrolls all the
way off screen we quickly reset it so
that it can scroll again image 2 is
never fully visible it's just there to
fill the left gap before the first image
has a chance to reset i hope this visual
makes it clear what's happening
and now you know the secret of endlessly
scrolling seamless backgrounds it's easy
let's make them parallax which means it
has multiple layers that move in
slightly different speeds to create an
illusion of depth of distance
i already brought those images into our
project in index html so i just turned
them into class properties here
i instantiate each layer class with its
associated image
i put all those layer objects inside
this dot background layers array so we
can cycle through all of them
at once using for each method inside
update
and draw now we are animating all layers
at the same speed i can give them
different modifiers layer 1 is just gray
sky no need to move it at all so its
speed will be 0. the speed of layer 2
will be game speed times 0.2
layer 3 is game speed x 0.4
layer 4 will move at 80 percent of the
current game speed and layer 1 will move
at the same speed as the actual current
game speed perfect
you can see that if i change the
modifier even higher it gives us faster
scrolling
since we connected everything to the
current game speed i can change the
scrolling speed of the game when the
player switches to a different state
maybe i want the game to stop scrolling
when the player sits down and i want
double scrolling speed when the player
does a special attack or a role
there are many ways how we can structure
the code at this point i can either
bring a reference to the main game
object into player states so that we can
manipulate game speed property from
there or i can for example do it from
within set state method on player class
because from there we already have
access to game speed
i will give set state a second argument
called speed inside i set speed property
on game object to the speed value passed
as an argument
at first the speed of the game is 3
pixels per frame since we start in the
sitting state the initial game speed
should be zero
in player set state whenever i set state
i will also set game speed i might
refactor this later maybe it's not the
best solution but it should work let's
see when we are running game speed will
be one
in game speed 0
jump in game speed is 1 falling also 1
run in 1
i save all unsaved changes in all my
files now the game stops scrolling when
we sit and it starts scrolling again
when we start moving we can refactor
this to make this code a bit better on
the game class i create a new property
called this.max speed and i set it to 3.
i set this dot speed to 0 at first
inside set state we set the current
speed to max speed
times the speed that was passed to set
state that way i can adjust the actual
game speed by adjusting just the max
speed property on the main game class
rather than adjusting the values we
passed the set state in all those places
in playerstate.js
now we have quite a lot of logic going
on if you are a beginner well done you
should be really proud of yourself if
you managed to follow along this was the
most complicated episode in this entire
project the rest will be relatively easy
when you understand the tips and tricks
i'm about to reveal it's important that
player feels like they have control over
the character quick responsive controls
add a lot towards positive user
experience
we are building a fast-paced animated 2d
game with plain vanilla javascript and
html canvas element we applied state
design pattern to animate our player we
have endlessly scrolling parallax
backgrounds where scrolling speed reacts
to player movement today we will learn
how to make our game more fun by adding
three very different enemy types are you
ready to take our dog for an adventure
and help it find its way home while
avoiding enemies and creatures of the
dark let's go
i create a new file called enemies.js
and inside we declare a custom
javascript class i call for example
enemy
i will have a constructor and inside i
declare this dot frame x which will
handle horizontal sprite sheet
navigation and frame y will navigate in
sprite sheet vertically the sprite
sheets we will be using are optimized
for 20 frames per second so we will
control them with timestamps and delta
time again so three helper variables fps
frame interval and frame timer
it will work exactly the same as it did
in player class we will also need update
method to move enemies around and draw
method to actually draw their sprite
sheets
i want to create multiple different
enemy types to keep our code organized
and easy to navigate in we will use
javascript sub glassine which means we
will have a parent anime class that will
define properties and methods shared
between all enemy types and we will
extend that parent class into multiple
different subclasses each subclass will
have properties and methods behaviors
that are specific just for that enemy
type
so anime is so-called parent class also
called a super class and we are using
this special extends keyword to create
three child classes also called
subglasses javascript actually doesn't
have classes this is just syntactical
sugar modern cleaned and simplified
javascript syntax behind the scenes this
code is just setting up prototype chains
using javascript inheritance it just
looks cleaner and easier to navigate in
if you write your code this way so we
have a parent anime class and three
child classes called flying enemy ground
enemy and climbing enemy all three child
classes are using extends keyword
pointing towards their parent anime
class this will automatically set up
prototype chain behind the scenes and
all these classes will have access to
properties on their parent class and
also to this update and draw method that
way we can avoid code repetition and we
don't have to re-declare methods and
properties that are shared across all
enemy types inside each subclass we will
only define what's unique about them i
will show you exactly how this works as
we create three unique enemy types with
very different behaviors and movement
click the like if you are getting any
value let's start by bringing images
into our project in the video
description i will give you sprite
sheets for many different enemy types
for now we will use just three of them
if you are a beginner you should maybe
use the same ones i'm using and when you
have a fully working code base you can
play with it and use your own custom
sprite sheets
we will use enemyfly enemyplant and this
big spider i will hide images with css
because we want to draw them with
javascript on canvas
there is one more thing we have to
understand when extending javascript
classes there is a special keyword
called super it's used in two different
ways because we can extend code from
parent class constructor or we can
extend a method from the parent class i
will show you how to do both as we
create different enemy types with
different behaviors i have flying enemy
subclass that extends this enemy super
class when i create a new flying enemy i
want to run all this code from parent
class constructor and then i want to add
some additional properties that are
specific only to the flying enemy
i do that by first calling super like
this this will automatically run all the
code from here
while extending classes i can only use
this keyword after i used super if i use
this keyword before super i will get an
error flying enemies will need access to
the entire game object because they need
to be aware of game area width and
height so that they know when they are
off screen i will pass game as an
argument to the constructor here and i
will convert it into a class property as
usual
each enemy type will also need width and
height but because each enemy type has a
different size i couldn't put these
values on the parent class width and
height will be declared here i look at
my fly sprite sheet and i can see that
the width of a single frame is 60 pixels
and the height is 44 pixels
each enemy will also need starting x and
y coordinates flying anime will start at
a different position than a ground nma
so x and y properties will also have to
be on the child class not on the parent
class
speed x will be horizontal speed and max
frame on our fly sprite sheet is 5.
by the way all my flying enemies will be
flies for now but i could also have
multiple flying enemy types i can have
flying anime class that extends parent
enemy class and i can have a bird fly
and ghost classes that extend flying
enemy class we can go down multiple
levels if we want to in that scenario
flying enemy class would only have
properties and methods shared between
all enemy flyers and things like width
and height speed x or max frame would be
declared separately on each subclass
because each anime will have different
sprite sheet we are keeping our code
modular and well organized so that it's
easy to make these changes later if we
want to inside update method on the
parent class we will handle movement for
every animation frame i want the
horizontal x-coordinate of the enemy to
be increased by its speed x property
i will do the same for vertical
y-coordinate and speed y property
we will also handle cycling through
sprite frames here it will work exactly
the same as it does for our player
sprite sheet
update method will have access to delta
time difference in milliseconds between
the previous and the current animation
frame
if frame timer from line 7 is more than
frame interval from line 6 we reset
frame timer back to 0 so it can count
again for the next frame and we serve
the next horizontal frame in the sprite
sheet
or if we are at the last horizontal
frame we reset back to frame x 0. else
meaning frame timer is not yet higher
than frame interval we keep increasing
frame timer by delta time until it gets
there
draw method will expect context as an
argument inside we will draw an enemy
spreadsheet using canvas drawimage
method it will need 9 arguments the
first argument is the image we want to
draw i will hold the reference to that
image in this.image property since each
anime type will have a different sprite
sheet it needs to be placed here on
flying enemy class i use get element by
id and i will point it towards this img
element with an id of anime underscore
fly from line 19 in index html so draw
image expects nine arguments in this
case the image we want to draw source x
source y source width and source height
of the rectangle we want to crop out
from the source sprite sheet one frame
and destination x destination y
destination width and destination height
to specify where to place that image on
destination canvas it will work exactly
the same as it does with player we
already explained before how frame x
multiplied by the width of a single
frame travels spreadsheet horizontally
source y argument will always be zero
because enemy sprites will only have one
row so we have image to draw these four
values define what to crop out these
four values define where to place that
cropped out image on canvas as i said
before we can extend parent class
constructor using super keyword we can
also extend a method from a parent class
in this case i want to have update
method on flying anime type i wanted to
first run all the code from update
method on the parent class and then i
want to add a little bit of code that
will be specific only for flying enemies
update method will expect delta time as
an argument i will call update method on
the parent class from line 9 by saying
super referring to its super class dot
update and i pass this delta time along
because it's expected here on line 9.
doing that will first run all the code
between lines 9 and 19 that code will be
shared for all enemy types
after i run that code i will add a
little bit of code that will be specific
only for flyers i can make them do so
many different things here i made a
special episode focusing only on enemy
movement patterns before let's just pick
one maybe i want vertical wavy movement
before we do that let's actually add
some enemies into the game to see how
the movement changes
let's make sure we are exporting all our
child classes
i imported them up here inside main.js
i want to periodically run some code
that will add enemies in a specific
interval
i will declare that code in a special
method on game class i call it for
example add enemy we will need some
helper properties to build this
functionality this dot enemies will be
an array it will hold all currently
active anime objects every time add
enemy method runs it will take this
array and it will use built-in
javascript push method to push one new
enemy in there push method adds one or
more elements to the end of an array and
returns the new length of the array we
want to push one new flying enemy in
there for now we are importing flying
enemy class here from enemies.js and
here i can see flying enemy class
constructor expects game as an argument
so
down here in main.js i'm creating an
instance of flying enemy class and i
pass it this keyword as an argument
referring to this main game object
we will handle enemies here in sight
update method on game class similar to
how we use delta time to periodically
serve the next frame in our sprite sheet
we will have timer and interval helper
variables to periodically add enemies
into the game enemy timer will start at
zero it will be increasing by delta time
every time it reaches a value in enemy
interval we will add one new enemy into
the game and we will reset enemy timer
back to zero let's say i want to add a
new enemy every second so thousand
milliseconds let's write that logic in
code
if enemy timer from line 23 is more than
enemy interval from line 24 call this
dot at nme custom method from line 38
and also reset enemy timer back to zero
so it can count again towards the next
enemy time else keep increasing enemy
timer by delta time until we reach enemy
interval again
let's put a console lock inside add
anime to see if it's working
i will console lock this.enemies array
from line 22.
nice you can see as the game runs every
second one new flying enemy object is
added into enemies array perfect so all
our enemies are held inside this dot
enemies array
i will run through the array and i will
trigger their update method to make sure
they move around
for each method execute a provided
function once for each array element
i will use fat arrow es6 syntax here in
the callback function i just trigger
update method on each enemy object and i
pass it the delta time from here because
i know it's expected there
i will do the same thing inside the draw
method i will cycle through all enemy
objects and i will trigger their draw
method i pass it context as an argument
i don't see any enemies coming
let's try to use minus equals here to
make them move to the left
still nothing i'm consoling enemies
array so let's check the console i open
up the array
let's change the initial x and y
coordinates to 50 50 now
if i open the array again and i check
one of my flying enemies i can see their
vertical y coordinate is none not a
number javascript doesn't know where to
draw them vertically let's track the
problem i define vertical y-coordinate
correctly on line 33
but as the game runs i'm increasing it
by speed y property here on line 12.
speed y doesn't exist so as a result we
are breaking our code
i will define vertical speed y property
on my flying enemy class let's set it to
zero
nice we have enemy flies moving from
right to left from the initial starting
coordinates 50 50 as defined here
i actually want them to start from the
point just behind the right edge of
available game area so the initial x
coordinate will be this dot game from
line 29 dot width
nice
i randomize vertical y coordinate to
spread them around i want them to only
move in the upper half of the game area
so master random times
this.game.height times 0.5
in console you can see we have an
endlessly increasing array as more and
more enemies are being added i actually
want them to be removed when they fly
past the left edge of screen i will
check if enemies are off screen in this
area if horizontal coordinate of the
enemy plus its width is less than zero
meaning it's completely hidden behind
the left edge set its marked for
deletion property to true this property
will be shared for all child classes so
i can define it only once up here on the
parent class
initially i set it to false
so we are adding new enemies
they fly from right to left when they
are hidden behind the left edge we are
setting their marked for deletion
property to true here inside update
method on game class in the area where
we handle enemies we are cycling through
every object in enemies array triggering
their update method
at the same time i will also check if
their marked for deletion is true and if
it is we splice it out of the array
removing it
splice method needs two arguments in
this case
index of the element we want to remove
from the array so index off this enemy
with marked for deletion set to true and
how many elements to remove at that
index we want to remove only one element
now i check in the console and i see
that new enemies are being added and old
enemies are being correctly removed
perfect
let's play with the movement a little
bit i can do so many things here and
there's a special episode about it i
can't for example randomize their
horizontal speed x value so that each
enemy flies at a slightly different
speed
let's try a random value between 1 and 2
pixels per frame
i can also randomize their initial
x-coordinate so that we get even more
randomness in their spacing
when the player starts running it
becomes obvious we need to account for
the current game speed when making
enemies move
up here on line 12 i just include game
speed in horizontal position calculation
i actually need to use plus here now
when the player moves and when it stops
moving the enemies are always positioned
correctly in relation to our dynamically
scrolling game world we made a lot of
progress today if you are still
following well done these are all
fundamentals of 2d game development i
hope you are getting some value out of
this
so the flies are moving in a straight
line from right to left what if i want
to give them a wavy up and down wobble
as they move it's easy
i will need two helper variables and
these will be specific only for flying
enemies so i declare them down here
angle will start at 0 and we will be
increasing it slowly and feeding it to
mastered sine method which will map it
along a sine wave
it will be increasing by this custom va
value velocity of angle and it will be a
random value between 0.1 and 0.2
inside update method on flying anime
class i first trigger all the code from
the parent anime class and i will add
some extra custom code that will be
specific only for flying enemies for
every animation frame i will increase
angle by va value
and then i update vertical y coordinate
by math.sine of this ever increasing
angle value
passing a slowly increasing angle to
method sign will map positions of our
enemies long sine wave we can also
create a circular movement by using math
cosine on horizontal x-coordinate for
now let's leave it like this we have our
flying enemy type perfect let's create a
ground enemy it will be applied so it
will have different behavior it will be
much simpler to implement let me show
you
class ground anime extends enemy so
again this class will automatically
inherit everything from the parent anime
class we declared up top the only
properties we will declare here are the
ones that are specific to ground enemies
shared properties will be inherited
automatically because of this extends
keyword constructor will expect the game
as an argument and we convert it to this
dot game property
the width of a single frame is 60 height
is 87 pixels initial x is just behind
the right edge of canvas so
this.game.with we want the enemy to be
sitting on the ground level of our game
world so vertical y-coordinate will be
game height minus height of this enemy
minus ground margin
image will point towards anime plant
image from index html
horizontal speed will be zero
and vertical speed will be also zero
this is a plant it won't move around
sprite sheet is very simple it has only
two frames max frame is one because we
count from zero
if i don't declare update and draw
methods at all on ground enemy class
javascript will automatically travel up
the prototype chain and it will find
update and draw method on the parent
anime class
in main.js inside add anime function we
only want to be adding ground enemies
when we are moving if we are sitting
down we don't want the game to keep
adding new ground enemies because they
would just be accumulating off screen we
only want to add a new enemy if game
speed is more than zero when the game is
scrolling
and also i don't really want to add it
every thousand milliseconds every time
add anime method runs i only want there
to be a 50 chance that we add one so
math at random is less than 0.5
master random code like this returns a
random value between 0 and 1 so a value
lower than 0.5 should occur on average
50 percent of the time so every time add
enemy method runs we always add one
flying enemy and if the game is
scrolling and this 50 check is true we
also add one new ground enemy
i get an error which tells me i forgot
to call super class constructor on my
subclass easy to fix
like this
nice we have a ground enemy in our game
i can see there is a small wobble
between enemy planes and the ground
texture i'm not really sure what's
causing it now if you know let me know
in the comments we will fix this later
let's add a climbing enemy climbing
anime will be a big spider suspended
from a web i showed you how to extend
update method to make our flies move in
a different pattern i also showed you
how it works when you don't need to
declare any additional update and draw
methods with the plant now i will show
you how to extend the draw method and
how to add some additional graphics in
this case spiderwebs constructor will
expect game as an argument we call super
the trigger class constructor from the
parent enemy class this.game is game as
usual width of a single frame is 120
height is 144 pixels the initial
starting coordinate is behind the right
edge of canvas so this.game.wav vertical
y coordinate will be a random position
in the top half of the available game
area
image will point to the big spider image
we linked earlier in index html
horizontal speed x will be zero our
spiders will be moving up and down
vertically vertical speed y will be
either plus one or minus one depending
on this math random check
this is so called ternary operator we
are using it as a simple one line if
else statement if math at random is less
than 0.5 which should be roughly in 50
of cases set speed y to 1. else set it
to -1 so if condition is true question
mark return this else colon return this
this will make sure some spiders are
moving up some are moving down when they
initially spawn in our game
max frame of spider sprite sheet is 5.
update method will take delta time as an
argument it will first call update
method on its parent anime class to run
all the code from there
we will also do the same thing for draw
method like this
here i'm checking if game speed is more
than 0 and if random check is less than
0.5 and i'm adding a new ground enemy
i'm going to add else if here and if
this random check is false and at the
same time if game speed is more than
zero we will add one new climbing enemy
into our game
now every second we always get one fly
and we get either one spider or one
plant nice
i'm extending update method on climbing
enemy because i want to climb up and
down when it's moving down and it
reaches a bottom boundary we define here
i want it to kinda bounce and start
moving in the opposite direction upwards
let's make it move upwards whenever it
climbs all the way down and touches the
ground level
so if vertical y coordinate is more than
game dot height minus height of this
spider enemy minus ground margin set its
vertical speed to its minus value so
this.speed times -1
also i want to set its marked for
deletion to true if it climbs off screen
vertically so
if this dot y is less than minus height
of the spider sprite sheet set it's
marked for deletion to true
this spider spawned moving up
this one is moving down when it reaches
ground it bounces and it starts moving
back up perfect
we are also extending a draw method so
let's draw a spider web spiders don't
fly they should be hanging from a spider
web
we are calling draw method on the parent
anime class that will handle drawing of
the actual spider sprite sheet and we
will add some extra code here just to
draw the spider web i want to create a
line so i start by calling begin path
move method will set the initial x and y
coordinates of the line i give it
coordinates 0 0 for now the top left
corner of canvas
line 2 will define the ending x and y
coordinates so i pass it spider's
current x position as x and 0 as
vertical y now i can stroke my line
i don't see any line right i need to use
this dot y here to move it on screen
and here's our spider web it works let's
make it look better i wanted to start
from this dot x and 0 so just above the
spider
nice so it goes from the top left corner
of spider sprite sheet upwards i need to
center it horizontally so plus the width
of the spider divided by 2 and i
increase y by 50 to actually touch the
spider image
almost there i just need to also offset
the initial starting point of the line
like this i'm happy with this if you are
designing a game with multiple levels
you can for example have a different
flyer different ground enemy and
different climbing enemy for each level
so three enemy types like this could be
enough depending on your game structure
also it's possible to put many more
enemy types into the game and mix them
together it's up to you i gave you all
the tools you need if you have any
questions let me know we will learn how
to handle collision detection next time
we will also apply particle effects to
give the player a fire trail and we will
add two more states with unique
animations for when the player is
attacking and when it gets hit well done
on completing the lesson see you in the
next one
we created a player we have our game
world and we added dangerous creatures
of the night it's time to add some
interactions and special moves today we
will learn an easy way how to handle
collision detection and we will resolve
collision between player and enemies in
two different ways depending on the
current player state if the player is
rolling enemies are destroyed and we get
score points in any other state it's the
player who receives a hit we will also
add dust particles and fire trail if you
followed any of my other creative
courses you can also use those animated
trails and use them here like you see in
this demo i like to combine game dev and
creative coding with javascript and html
canvas it's all the same set of
techniques let's go
we have player and enemies in our game
we want them to be able to interact in
different ways with each other let's
apply collision detection first i want
to draw a rectangle around the player
and around each enemy to see their
collision areas so called hitboxes i go
to input js file and i delete these
console logs i want our game to have a
debug mode when i press letter d on my
keyboard we enable debug mode and
collision hitboxes will be drawn when we
press the again we exit debug mode and
hitboxes will be hidden it's very simple
to implement in keydown event i create
an else if statement if e.k is d set
debug property on the main game object
to its opposite value if it's currently
true set it to false if it's false set
it to
true in main.js i created this.debug
property on game class and initially i
set it to true
in draw method on playerclass before i
draw the player's spritesheet i say if
this.game.debug is true draw a rectangle
around the player this rectangle will be
exactly the size of player's hitbox so
from this.xdist.y
player's coordinates to player's width
and height like this
now i can go back to input js here we
are toggling debug mode on and off by
pressing letter d
for this to work i need to bring a
reference to the main game object here i
pass gameobject as an argument to the
class constructor and i convert it to a
class property from here we can point to
the game object and toggle debug mode on
and off finally we know that input
handler class expects game as an
argument so here on the main game class
i passed this as an argument now when i
press letter d on my keyboard we are
toggling debug mode on and off perfect i
can also create hitboxes around enemies
inside the draw method on anime class i
say if this.game.debug is true stroke
rectangle around the enemy
like this
this will work reference to the game
object is not on the main parent enemy
class but we have it down here on each
enemy type separately
our game now has a debug mode you can
toggle it on and off by pressing d
these hit boxes represent collision
areas when the player hitbox touches any
of the enemy hitboxes i want them to
interact in some way we can have
multiple different interactions today i
will show you how to have two different
interactions when the player collides
with an enemy while in rolling state it
will destroy that enemy and we get some
score points if the player is not
rolling it will get hit and it will stop
its movement for a moment and play dizzy
animation from our sprite sheet we will
use a simple collision detection formula
between two rectangles to check if
player and enemies interact here inside
the player class i create a new helper
method i call for example check
collisions inside we will cycle through
enemies array that holds all currently
active enemy objects and as we cycle
through them one by one we will compare
their x y width and height to the
current x y width and height of the
player object so this dot game dot
enemies
each and for each anime object i will
run the following callback function
we will have a simple if else statement
if some conditions are met collision is
detected else there is no collision
to check if two rectangles collide which
means they touch or they overlap we have
to compare their x y width and height
keep in mind that the way images our
sprite sheets are drawn on canvas we go
from their x and y coordinates from the
top left corner of the image to their
width and height like this
so now player's current horizontal x
position is here and vertical y position
is here for example we need to check if
x-coordinate of this enemy is less than
x-coordinate of the player plus player
with
if this point is less or to the left on
the horizontal x-axis from this point
at the same time we check if
x-coordinate of the enemy plus the width
of the enemy is more than the current
x-coordinate of the player if this point
is to the right of this point
if these two conditions are true we know
that the player and enemy are colliding
horizontally we still don't know if they
collide because they could be far away
from each other vertically we will need
two more checks here we check if the
enemy's current vertical y position is
less than vertical position of the
player plus player's height we check if
this point is above this point and
finally we check if enemy's y position
plus its height is more than y position
of the player if this point is below
this point
only if all four of these conditions are
true player and enemy are colliding even
if one of these is false this entire if
statement will evaluate to false and we
know there is no collision
if we collide we will set marked for
deletion property on that enemy object
the true i will also add one more score
point so this.game.score plus plus i
save changes and in main js i need to
create this dot score property and
initially i set it to zero
now i go back to player js i take our
new check collisions method and i'll be
constantly calling it over and over from
up here inside the update method like
this
and we have interactions in our game
whenever the player hitbox touches a
hitbox of any enemy that enemy gets
deleted perfect whenever we destroy an
enemy we are also increasing our score
but we can't see it yet let's create
some ui elements i create a new file
called uijs
inside i create a custom class i call
for example ui and i will be exporting
it
be careful about lowercase and uppercase
letters with the word ui make sure you
spell it the same across our code base
constructor will need a reference to the
main game object because that's where
the current score value is stored i
create a property called font size and i
set it to 30 pixels for example font
family will be helvetica you can also
use any google fonts here just link them
in index html and use their font family
name here if you want to it will work
this ui class will have just one method
i call for example draw its job will be
to draw all ui elements and game
statuses that we need first i declare
some basic settings context.font will be
this dot font size plus pixels space
plus this dot font family in this part
we will declare code that's specific to
drawing score up here some more global
settings text align will be left
and fill style for all fonts will be
kept on the main game object in case we
need to draw fonts from some other
modules as well
this.game.font color it doesn't exist
yet so i declare it here online 27 in
main.js file to draw score i call built
in fill text method and i pass it some
text we want to draw so score colon
space plus this.game.score
that's a variable from line 26 in
main.js
and i want it to be drawn at coordinates
2050.
we are exporting our new ui class up
here so we can import it to main.js like
this
i will instantiate ui class inside game
class constructor as usual and i pass it
the reference to the main game object so
this keyword
inside the draw method on game class i
take this dot ui property that holds an
instance of our new ui class be careful
about capital letters here
and i call it the draw method and i pass
it context perfect we are drawing score
and it's increasing as we collide with
enemies so this is how i like to handle
drawing game text and statuses if we
want to display more information to the
user we can just add more code inside
the draw method on our new ui class we
are keeping our code modular and
organized today it's easy to expand it
later
i want to add more player states we will
have two different attacks and a
separate state that will play dizzy
animation when the player gets hit by an
enemy let's go ahead and add them up
here inside player states jazz into our
enum object that holds key value pairs
and it assigns each state number a more
human readable value
we will have rolling state with index 4
diving state with index 5 and hit state
with index 6 for when the player gets
hit
i copy this entire code block and i
rename it to rolling
i will also put rolling in all caps here
i check my sprite sheet and i can see
that rolling animation is on the row 6
counting from 0 so frame y is 6.
i want player to start rolling when we
press enter and i want it to keep
rolling as long as enter key is pressed
down inside handle input we deal with
switching states we only want to switch
player to a different state when enter
is not pressed anymore so if input
doesn't include enter and at the same
time if player is currently on ground we
can exit rolling state and switch the
player into running state
else if input doesn't include enter and
player is not on ground if we stop
drawing in the air switch into the
falling state like this
we have a rolling state now we can
decide from which states we will allow
the player to enter rolling in this case
i will allow it from all states because
player can start rolling anytime
inside handle input method on sitting
class i say else if input includes enter
set state to rolling and pass it speed
of 2. rolling will increase the
scrolling speed of our game compared to
the regular running speed
i take this else statement and i paste
it down here inside the running class we
can also start rolling when we are
running
i do the same in jumping class we can
also start rolling while we are in the
middle of a jump for now i will not
allow player to start rolling while it's
falling let's see how that feels we can
always add it later
so now we have rolling with a value of 4
up here inside our enum and we are
exporting rolling class on line 94.
on line 1 in player js i import rolling
and i create an instance of it inside
this.states array on line 21.
i get an error it's because i didn't
save changes i made to playerstate.js vs
code editor indicates that you have
unsaved changes in a file with this
little icon here
i go in i save it and now i can press
enter and i can roll around nice work
i can start rolling from running state
from sitting state and from jumping
state i'm testing my gameplay and i feel
like i would like to start in while i'm
rolling on the ground like this but the
game won't allow me to do that
i can't enter jump while rolling on the
ground because we didn't write that
behavior let's do it
in handle input method on rolling class
i say if input includes enter which
means we are rolling and if input also
includes arrow up at the same time
remember that our input keys array can
hold multiple keys at the same time if
enter and arrow up are pressed at the
same time and if we are rolling on the
ground at that moment so this dot player
on ground is true
we will push player up in the negative
direction on the vertical y axis this
dot player velocity y minus equals 27
now i can roll around and i can jump up
and down like this this feels much
better to play this is a superhero dog i
want the controls and movement to feel
good and quick this dog can roll and
jump around freely and the controls are
very
precise time to add some particle
effects we will have three different
particle types in this game dust that
comes from the ground at player's feet
when it runs on solid ground blazing
fire trail when the player is rolling
and diving and a big splash of particles
when we dive and stomp into the ground i
create a new file i call for example
particles.js inside we will have the
main parent class called particle i will
not be exporting it it will just contain
properties and methods shared between
all three particle types constructor
will need a reference to the main game
object marked for deletion will be false
at first
update method will also have some code
shared between all particle types
horizontal x-coordinate will decrease by
the amount of speed x and the game speed
like this
vertical y coordinate will be affected
by speed y property
for every frame the size of each
particle will decrease by 5
when size is less than 0.5 pixels the
particle is small enough and we will set
its marked for deletion property to true
values like speed x and size don't exist
yet i didn't declare them on the main
particle class because they will have
different values for each particle type
we need to make sure we define them on
the child classes because if javascript
can't find these properties when update
method runs we will get an error
so child class i call dust extends
parent particle class we will be
exporting it we will also have splash
particles for when we hit the ground at
high speed and fire particles for the
attack animations i start with the dust
class constructor will need a reference
to the main game object and x and y
coordinates because the location of the
particle will depend on the player's
current position we want them to appear
under the player as it moves around i
call super and pass this game along
because it's expected up here this will
trigger class constructor on the parent
particle class activating all shared
properties size of dust particles will
be a random number between 10 and 20.
x-coordinate will be x that is passed as
an argument same goes for the
y-coordinate horizontal speed x will be
a random number between 0 and 1.
vertical speed y is also a random number
between 0 and 1.
color will be black
draw method will take context as an
argument as usual i want to draw dust
particles as circles so we start with
begin path
we create an arc add coordinates this
dot x distort y
with a radius of this dot size start
angle will be zero and angle is mothered
by times two so full circle
we set fill style to this dot color and
we fill the path with black color
we are exporting dust so i will import
it up here on line 1 in player states js
since we are using state design pattern
it makes sense we control particles from
here as well because they will be
closely tied to player states
i have a problem now if i want to handle
particles from here this way i need
access to the main game object when i
initially built this state management
code i thought i would only need access
to the player class but we need to go
one level up and access the game object
this is why it's good to plan your code
bases well before you start writing the
code i will have to do a little bit of
refactoring here to make sure we have
access to the main game class from
within each individual player state
class
here on line 14 i pass the main state
parent class a second argument called
game and inside i convert it to class
property this.game equals game
i want to replace all references to the
player object with references to the
game object game object contains the
player so i will still have access to
the player object from there
constructor on the sitting class will
expect the game as an argument we delete
this line with player
i pass that game object reference along
to the parent class constructor as a
second argument because i know it's
expected here on line 14. it will get
converted to this.gameclass property
now if i want to access player in these
5 places i need to say
this.game.player in vs code you can
highlight a portion of text and hold
ctrl key down then whenever you tap
letter d it will highlight another
occurrence of that text using this you
can select multiple lines at the same
time i tab d four times to select all
five occurrences of this text and that
gives me multi-cursor selection i can
use left and right arrows to move around
and i just type game dot
i do the same in the running class i
pass it game
i remove this player line and i pass
game as the second argument to the
superclass constructor then i select one
two three four five six and i need
this.game.player here in all these
places
i do the same in jumping class
refactoring sorry i should have planned
this part better we are almost done
i replace all 9 occurrences of this dot
player here with this dot the game dot
player
falling class doesn't have much code so
this one is easy
and rolling class is the last one we
need to refactor
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
and
this.game.player
if i save this it will break our code
because our state classes are expecting
game as an argument now so on line 21 in
player.js we are currently passing this
keyword which means player object i need
to pass this.game from line 5 instead to
all of them
now we are getting some new errors and
that's because i'm passing game object
as an argument and immediately i'm
triggering that state class and its
enter method but at this point the game
object is not yet completely loaded so
the initial state is failing i need to
cut these two lines of code and i only
want to run them when the rest of the
game object is ready so add the end here
when everything is ready including game
class player class and all state classes
we take current state property on player
class and we set it to states 0 sit in
state and we trigger enter method on the
sitting state
we refactored our code and now
everything is working again we are well
positioned to start adding particles
through our state classes
we have a lot of console logs here i
press ctrl f and i search for console
i delete this one on line 61 in main.js
and this one on line 65
we also have a console lock on line 57
in player js i delete it
debugging is better with a clean console
so we are exporting dust class here and
we are importing it up here in player
states js i will hold all currently
active particles in an array on the main
game object so i created here
these two particles will be an empty
array at first
back to player stage gs i only want to
add dust when the player is running so
inside handle input method on running
state that runs 60 times per second i
will be pushing one new particle in
every time it runs
this.game.particles.push and i pass it
new dust on line 14 in particles.js i
can see that the dust class constructor
expects game x and y as arguments so i
pass it this dot game from line 16
i will also be passing the current x and
y coordinates of the player because i
want the new particles to appear at
player's current position
i close some of these javascript files
for now to keep our workplace clean
inside update method on the game class
after this block that handles enemies we
write our code to handle particles on
line 25 we have this dot particles array
that holds all currently active particle
objects we are pushing new dust
particles in here from inside running
state class
i take that array and i call for each
for each particle in the array i will
call their update method
if particle is small enough and its
marked for deletion property has been
set to true we call splice method to
remove it splice method will need index
of the particle we want to remove and
how many elements to remove starting
from that index for each method passes
auto-generated index argument so i can
just assign it to a variable name here i
call it for example index and i pass it
the splice to identify the particle to
remove and i want to remove one element
at this index so here we call update on
all active particles and we delete old
ones
inside the draw method i will cycle
through all the particles again and i
will call draw method
one optimization tip here would be not
to cycle through the same array once in
update and once in draw method i can for
example have a utility handle particles
function that does all of that there are
many ways to refactor this code we might
do it later for now this code will work
well
you can see we are drawing our dust
particles from the top left corner of
the player hitbox only when we are in a
running state nice
i will count lock this.particles array
to check if old particles are being
correctly removed we don't want to have
an endlessly growing array in our
project that would become a performance
problem soon in console i can see that
particles go up to 50 or 60 and when we
stop running the array is getting
smaller and smaller until it's empty
again perfect i want the dust particles
to come from a different point relative
to the player
i adjust horizontal x-coordinate by the
half of player's width like this
i will also adjust vertical y coordinate
by player's height pushing the
particle's initial coordinates down
closer to the game level ground you can
see how well this works in combination
with state design pattern we are only
adding new particles when in running
state when players feet are moving and
touching the ground
i can go to my dust class and play with
properties of the dust i can make the
particles different shape or size here
if i want to i can also give them a
different color
red blue
it will all work
i can also do a semi-transparent color
using rgba color declaration like this
i'm happy with this but feel free to
play with the code and adjust these
effects
i came up with two different versions to
animate fire for this game i showed you
both versions this is the version with
svg filters where we are blurring and
sharpening particles to create this
liquid smoke effect i use this a lot in
my generative art videos you could
actually look at any of my creative
coding videos where we build trails and
use that code to give your player a
unique trail effect it will be
compatible with everything today i will
do something i haven't showed you how to
do before i will use a particle image it
will be this simple flame texture canvas
is very good and efficient at drawing
images drawing a rectangle or an image
are often two most performance efficient
options for an effect like this from my
experience you can download the fire
texture in the video description
the texture is big i will probably make
the image smaller before i give it to
you for download you can also color
shift the image in photoshop to create
blue or red fire trail if it fits your
level art assets i set its display to
none with css we will use this image
here for our fire class constructor will
expect game x and y as arguments
this.image will be this fire texture
image i gave it an id of fire
size will be a random value between 50
and 150 pixels
x will be passed as an argument and same
goes for y
horizontal speed will be 1 pixel per
frame
and vertical speed will also be 1 pixel
we have update method on the parent
particle class i will first call the
code from here so update
super update like this draw method will
take context as an argument and it will
call draw image
i pass it this dot image from line 39
this dot x this dot y this dot size as
width and this dot size as a height
nice so this is our fire class we are
exporting it so i can import it on line
1 in player states js
i can copy this line of code from
running class that is adding a new dust
particles i pasted inside handle input
method on rolling class and instead of
dust i instantiate the new fire class we
just wrote
now when i roll i'm getting a trail of
fire i adjust these properties a bit
before we fix the position of our fire
trail let's make the individual fire
texture images rotate i will need two
helper variables called this.angle which
will start at zero and this dot va
velocity of angle it will be a random
value between minus 0.1 and plus 0.1
in a site update method i will increase
angle by va for every animation frame
we will be rotating so to make sure the
rotations don't overflow to other
elements and only affect this fire
particle i will wrap this code between
save and restore this will make sure all
canvas settings i declare in between
will only affect this one particle
to rotate anything on canvas first we
have to translate rotation center point
from its default position at coordinate
0 0 in the top left corner of canvas
over the center of the item we want to
rotate so i will translate to this dot x
and this dot y of this fire particle
that particle is a rectangular image so
i'm translating to its top left corner
then i call build in rotate method that
takes angle value in radians and it will
rotate everything that's drawn after
this call unless we restore canvas again
to its original default state if i roll
now we are getting a spiral of small
fire particles in a big circle around
the player it's because we are
translating to this dot x this dot y and
from that point we are drawing again to
the distance of this dot x this dot y
here i fixed that by setting this to 0 0
because position of particle on canvas
is already defined in translate method
here
translate method moves rotation center
point and what is considered coordinate
0 0 on canvas to the coordinates we pass
to it so because of this translate call
for these particles coordinates 0 0 on
canvas are here in this area i'm
translating to the topless corner of
each fire image of each particle
rectangle i want to center it so i
adjust this value by half of its width
and this one by the half of its height
canvas rotation can be difficult for
beginners but we just covered all of it
i have more detailed lessons on this
topic but for now let's just move on
i can increase the size of fire
particles here on line 40.
i can also give them some horizontal
wobble using the same technique we used
for flying enemies for each frame i
increase x by a sine value of ever
increasing angle and it will map
horizontal x positions along an endless
sine wave shape if you are a beginner
all you have to understand about this is
that if you pass math design and ever
increase in angle value our angle is
increasing here on line 50. it will mod
positions along a wavy path if you look
at the particles now there is some left
right wavy movement
i can also make the particles shrink
slower by adjusting this value this will
result in a longer fire trail as
particles take longer to be small enough
to be removed i can make the rotation
faster or slower by adjusting this range
of values
i can increase particle size
i can make them shrink faster
in main.js i remove this console lock on
line 53
i want to make sure we don't get too
many particles i want to have a property
that will limit the maximum amount of
particles we allow in our game so we can
easily adjust that value if we need to
so inside update method on the main game
class
in this section where we handle
particles i say if the length of
particles array is more than 50 i want
to slice the array and remove everything
from 50 upwards i do that by taking
these particles and assigning it to the
same array but sliced from index 0 to
index 50. it will only allow the first
50 particles to be in this array
anything over and it will get sliced
away slice message returns a copy of an
array with only a portion of elements
from start index to end index we defined
the original array will not be modified
so that's why i'm overriding it like
this because in this case i want to
modify the original array
so we have some hard-coded values
repeated here and here let's replace
them with a variable i call it for
example this.max particles i declare it
up here and i set it to 50.
i can see it works because it slices
particles from the array you see how
they disappear and we are getting gaps
in our particle trail i actually want to
slice particles from the other side of
the array i want to remove the old ones
not the new ones i can change the
arguments i pass the slice method or i
can change how we push our dust and fire
particles into particles array in player
states js on line 104 instead of using
push method which adds one more element
to the end of the array i will use
unshift built in array method instead
unshift method adds one element to the
beginning of an array so now when i'm
slicing from index 0 to index 50 i keep
those new particles and i'm removing old
ones if their index exceeds the value
stored in max particles variable i do
the same thing on line 48 i will be
unshifting dust particles adding them to
the beginning of our particles array to
check if everything works i will control
lock distort particles from here it
starts empty if we start rolling it
fills with fire particles if we run it
fills with dust particles it never
exceeds 50 particle objects so our slice
method is correctly limiting the length
of the array nice
i'm on a strong computer so i will set
my maximum particle limit to 200 but you
can keep it on a lower number if you
want to it's up to you
i will also delete this console look on
line 57 to clean up congratulations on
completing this lesson in the next part
we will make our game look and feel
better by adding more animation it will
help the player to get more visual
feedback to the events happening in the
game i'll see you there
hey creative coders in this episode we
will finalize player abilities and
particle effects we will animate
collisions with a special sprite sheet
and we will add win and loose condition
based on game timer we will also clean
up some loose ends in our code let's
finish the base game and then we can
talk about some optional bonus features
havana
i want to create a second attack this
time it will be a crushing meteor attack
from above player can only enter this
state when it's in the air it's a
perfect use case for state design
pattern we have here in our code base
when the player is running on the ground
and we press down arrow key it sits down
when the player is up in the air we
press down arrow key it will do a
crushing dive attack from above i copied
the entire code block with the rolling
state class and i call it dive in i also
pass a string that says dive in in all
caps to superclass constructor all the
values inside entry method will stay the
same because dive in uses the same
sprite animation row as rolling we will
also leave the same fire particles code
because diving also leaves a fire trail
while the player is in diving state it
is just moving fast towards the ground
when it hits the ground and this
statement is true we switch player to
the running state to keep the momentum
going
i can delete this entire else if
statement
and here i say else if input includes
enter and player is on ground transition
directly into rolling state it should
make the transition animation connect
better
we have our diving state but there is
currently no way to enter that state
let's define rules for when it can
happen we can enter dive in state while
we are in a jumping state
when we are jumping and we press arrow
down we set state to dive in and game
speed will be zero because we are moving
directly down let's take full advantage
of the fact that the scrolling speed of
our game world is connected to player
states we can also enter dive in state
while falling so i just copied the same
else if statement here and we can also
dive while rolling
let's test it and see i save my changes
and the code breaks because we need to
import and instantiate the new dive in
class i import it on line 1 and i create
an instance in this dot states array on
line 21.
it works
i want to feel like we are slamming into
the ground with a great power but right
now the player hovers in the air for too
long in enter method on diving state
class i set velocity y to plus 15
instantly giving the player a massive
push towards the ground
nice now it feels like there is some
power behind that special move
as i'm diving and hitting the ground
player kinda gets stuck below the ground
level let's fix that
so here inside update method on player
class we handle horizontal movement and
horizontal boundaries here we handle
vertical movement and vertical
boundaries will be defined here let's
keep ourselves organized i want to make
sure that the player cannot get stuck
below ground level like this so i will
limit its vertical position
if this dot y is more than the height of
the game area minus the height of the
player
minus ground margin set player's
vertical y position to game height minus
player height minus ground margin like
this
now the player can never move to the
space below this point below the level
of ground texture in our game world
we have one more particle class i called
splash when the player does a meteor
dive attack from above and it hits the
ground i want it to do a flame explosion
and i want the flames to splash in all
directions to make that move look and
feel very powerful
constructor will need three arguments as
usual game and x and y positions
i trigger constructor on the parent
super class and i pass the game along so
this code will run
size of the splash particle will be a
random number between 10 and 200 pixels
this dot x is x
this dot y is y
speed x will be a random number between
-3 and plus 3 because i want them to
splash in both directions horizontally
speed y will be between 2 and 4 for
example i want the particles to start
moving up but as the gravity slowly
grows stronger i want them to curve and
start moving down similar principle we
used for player jump in logic image will
be the same one we are using for fire
particle class
update method will at first call update
on the parent particle class as usual
gravity from line 40 will be slowly
increasing by 0.1 and this dot y will be
increasing by the ever increasing
gravity value to get that curved path
draw method will just draw the fire
image from line 41.
we are exporting splash class so i
import it online one in player states js
i can't really create this particle
explosion when we enter dive in state
because at that point the player is
still in the air i wanted to create it
as we hit the ground so i could add exit
state to all my states which would be an
ideal location for this to happen given
our code structure i can also create
some small transitional state just for
this or i can just do the simplest
option and create the explosion in this
else if statement on line 133 when
player is in diving state and handle
input method detects we touch the ground
we set player state to run in and we
create our splash particle i use unshift
again to add one particle to the
beginning of the array and i pass it
game x and y position of the player
one particle wouldn't be very impressive
so i create a for loop here and i will
run it 30 times we will create a splash
of 30 particles
i'm getting some errors
it's here on line 1 in player stage js i
misspelled my class name
when i dive i get another error it just
says that i forgot to pass context to
draw method on splash class console
errors are usually good at pointing us
to the file and line of code where the
problem is these two errors were easy to
find and fixed thanks to my browser
console now when we hit the ground we
get a splash of particles i offset
initial x coordinate maybe like this
i also offset the y-coordinate
i adjust the initial position values i
pass to splash particle class
constructor i'm kind of just playing
with the values and offsetting them in
random way because i want the particles
to shrink in size which makes them move
towards their top left corner i adjust
this value
there is a better way to deal with this
but i think for the purposes of this
class we can just do this quick hack it
will look good enough
and i just speed x like this
this looks alright for now i think
we get a nice impact animation when we
hit the ground perfect
i also want to have a player state that
will play dizzy animation when we get
hit by an enemy while we are not in a
fireball state i call it hit
i delete this line that adds fire
particles i also deleted this
i check my sprite sheet and i can see
that max frame for this animation is 10.
frame y is 4 and i delete this
i will spell class name like this and
i pass it hit here with this state class
i will do something i haven't showed you
before we can enter a state have it play
its animation row once and when that
animation has been played we
automatically transfer to another state
so the trigger for switching state will
be animation frame this time
so while we are in this hit state this
animation row is playing
i will wait until frame x is at position
10 and i check if player is on ground
and i switch player back to running
else if we are on the last frame on this
animation row and if player is not on
the ground we set state to fallen
nice
up here i can see that hit state has an
index of six
i import it into player.js module and i
instantiate it as the item with an index
of 6 inside this dot states array
ideally i want to do all my state
swapping from within player states js i
could do it through a set of flags and
flipping values around but since this
class is beginner friendly i will do a
simple thing and switch my state from
here now
i want to enter this new state when
player collides with an enemy and it's
currently not in rolling or diving state
so if collision is detected we will
always mark enemy for deletion
regardless of what type of collision it
is
i delete this else block we won't be
needing it we are going to run if else
statement if collision is detected
if we detect collision and player is
currently in rolling or diving state so
index 0 1 2 3 4 and 5 player is
invulnerable in these states so it will
destroy enemy and give us plus 1 score
this.current state
is this dot states 4 rolling or if
this.current state is this dot states 5
divin increased the score
else meaning the player collided with an
enemy while it wasn't in one of those
two states it means player will get hit
by enemy and it will play the hit
animation we will of course get no score
points for that
i call this dot set state and i pass it
6 the index of hit state and i pass it
speed 0 because i want the game to stop
moving for the duration of this state to
properly emphasize that we collided with
something
if i test it i can see the score is
correctly increasing as we hit enemies
in rolling or diving state and if we
collide with an enemy while not in one
of these states we enter hit state
perfect great job if you are coding
alone hope you are getting a lot of
value when the player collides with an
enemy i want to run this sprite
animation let's handle that logic in a
separate module i will call it for
example collision animation js you know
how we do this by now
there will be a class called collision
animation constructor will expect the
game object reference and x and y
positions we convert game into class
property as usual
you can download the image in the video
description i place it in my assets
folder and i link it here in index.html
i give it an id of collision animation
i hide the image with css
sprite with the width of a single frame
is 100 pixels sprite height is 90 pixels
we will have size modifier to randomize
the sizes a bit it will be a random
value between 0.5 and 1.5 the width will
be multiplied by this dot modifier value
like this sprite width times size
modifier height will be sprite height
times size modifier it's a rectangular
image and i want x position to be in the
middle of the image that's why i waited
until now to convert x and y into class
properties we can only do it after we
calculate the width and height of the
animation i want to push x and y over
the center of the animation so x will be
x coordinate passed as an argument minus
half of the width y will be y coordinate
minus half of the height frame x will
start at 0 max frame is 4.
marked for deletion will be false at
first
we are animating a sprite sheet so as
usual we use a draw image built in
method and pass it nine arguments image
we want to draw so this dot image from
line four source x will be frame x times
sprite width for horizontal navigation
around the sprite sheet source y will be
0 because this sprite sheet has only one
row source width is sprite width source
height is sprite height so these 4
values specify which area we want to
crop out from the source sprite sheet
now i pass it for more values
destination x will be this dot x from
line 10
destination y is this dot y destination
width and height will be the width and
height we calculated on lines eight and
nine these last four values determine
where to draw that cropped out frame on
destination canvas
update method will make sure that
collision animations move with the game
world so this dot y minus equals
this.game.speed we export the class up
here on line 1. i import up on line 2 in
player js because this is the module
where we handle collisions
i create an array that will hold all
currently active collision animation
objects i call it this dot collisions
and it will be an empty array at first
we have collision animation class
available so i go down to check
collision method and every time player
collides with an enemy we set marked for
deletion on that animator true and i
will also push one new collision
animation object into this.collisions
array
i can see it expects game x and y so i
pass it this.game and i pass it x and y
coordinates of that enemy since enemy is
a rectangle i pass it in the middle of
that rectangle horizontally and
vertically like this i want the
collision animation to be centered
exactly over the enemy that just
collided with the player
inside update method on game class down
here we will handle collision sprites
for each object inside collision array
we will call its update method
and i will pass it delta time because we
want to slow the animation down
if that collision object is marked for
deletion i splice it out of the array
same as we did with particles inside the
draw method i will cycle through all the
collision objects again and i will
trigger draw method on each one
nice we are drawing collisions we are
just drawing the first animation frame
in the sprite sheet
let's go here inside draw method on
collision animation class and animate
frame x
if frame x is more than max frame set
marked for deletion to true
and console collisions array and i can
see that collisions are correctly being
added and removed
i can delete this console log
collision animations are running very
fast we can control their fps frames per
second using delta time delta time is
the difference in milliseconds between
the time stand from this animation frame
and the timestamp from the previous
frame it will be passed as an argument
up here
we will need three helper properties fps
will define frames per second
frame interval will be the amount of
milliseconds that needs to pass before
we serve the next animation frame it
will be one second thousand milliseconds
divided by fps
frame timer will be counting from zero
to frame interval over and over every
time it reaches the value in our frame
interval it will reset back to zero and
it will serve the next animation frame
in our collision animation sprite sheet
so here i say if frame timer is more
than frame interval only then serve the
next horizontal frame and reset frame
timer back to zero so that it can count
again for the next loop
else keep increasing frame timer by
delta time
now collision animations are animating
at 15 frames per second i can also
randomize that fps not sure what that
will look like let's try a random number
between 15 and 25 frames per second
i can make that a larger number
it will be capped at 60fps anyway
i think smaller numbers will look better
since this spreadsheet only has 5 frames
this will make sure they don't disappear
too fast
i will set the initial value for debug
to false so we don't see collision
rectangles on the first page load
you can still view them by entering our
debug mode by pressing the letter d
win condition for this game will be a
time limit we need to get as many score
points as possible within a specific
game time window i want a fast paced fun
game we will store game time in this dot
time variable here on the main game
object when time reaches max time value
the game level is complete for testing
purposes let's set that time to 2000
milliseconds 2 seconds just for now
inside update method we will be
increasing game time by delta time
that's passed as an argument up here
milliseconds between animation frames
will be accumulating in this dot time
variable giving us the total amount of
time that has passed since the game
started
if time from line 33 is more than max
time from line 34 we set game over to
true
we need to declare this game over
property up here when the game over is
true i want to display a scoreboard a
custom message and i want the game to
stop animating down here in animation
loop i say only request the next
animation frame if game over is false
this will make the game freeze and stop
animating when game over happens i could
also have just disabled controls and
have the player running endlessly in the
background you can customize your game
over screen later based on your
preferences
i open uijs and here i want to display
game time and game over messages let's
start with the timer i want the font to
be smaller let's say 80 percent of the
font size we used to draw score
i call fill text and i say time colon
space plus this dot game time
add coordinates 2080. nice we are
drawing game time we will fix this but
first let's also draw a game over
message
if game over is true set text align to
left
i want font size to be double of the
base value
i will have two messages one where the
level is successfully completed and one
for when the player fails to get enough
score points in time this will be the
winning message i will say booyah in
large letters
codiness will be the middle of canvas
so game width times 0.5 and game height
times 0.5 okay i set text align the
center i need to fix this to actually
set font size correctly i need to move
this space from here to here
and the same on line 14.
nice
winning message will have a second line
of text with smaller font size that says
what are creatures of the knight afraid
of you exclamation mark exclamation mark
this message will show up when we win
i change font size to 70
i move the first line up 20 pixels and
the second line down 20 pixels nice so
this is our winning message i want this
message to display if score is more than
5 for example this is just for testing
purposes when we have the whole game
working you can tune it and you can set
game time and the score required to win
the game to different value depending on
how difficult you want your game to be
if game score is more than 5 we display
this message
else meaning game over is true and game
score is less than 5 we display a
different message i will say love at
first bite i like to keep the halloween
theme
the second line will say nope better
luck next time so this is when we fail
the level the tested i give us more game
time so we can get enough score points
10 seconds
nice win condition works well and now
lose condition let's wait
perfect we can also lose if we don't get
enough score points in time we need to
fix game timer it's showing milliseconds
i want it to show seconds so i multiply
it by 0.001 to move the decimal point
from milliseconds to seconds
and i only want to see one decimal space
so build in javascript to fixed method
and i pass it one
we can also highlight the text to make
sure it doesn't blend in with the
background i wrap all the code inside
the draw method on ui class between save
and restore that means all the settings
here will only affect this text i want
to apply canvas shadows and i don't want
them to be applied to players and
enemies canvas shadows are still not
well optimized in firefox so if you
notice lower frame rate i suggest you
don't use them but if you want to know
how to use them it's simple shadow
offset x 2 pixels
shadow offset y 2 pixels shadow color
white
and shadow blur 0.
now our text gets a nice white highlight
we could also achieve the same effect by
drawing the same text twice and the
second one would have 2 pixel horizontal
and 2 pixel vertical offset that would
be more code but it's more performance
efficient than using built-in canvas
shadows let's clean up the code and fix
some small bugs we have here when the
player gets hit i don't want it to be
able to move left and right
when the player is in state 6 left and
right arrow inputs will be disabled
on line 11 in collision animation gs we
are calculating vertical y-coordinate so
this value should be height
in running state we are setting max
frame to six we are missing two frames
max frame should actually be eight
when i'm rolling on the ground and i
press down arrow key player starts
diving and it's causing this weird
movement pattern we are not supposed to
be able to do a dive attack when we are
on the ground we can only switch to
diving state when the player is not on
the ground like this that fixed it
one last small thing is here on line 61
in main.js we don't really need to call
slice method we can just set length of
particles array to max particles value
like this
in the next episode we will add more
bonus features but from this point you
can consider the game complete feel free
to add your own features and run your
own creative coding experiments i'll see
you in the next one
this is a final episode where we quickly
implement some of the bonus features i
showed in the previews we will improve
visuals and clean up our code i will
start by quickly changing background
images just to keep things interesting
you can download the forest background
layers in the video description and i
just replaced them in the assets folder
overriding the city images i backed the
old images up somewhere else on my
computer you can also go to
background.js and adjust speeds of
individual layers sometimes a different
background art looks better when speed
modifiers on the background layers are
adjusted i also changed ground margin on
line 17 in main.js to better fit this
new forest environment since we are
changing visuals let's also change the
font to something nicer you can go to
google phones and choose any font from
there it will all work and it's very
easy to implement let me show you with
creepster because this is a halloween
themed game we are in a scary dark
forest escaping from creatures of the
dark
when you choose your font click select
this style
now i click up here and it will give us
everything we need to use this font on
the web in our web browser game i copy
this link tag you can also select
multiple fonts and they will be
automatically added to the same tag i
will use just one font for now i copy
the link tag and i paste it up here in
index html notice i put it before my
custom style css file because i want the
font to be available when that file
loads then i just take this css rule and
i apply it to canvas element now i can
use this font all over my project and
canvas will draw it i will use it in
uijs for score timer and game over
messages by replacing helvetica with
gripster here i think this looks much
better and you can choose from so many
different google phones to fit the art
style of your game i have other
favorites on here for example a font
called bangers for a really cool comic
book art style i want the player to have
a limited number of lives and i want
those lives to be displayed on screen
each life will be represented by a small
image of dog head you can also use heart
image or something completely different
it's up to you if you want to use the
same image as me you can download it
down below as usual i bring it into the
project here in index.html first
then i hide it with css
i will be drawing the lives here in uijs
so in the constructor i bring the image
into the project like this
i will call it for example this dot
live's image
down here under timer we will draw
player lives i will call draw image and
i pass it the image i want to draw i
want to draw it at coordinates 20 95 and
width and height will be 25 pixels nice
we are drawing it here i created
this.life's property on the main game
object let's start with 5 lives back in
uijs i create a for loop that will run
once for each life and it will draw an
image that represents it
now i'm just drawing five images on top
of each other i need to multiply
horizontal x position times index from
the for loop
actually it will be the width of the
image so 25 pixels times index plus left
margin of 20 pixels perfect now when i
change the value here it changes how
many lives are drawn on screen maybe you
want your game to be easy you can give
the player 15 lives to start with i will
go back to 5 lives in player.js in the
area where we handle collisions when the
player collides with an enemy while not
rolling or diving this animation is
played by setting stage to state 6. we
call that state hit
and at the same time i want to remove
one life so this.game.lives minus minus
after we removed one life we check if
total lives are less or equal to zero
and if they are we set game over to true
i tested by colliding with enemies on
purpose you can see that each time we
collide we lose one life per anime and
when we lose the last life we get game
over screen perfect
i want score numbers to fly from enemies
as we defeat them this can also be used
for other floating messages in our game
i create a new file called floating
messages js
i create a custom class i call for
example floating message and i export it
constructor will expect value of the
floating text starting x and y position
and target x and y position text with
this value will float from this position
to this position and then it will
disappear i convert these values to
class properties as usual
i also create a property i call timer
just to set some simple time limit after
which the messages disappear we will
need update and draw methods as usual
update method will push horizontal
exposition by the difference between
target position and the current position
making it slowly move towards the target
same for the vertical y position
difference between vertical target and
current vertical position
for each loop timer will increase by 1.
when timer is more than 100 we set
marked for deletion to true
draw method will take context as an
argument we set font to 20 pixels
creepster
fill style will be white and fill text
will draw value from line 3 at its
current x and y coordinates now i show
you an alternative to using canvas
shadows for score and timer we are using
canvas shadow properties here we will
achieve the same effect by drawing the
same text twice white first then black
on top of it and we give it two pixels
horizontal and two pixels vertical
offset
we are exporting our new floating
message class
i import it up here on line 3 in player
js
inside check collision method when we
successfully hit an enemy and score
increases i want those score points to
fly from that enemy towards our
scoreboard i say
this.game.floatingmessages
push and i want to use floating message
class to create one new floating message
object first i need to go to main.js and
on the game class i create this floating
messages array
it will be an empty array at first
now i'm pushing a new floating message
into it like this
i check here and i can see that class
constructor expects text value starting
x and y coordinates and target x and y
coordinates value will be plus 1 because
we get one score point we could also
make this value dynamic if every enemy
type gives different amount of score
points starting coordinates will be x
and y of the anime we just collided with
and target x and y will be for example
the top left corner of canvas so
coordinate 0 0.
inside update method on game class the
same way we cycle through all anime
object inside enemies array we will also
cycle through all floating message
objects inside floating messages array
for each message we will trigger its
update method
i delete this splice to remove old
messages because we will do it in a
better way i'll get to it in a minute so
for every floating message object i call
their associated update method i copy
this code block and inside draw i also
call draw method on every message and i
pass it context if i play the game
messages will be moving too fast so
there is no animation i just see the
bottom of the letters here
i need to go to update method and i need
to multiply both of these by 0.03 so i'm
saying here for each animation frame
increase the current vertical and
horizontal position by three percent of
the difference between the target
position and the current position this
will make the text move towards its
target position by three percent of the
distance per animation frame meaning it
will start moving fast and as the
distance between current and target
position gets shorter so it's a smaller
number three percent of that value is
less pixels so it will travel slower and
slower giving us a nice ease out effect
you can see that the movement is faster
at first and it slows down as the
letters float closer to target 0 0
coordinates on canvas
i adjusted the target coordinates i want
them to flow somewhere to the end of
score line maybe these coordinates
yeah let's do 150 and 50.
right now we are creating an ever
increase in floating messages array
because we are not removing the old ones
i will use filter array method to do
that it's better than using splice for a
reason i will explain in a minute built
in array filter method runs a provided
callback function once per each element
in the array array elements which do not
pass the callback function test are
skipped and are not included in the new
array so when i say
this.floatingmessages.filter
and as a callback i say marked for
deletion property on each object needs
to be false the new array will contain
only elements that have marked for
deletion set to false elements that are
set to true will be excluded at the same
time i am assigning this new filtered
array to the original floating messages
array overriding it so this simple line
of code filters out all elements that
have marked for deletion set to true
in the previous episode i mentioned a
pack where i noticed that ground enemies
jump and wiggle horizontally even when
they are supposed to be static it's
especially visible when comparing ground
enemies against the ground texture but
it is actually happening with all
enemies it is because as i cycle through
the array i am removing enemies that
collided with player or moved off screen
using splice problem is that when i
splice out and remove enemy from the
array while i'm in the middle of cycle
and through that array it changes index
of all the following elements in our
case enemy objects because of that their
position is not calculated correctly for
that loop and they jump around instead
of splice i will use filter method and i
will only remove enemies that have
marked for deletion properties set to
true after we finished cycling through
the entire array so there are no
problems with indexes and skipping
positions basically i will do the same
thing for enemies i just did for
floating messages
i will also do the same thing for
particles like this
and finally i also do it for collision
animation objects
now that's better we fixed the bug and i
think this syntax is a bit cleaner as
well
i just quickly can't lock all my object
arrays
i put it inside at enemies so it logs it
only periodically not for every
animation frame i play the game and i
can see that all the arrays are being
correctly filled with objects and those
objects are also being removed perfect
player class doesn't have this dot
current state property because i had to
define it from inside game object
here that property belongs on player
class so i can define it here and
initially i set it to null this is just
to clean up the code will still work the
same
let's tune the game difficulty to make
it a bit more challenging max time will
be 30 000 milliseconds or 30 seconds
in this time the player needs to reach
at least the minimum winning score of 40
to see the winning message we can do
other things for example every time
player gets hit by an enemy and this
animation is played we can remove 5
points from the score as a penalty you
can tune your game however you want you
can make it easier or more difficult by
adjusting these values when the game is
over after 30 seconds i check if score
is more than winning score and if it is
we display winning message else we
display the losing message let's test it
i play it and i get hit over and over my
score is in minus values i get game over
and losing message from line 35 is
displayed nice
i increase game width to 900 pixels i
will keep game height at 500 pixels
because our background images are
optimized for that size we're not gonna
go into aspect ratio calculation in this
class this time i will really try to
play the game and let's see if our
winning condition works i need score
over 40 in 30 seconds
it's actually pretty close
yes i played well i got 55 score points
and when a message is displayed awesome
we are done let me know in the comments
if you code it all the way through and
if you learned something new i'll see
you later
[Music]